foreign
[Music]
chess.com's game review recently got a
major update here are four key notes at
the end of each game review you will now
see a summary of the game from your
coach your performance rating for that
game and a quick grade for you and your
opponent in the opening middle game and
in game we've added a new classification
called Miss for when a move fails to
take advantage of an opportunity but it
is otherwise a sound move we've also
changed the definition of blunder now a
move will only be considered a blunder
if it loses material or allows a
Checkmate coach will now draw arrows and
highlight squares when you hover over or
click on the highlighted words in the
move explanation this should make move
explanations easier to follow finally
coach's explanations will now reference
specific pieces and threads in
explanations making move explanations
much more intuitive the new game review
experience is available on chess dot com
right now
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
land of fjords Majestic mountains Cliffs
and waterfalls
in addition to stunning geography Norway
is home to the greatest chess player who
has ever lived Magnus Carlson
since 2013 Norway has also hosted one of
the strongest chess super tournaments in
the world and it is one for which Magnus
has claimed the top prize in the last
four years
can anyone stop him
this time he'll meet one of his toughest
Challenges ever at his home tournament
with nine Rivals all hungry to beat the
best
from Carlson's fiercest online rival
today in their first classical
over-the-board battle in nearly four
years Hikaru Nakamura
to the young star Carlson once
hand-picked as his most worthy
Championship opponent alireza farrugia
two more young stars are trying to
follow in his footsteps lodibeck Abdul
sotorov and kukesh domaraju
two established stars have already won a
Super tournament in 2023 Anish giri and
Fabiano caruana
two more long time Headliners seek to
take their next turn Atop A major
tournament Wesley so and shakuria
Mahmoud yarov
finally Carlson's Countryman and friend
ariantari rounds out the field who will
come out on top will Carlson run the
table yet again or will someone else
usurp the throne this
is Norway chess
hello and welcome to day two of the
exhilarating Norway chess tournament and
it's a beautiful day here in Stavanger
and the stage is setting up for another
day of fierce competition as the world's
best chess players fight it out get
ready to be captivated by all the action
I'm International Master Ivanka houska
and it is a great pleasure to be here in
the Stavanger Studio alongside the
legendary Grandmaster Judith Polgar and
the man is probably one of the most
knowledgeable Grandmasters around David
Howell now yesterday Judith we had a
dramatic day when we saw Fabiana caruana
defeat Magnus Carlson for the first time
in eight years how will Magnus Carlson
recover from that well this is the
question of the day I believe but this
is not something unusual for Magnus I
think there are plenty of events where
he started in so well and then he
recovered but of course he had a even a
very difficult day on the blitz day as
well but we can't take away the the
greatness of Fabiano he really played
the good game and he outplayed magnets
he certainly did and David were there
any other standout moments for you yeah
uh Ivanka those decisive games between
Fabi and Magnus also alireza and kukash
those stood out but the armageddon's for
me were the most dramatic they really
set the tone we saw some really fast
furious chess and Wesley taking down
Hikaru Nakamura in the Armageddon for me
was the highlight of day one
and talking about day one let's take a
look at the results there were a lot a
lot of exciting games as David mentions
and top of the table we can see that
Fabiana Carolina with that victory in
the classical game does walk away with
three points whereas someone like
Shakura mamadrov who was resplendent in
the Armageddon game and defeated our
antari there just gets one and a half
points and our antari gets one other
exciting results when nordebec Abdul
toroff and Anish giri anything else that
catch your eyes do it
well all the games were really exciting
I also liked the the playoff of uh of
Dari mom Madero I really like that game
to be honest because it was so pure in a
classical game practically mom Madero
did not reach anything but in the play
of it was very nice and for you David
any surprising results yeah actually it
was the Armageddon game that I did
mention between Wesley and Nakamura
because uh Nakamura just looked
untroubled the whole time he was in
control firstly in the classical game
and then in the Armageddon but just as
the clock ticked down the last 30
seconds one minute was crazy pieces were
literally flying on the off the board
and we saw a big reaction from Hikaru so
uh yeah I'm expecting more of the same
today and we couldn't have asked for a
better start and talking about dream
starts we have to mention 17 year old
cash had the perfect start when he
defeated alireza fuja with the black
pieces in the classical game our
reporter svera caught up with him after
it
this must be characterized as the
perfect start winning with black against
aledeza yeah I uh of course this is the
there's a very good start hey
I wanted to be solid today to just get
the blitz of my mind and to start the
tournament in a good mood but okay this
is uh yeah better than I could then I
hoped you said you wanted to be solid
but it looked like even though it was an
equal game for a long time it was a very
exciting game yeah I mean when you're
playing earlier itself because you can
expect that he'll take some risks and
give you chances and
I think the critical mistake was Bishop
B6
I mean he could have played Knight E4
and I'm guessing like black has
something to just uh be slightly better
I shouldn't really be in a lot of
trouble but uh
uh yeah Bishop B6 was just
a serious mistake I think
today was your birthday so this is your
first classical game as a 17 year old is
this the kind of results we can expect
this year
hopefully
I look forward to seeing that how much
confidence does this win give you for
the rest of the tournament
of course it's very uh
very nice to win and
the thing is like every round is a tough
round everybody is super strong so
um
yeah you take one game at a time and
give your best
we look forward to seeing you one game
at a time thank you
very interesting interview there from
the youngster you know pinpointing the
exact moment where alireza farisa went
wrong and was it just me detecting some
emotions there that perhaps he was
over overcome with emotion of defeating
alireza so early on I don't know Ivanka
he just seems so focused so professional
it's as if okay job done tick I've
beaten the first victim it feels like
he's ready to go again today I mean I'm
so impressed just turned 17 uh he
pinpointed the critical moment correctly
he seemed to assess things really well
navigated his way through some chaotic
tactics Judith thoughts on this young
Superstar well I'm very excited to
follow him how things are happening for
him and it was very interesting game
yesterday and some critical moments the
opening was also kind of interesting and
we were discussing about this week porn
on A3 which actually later on it became
a little strong bone but there was a
moment when in move 20 where alireza
missed an opportunity where he could get
great advantage and I'm wondering if
gokish knew about this when he gave the
interior you know because this can be a
little bit unpleasant to get to know
after the game that I completely missed
this opportunity from my opponent's side
and it was interesting very interesting
for me that it was so obvious for him
right after the game that Bishop E6
which was highlighted to capture the
pawn which is the most natural move
right that it was very clear for him
that that was a mistake but it was
really exciting and I'm very much
looking forward for today I certainly
I'm looking forward to that as well and
it was day one yesterday but let's have
a look at the standings and in the early
lead is the Fabiano caruana and could
cash both with three points and there's
a big tie for third place between Anish
giri Wesley says Shakura mamijov who all
won their games in Armageddon and just
take a look at those names though at the
bottom yet to score any points we have
Magnus Carlsen Ninth Place and Ali Reza
farisa both number one and number two in
the world and of course it is day two
and we are in for a treat I'm like a kid
in a candy store when I see the players
who are playing in OHS and Judith what
matches catch your eye
well it's again a very interesting day
I'm very curious about gokash how he's
going to be playing against Hikaru and
I'm also excited very much how Anish
Fabiano game will turn out to be this
day because I think Anish played pretty
well yesterday Fabiano had an amazing
start so how it's going to be heating up
and for you David yeah I'm looking at
the top of those matchups Magnus Carlson
can he bounce back to horrible Days by
his uh own high standards there he's up
against maybe the most solid man in
World Chess right now Wesley so so it's
going to be an uphill battle Magnus
really needs to do something different
try something new and he needs to strike
now otherwise the momentum could
continue yeah I have to have to say that
Magnus is actually running the gauntlet
you know he started off yesterday with
fabiani Carona today it's Wesley so
tomorrow hits Hikaru Nakamura
no easy pairings here I mean this is
Norway a chance very unique tournament
lots of Fighting Chess and that's
primarily because of the format
um we have I don't think it's ever been
done in the world and take a look at
what is in store it's a 10 player single
round ROM it Robin and they have a 120
minutes for the entire game it sounds
like a lot of time it actually isn't
because there is no increment until the
players reach move 40 in which case they
get a 10 second increment per move and
this is where Norway chess is completely
unique because if the players draw
Armageddon will break the tie and of
course Fighting Chess is most certainly
encouraged so no draw offers allowed
before move 30. what do you guys think
of this format
well I believe it's very challenging for
the Players yesterday also Fabi said it
that the time is very tricky in this
tournament and we are going to see a lot
of issues around that because yeah it
seems like 100 20 minutes it's a great
number of minutes for for the whole game
but when it comes to the point where you
have only minutes left in move 38 let's
say then you start thinking oh my God
maybe this game will be 102 moves and I
have very little time to finish that
yeah I love it to be honest uh we really
see the players being pushed to their
limits we saw yesterday farrugia with
what was it 20 seconds to make 10 moves
just pushing them to their physical
capabilities and uh taking them out of
their comfort zone usually at top level
chess we see the players given a
generous extra hour maybe after move 40.
they can take their time but here is
just fast non-stop action and the
players struggling to adapt it's uh led
to really exciting chess so far and
certainly there we can see the players
are getting ready to battle it out on
the chessboard we already have one
player who's again gets seated he is
alireza starting with two whites in a
row here we'll be facing off against
Shakura mamajarov and here it's going to
be a very interesting game because both
players are renowned for their
creativity and this stylish Flair when
they play chess yeah and we shouldn't
forget that farrugia he did extremely
well in the blitz tournament before the
event he was able to pick his number he
picked number one in the seedings
meaning he starts this event with two
whites yesterday losing with white
against gokesh a bit of a shock to him
bit of a wake-up call perhaps and now
again with the white pieces against
mamajorov it's not going to bode well if
ferrugia isn't able to win that one it's
a clash of stars fire versus fire we
will prevail and uh there we see Elsa
Anish giri getting ready to face off
against Fabiano caruana now both Anish
Geary and Fabiana Caron are known for
their opening preparation
what kind of strategy do you think both
these players will be employing because
it's very difficult to Out book your
opponent when they are well known for
that particular skill well I think it's
it's very interesting how the players
are preparing these days because I think
they have several repertoires for
different time control games for example
and and also we shouldn't forget that I
think already now
before starting this game they are also
mentally prepared to play an Armageddon
game afterwards so it's a preparation
immediately for two games in your mind
and of course it's a very high level of
preparation for both players especially
Fabiano he played World Championship
matches also so of course you have a
very different level of preparation
Anish is still not there that he ever
played the world championship match but
his preparation you can see that it's on
the very highest level
and uh what do you think there we see
Wesley against Magnus Carlson and
according to my stats Wesley has only
beaten Magnus once in a classical game
how does one go about facing not only a
former world champion number one rated
in the world but someone you don't
really have a good score against the
good news for Wesley he he's only beaten
Magnus one time in classical chess but
it did happen here in Stavanger in
Norway uh five years ago so maybe
lightning will strike twice especially
if Magnus is feeling over ambitious and
maybe overextends over pushes a bit
later in the game uh it won't be easy
though that one I am predicting an
Armageddon it feels like Magnus just
wants to get on the scoreboard while
Wesley yeah he will lock things down if
he gets an opportunity and as Judith
says maybe Magnus will come prepared
with an extra weapon with white if it
does get that far down to Armageddon
chess but it's a question for me you
know that whether Magnus really in both
mindset is he going to come to today's
game is it something that I'm going to
try everything by any means to win in a
classical game or will it depend how the
opening will turn out and let's say move
20 he looks around and says okay I don't
want to waste my energy I just want to
simplify the position and really go for
the Armageddon do you think he has a
much bigger self-confidence to win an
Armageddon with white yeah none of these
players really lack in self-confidence
but then again
yeah I don't know how you feel Judith
but when I'm not in good form I just
want to get any result by any means
necessary even if it's just a draw even
if it's just something to uh kind of get
back on the right track and we know
Magnus has had a rough couple of days so
as you say it will depend maybe on his
mood a bit later in the game
and there we can see Magnus Carlson
getting ready with the white pieces
against Wesley so
interesting how to regain motivation do
you think Magnus will be feeling more
motivated than ever or
yeah perhaps
I think it's going to be that mix
massively motivated of course he wants
to win he wants to strike and I mean
it's not going to be easily against uh
Wesley of course but then again it's
yeah it's that kind of you're caught in
two minds you want to win but you don't
want to lose and uh which is going to be
heavier the desire to win right now or
the fear of losing a second game in a
row I think once it gets into the head
of Magnus or any player that you're
afraid of losing and that's what you
have in your mind then you're lost
you simply can't have that I think the
most important thing for Magnus also and
whenever you are in such a situation
that can you make yourself Focus only in
the game and get into the flow of the
chess moves and why things are working
not working but really just focusing and
excluding everything potential results
or outcome or what people say what will
be the effect of this whatever no you
just have to exclude every single uh
Vibe around which is outside of the
chessboard
yeah it takes superhuman kind of levels
of focus though to block out all those
emotions and we'll find out if Magnus is
capable of that today it looks like the
players are waiting itching to get ready
the clocks will be started in a moment
by the several ceremonial first move and
it's interesting that these moments it
can be pretty stressful for the players
I must say because of course all players
had their preparations they were
preparing probably for an hour or two
even some players maybe more the day
before also right and then here you're
really few minutes away from the moment
where you're really going to be seeing
if you're prepared on the moves which is
going to be played on the board or you
have to recall something which Fabi said
yesterday right that he was watching
this or looking this line of French
years ago so he had to remember some
things it's kind of stressful moments
yeah and it was interesting to see the
contrast in uh how the players are
approaching these stressful first
moments we saw Anish giri and Fabiano
caruana sharing a joke then we saw
Magnus and Wesley just both Stone Cold
Sirius maybe the nurse jangling and uh
okay it looks like we're about to be off
a lot of the boards now have first moves
on them I'm not sure if the players are
committed to these they are made by uh
friends of no HS by some of the VIPs out
there
so yeah I think we'll see action any
second now Ivanka yeah I absolutely
think that uh I also wonder whether
Magnus will keep that first move
okay it looks like E4 from Magnus
if he keeps that move on the board
sometimes they play jokes at this point
right just to give a heart attack to
their opponent and then put it back and
make another move
okay and Magnus doesn't take the move
back it is one E4 and Wesley very
predictable here he doesn't tend to vary
too much from his standard 1e5 he likes
a solid start to the game
Magnus choosing his main repertoire no
more surprises no more uh kind of
orangutan openings or no more freestyles
there
and we think we'll see a branch of the
Berlin that tends to be what these two
have when they face off against each
other maybe the Italian game as well
where both players have vast experience
I would go for detailing hmm
it's interesting though because Wesley
of course knows a lot about the Italian
and in fact he did a chessable course
where he recommended playing the Italian
but uh how to Outfox your opponent
especially at this level you always feel
like it's a case of small margins and
well Wesley pausing
is he going to surprise us by playing a
petroff
no no no no no no of course not
there we go Knight C6 on the board just
took him a while to write down the move
and yeah Magnus tends to avoid the
Spanish tends to avoid sorry the Italian
against Wesley going for the Spanish
instead the Royal Lopez and it is the
Berlin defense these three
yeah we don't want to see an endgame you
you called it Judith D3 on the board
neither Magnus
yeah so D3 is a sign of ambition from
the white side usually not allowing any
early peace trades and the line with
Bishop takes C6 on the board so this one
will become very strategic white has a
slightly more sound Pawn structure uh
found uh nice foundations there to his
position but black does have the bishop
pair black as well very solid later in
the game but there will be a variety of
plans for each side to choose from uh
White can even decide which side to
Castle black and decide which side to
Castle uh we await the player's plans
Judith much experience in this uh type
of set actually to be honest it is a
kind of a position that I was never too
familiar with because I didn't play it
with either colors and somehow I always
like to play more open more energetic
more concrete lines like open Sicilian
but even in the Rye Lopez somehow this
is why I was kind of stuck a little bit
better to enter against the Berlin into
the end game and then look for something
there or to lay also I tried out these
three but I was not playing it with the
bishop C6 idea I somehow like to keep my
white square Bishop quite a lot and
generally Spanish for me is something
that I don't give up my Bishop bear
yeah and uh okay so this one looks like
it's going to be a quiet game
maneuvering both players very much into
their opening preparation shall we take
a look at the bird's eye view and have a
look at what other openings the players
have been playing and the one that
immediately catches my eye
is the game between alireza farooza and
Shakira mamajarov because these two are
aggressive players
they have a tendency to go for the
others King quite early on what do you
think
can we dive in Wow Let's dive into that
game uh Ivanka and already a extremely
ambitious line extremely ambitious
opening play from both sides we know
that alarisa wants to attack with white
he's switched away from his customary
one E4 and this is the position it's a
line of the Queen's Gambit accepted for
a trendy line that's happened a lot
recently but let's do a quick recap from
move one we're just at move six here the
game started with one D4 black reply to
D5 and the Queen's Gambit was gratefully
accepted by uh mama jarov and after E4
E5 Knight F3 a bishop check the very
trendy modern move Knight to C3 in the
past this check used to be blocked in
different ways and now Knight to F6 a
Gambit line giving back the pawn level
material now but black strikes with B5
and uh this is just crazy I've looked at
this a bit myself and then I gave up on
it that's black just uh there is a
threat against this white Pawn due to a
pin on the white king black is very
quick to Castle but then again white has
a beautiful Pawn Center that has just
been supported by alaris's last move F3
wow keeping the center intact student
well it's very interesting this F3
because I've never seen something like
this before the last move B5 was very
important for black to protect this Pawn
on C4 at the same time also stuffed
grenade for a possibility checks and but
it's very much like mamajaro of having
after what move seven or something it's
so typical that it's already complicated
they're endless of opportunities for
both at first I would think that after
F3 white is going to be playing Black
Castle now to play Bishop E3 maybe even
long Castle or leave it in the in the
middle of the Border by the gang I can
easily imagine that G4 will shown up on
the board after some developing move
and this game is not going to be boring
this I can't guarantee I think
this will give a lot of fun I I I think
so and that's the name of the game right
but um I'm just also looking at the
opening database I can see this position
has been reached just three times
so it's a little bit murky territory for
um Mama jarov um there in two games
white actually played a fourth
destabilizing the queen side and then in
the last game white did Play Bishop E3
your suggestion
and uh how strong would those players
play in the games Ivanka were these
heavyweight Grandmasters as well to me
it looks like the line that you don't
try at home you only go here if you've
studied hundreds of hours deep Theory uh
in this position with an engine yeah
actually quite uh it's been a favorite I
say favorite just that's a very generous
word of yanchist of Duda he's paid it
twice in 2023 uh first time he beat
Maxim vashilograph and then the second
time he drew against Anish giri
some pedigree it's basically a who's who
of World Chess playing this position it
is also a big question whether it was a
blitz or Rapid or classical game because
you can have a different taste for
different town controls what kind of
openings you play right actually it was
played just now in the super bet Poland
so it was a rapid orbit Blitz game
yeah I remember actually watching that
one and uh yeah it led to some chaotic
positions as you can kind of predict
from this imbalance to pawn structure so
early in the game and okay no A4 no
Bishop E3 first uh alarisa just pushes
his Pawn one square kicking back blacks
Bishop to A5 black of course doesn't
want to part uh with this bishop he
doesn't want to break the pin this can
be an important uh move to include A3
Bishop A5 because now once white goes
Bishop G5 for example there is going to
be possibly an unpleasant pin but we see
A4 so there is a completely other idea
behind the A3 for alireza and going off
from the board so he seems like he has
his home preparation there and I think
there's a couple of points behind this
uh inclusion let's just jump in and show
a couple of variations it's about to get
crazy this position uh White has just
played A4 and the whole idea behind
tricking the black Bishop to A5 is that
black can no longer play B4 himself
because Knight takes C4 would now hit uh
okay the evaluation bar drops now A4
would now hit this bishop and uh at
least this is one concept either now or
on the next moves The Bishop's
undefended and uh I guess the benefit
for black however is that you are now
capable potentially of playing the move
A6 because this a file has been blocked
so it's kind of pros and cons after 8xb5
8xb5 here you are no longer winning this
black Rook on A8 so this inclusion kind
of might have some benefits for white
might have some drawbacks as well
interesting decision there from alarisa
this being the current position I'm
assuming he's going to try and back up
his Pawn chain either with A6 or C6
because if the black pawn is full then
Black's Position will be pretty much
busted long term
I wonder whether this bishop on A5 how
it will be playing in the later part of
the game to be honest because somehow it
belongs to the A3 f8 diagonal somehow to
be in B4 there you go back Bishop D6 or
Bishop E7 right
or supporting possibility of playing C5
so somehow it does not belong to A5 to
me
yeah just a weird position in general
right very weird
very weird it wouldn't be it wouldn't be
surprising to me if my major plays a
move like C5 it does look like his style
but I guess right now the question would
be whether white can just take that pawn
and uh yeah this is crazy black of
course wants to get to the white king
while it's in the center but for now
white has some measure of safety it
looks like he's played a move on the
camera there
and it is
well this is the most logical one if you
think for the reason uh what you said
that Bishop A5 is blocking uh
the Rooks power
so it is very easily can be played A6
and 8x B5 now
yeah very quickly after a takes B5 white
has to move out probably with the bishop
because Bishop C3 is a threat
immediately grabbing The Rook on A1
so it's a question Bishop E3 or Bishop
G5 I would
think
well we can move the king yes I was just
thinking about it to go King F2 which
was quite tempting with Bishop C3 anyway
yeah there is some possible problems
good yeah is it strange to see my major
off pause and think now it looks like an
automatic recapture on B5
will happen
okay uh perhaps okay a takes B5 hasn't
on the board that was my analysis my bad
sorry there uh A6 and farrugia is the
first one to be thinking right and this
was the question I mean you guys just
assumed that he would be playing Pawn
takes pawn and is there any Merit to
actually just keeping that tension there
and maybe just continuing with your
development of the pieces yeah
definitely I was showing porn takes
pointers what not to do so I was very
surprised when I thought he'd played it
but of course Borussia knows better and
I think you'll write Ivanka uh probably
one of the bishop moves that you've been
highlighting there Judith Bishop E3
looks sensible backing up the pawn
Center if you want to be really
ambitious a nasty pin potentially at the
same time maybe white does not want to
make a decision on where to put the
bishop yet so it should be doing short
castle if short Castle is the plan in
the long term for Fairuza then it is
easily Bishop E2 castle and only in a
much later stage to decide where to
receive on Bishop will be developing
yeah well an exciting game ahead if we
can take a look at the bird's eye view
because there are other fantastic games
I'm sure or can't wait for this one I
always get so excited when I think about
the players that are actually competing
in OHS I mean it's so rare to have a
tournament where you have like the best
players in the world and then the best
Juniors who are incidentally the best
players as well and
um yeah let's zoom out and uh Ivanka my
eye has been caught by one game uh let's
drop out of this one and go out I think
to Harry and Harry against nordebec
Abdul satorov because some crazy some
very strange stuff has been happening
and we need some explanation and uh
let's go in this is ariantari with white
nordebec Abdul sotorov with black one of
the players of 2023 so far Abdul sotorov
won the blitz tournament here in Norway
chess won the chesky cup last week lost
to anishigiri yesterday in the
Armageddon but a man in form in general
and uh this is the position after C4
from white but we have to explain how
the black Rook ended up on G8 I have no
idea I'm just wondering non-stop since
you pulled up that that will be the next
position which we want to look at I mean
this is something that I mean the first
thing comes to mind that somehow uh
black touched the Rock by chance
something similar and definitely I would
bet on that at least 80 percent that
it's that's the case otherwise I have no
explanation
is this fish a random Chester that I
don't I don't know but hang on a sec
isn't this kind of the thing that fisher
would do on occasion you know put the
Rook on G8 just but normally and then go
G5 yes okay but then fish around them
usually you have a complete random
placement of pieces and then you're
working the first few moves to get the
normal position but here it seems like
something the opposite is can we go back
from the beginning because I'm just
still under a shock why that Rook
happens to be on G8 I think we have to
go back to the beginning Judith let's
backtrack action replay of this game
from move one uh White played E4 it was
the Sicilian Defense and a branch of the
rossolibo in this position black played
D6 something that Abdus had success with
he played this in the chess kid Cup last
week and uh after castles Bishop D7
still no more stuff so fast this is the
familiar to me
very normal logical move Theory and here
Judith something's happen Rook G8 well I
can tell you
it's not a novelty it is a novelty
I'm sorry I couldn't resist playing with
you guys
it is a novelty no one's done it before
completely new
I mean this is exactly it shows that if
we would check the engine probably it
would be in the top three moves that's
why you're seeing this
I don't know maybe you have to go
further down that means such a weird
move we should explain I mean definitely
don't try this to anyone at home causes
your king get your Bishop out you know
what don't try this at home play G5
immediately
this one would make more sense at least
you're going on the attack and uh that
that comes in the Armageddon I think
exactly I I think I've actually seen
this in an Armageddon between Magnus
Carson and uh Hikaru Nakamura black
played G5 but the problem is white can
strike in the center with D4 and after
G4 this is a theoretical line with D5 uh
White counter attacks and after some
fireworks the game dies down a bit we
see a position like this where black
struggles to whip up an attack and uh
the black king in the center maybe the
more vulnerable of the two so he's
trying to test this explain me if you go
back to Rook G8
I understand I'm trying to digest it if
you go D4
which looks very natural well I'm an old
timer so what can you expect from me I
play a logical move of D4 Knight D4
still some how the Castle link will be
so easy yeah it's cram Nick style that
uh try to Castle it's old-fashioned
stuff
I mean but this is typical uh Sicilian
idea you forge a square on E5 for your
knight you stop white pushing upon to a
few Generation stuff oh I definitely
don't recommend it I don't like it but
with the king in the center but we've
seen ideas in the Sicilian of this
happening in some nidor G5 amazing wow
it's like super provocative and bearing
in mind that REM you know has a very
strong Grandmaster but he is the lowest
rated player in the tournament and
someone who ideally nordebec actually
wants to beat in the classical game I
mean
bearing in mind the scoring system isn't
it warranted that he takes some risk
I think it is uh it makes a lot of sense
to take risk of win with black here is
almost Priceless especially in the
classical uh let's just catch up with
the current position uh quickly white
play D3 keeping an eye on this G5 Square
uh it's quite as covered twice so black
of course just plays H6 slow and steady
wins the race be consistent but this
novelty cannot have come as a surprise
to Ariane because Jude B4
what is this B4 he must have prepared
this tarry this must have been on his
radar
these guys come from another planet I
see yeah Pawn sacrifice here if you take
this Pawn with your knight I guess the
idea is to build a very strong Pawn
Center C3 gains a bit of time now you
build a center with your pawns and this
does look slightly scary for black uh
still it is a pawn instead Abdus tour of
took it in the other direction and after
A3 it's very much like a benko Gambit
white just trying to open lines on the
flank for his pieces and uh black says
okay no I don't want to take your Pawn I
don't want to be a pawn up please take
me back and white says no I insist on
being a pawn down pull into C4 yeah this
I mean this is kind of a psychological
battle I I'm not sure B takes A3
grabbing the bomb was not better or just
leaving it there
but this must be open in preparation
they've used about 10 minutes each or
close enough to 10 minutes each
so it means Rook J it has to be a top
three computer move it must be engine
that's the only reason why you just
flash out before
I've been playing this opening for years
with white shooter I've never once
bothered to check with the computer hang
on wait one second okay I'm going to put
it there on the computer and I'm gonna
see I am going to see is it a top engine
move
um
let's have a look let's have a look I
would be shocked now if G5 doesn't
happen it just feels like you've kind of
committed uh you have massive commitment
issues if you play root G8 and then
don't play G5 essentially and and you
play H6 and you play H6 wasting all the
time in the world
this B4 idea
is definitely a computer suggestion it
has been seen before but black was the
first to kind of launch the novelty but
you're right both of you are all right
Rick g8's top move of the computer
wow wow
amazing stuff
these guys they're so well kind of
booked up they've studied everything
under the sun I don't know how they have
free time I don't know when they ever
relax they're just studying openings all
the time Rook G8 impressive and imagine
new computers just happy to keep kings
in the center like this going against
all conventional chess wisdom it's all
about the attack all about the
opponent's king but if you think about
it I mean imagine what kind of
recognition and respect engines went
through in the last 15 years let's say
yeah I remember when I was in like 2002
or whatever a year
still when you were seeing suggestion
wrong like Rook G8 you were like I mean
really I mean you have to be you have to
be in a good mood to take it seriously
it must be a glitch in The Matrix and
nowadays
okay Rook Jade and within a second they
start looking analyzing ah maybe there
is something interesting around it let's
check it a little bit right and of
course the next movie is B4 what else to
analyze there is nothing to analyze
other than that right
so it just really became an event in a
very different way of playing it it's
simply the player's mind go on a very
different roads yeah I missed the days
of Fritz three when you didn't need to
trust it
stockfish 15 has ruined everything
well this is certainly a quirky game and
we look forward to catching for that
later but
a look at
this game because he is facing off with
the black pieces against goo cash our
youngest participant who got off to such
a perfect start yesterday anchor cash is
a very tactical player I can't really
love to see these type of battles when
you have the new Young Challengers
taking on the old God
yeah Clash of generations and Hikaru
just like after storm will be determined
to win with black against a under well I
was going to say underrated low rated
rival kukesh definitely not underrated
here and Hikaru is playing his second
black game right so after this his uh
he's gonna be okay with colors
yeah and uh starting with black here
it's another Queen's Gambit accepted uh
by transposition this time and uh it's
early days here still a very tense
position and uh maybe we do what we
always do just go back to the beginning
and see how we got to this position so
uh let's backtrack here we started the
game with D4 D5 uh queensborn opening
the Queen's Gambit was declined
temporarily by uh Nakamura uh playing a
very kind of solid opening setup every
time a player is happy with a solid
position now they seem to go for this
tarash type of setup white played E3
keeping the tension very ambitious from
white as well and after a few Night
Moves A3 black took on C4 so this is the
transposition to the Queenstown Gambit
accepted black is arguing that the White
Knight might not be so well placed on
see-through necessarily uh White has
also spent a Tempo on A3 which you
wouldn't normally see in that opening
and after a few more moves we saw black
extend on the queen side and uh White
develop but this is a bit strange to
meet you that white played Rook E1 and
because I was wondering that I'm not
playing this with the or even I never
played it with either color maybe no I
think I didn't play it but we need to
somehow seems more logical at first
right rookie one is
yeah I guess there's some pressure on
this Pawn right I've always played it
with Queen E2 and then Rook D1
yeah so the big question is go cash here
if you'd played Queen E2 maybe grab a
pawn maybe black could cash in on the D4
Square you can take three times here as
black and you're pulling up white has
compensation though you've got to think
uh with the black king in the center it
feels like there might be some tactics
The Rook slide uh indirectly hitting the
queen and some tactics with taking on B5
but maybe good question just didn't want
to enter these Waters well and probably
it's all Theory and in G4 or yeah in G4
Bishop B G should be fine oh but uh just
take it
yes it does I mean it's just begging to
be played right yeah but it's the kind
of tactic certainly one has to be aware
of and have stored in your memory banks
yeah what he did in the game though
feels a bit clumsy go cash maybe he
needed to do this maybe it's still
preparation he's uh only spent about
seven minutes on the clock uh here in
this position he played Rook E1 Quincy
now Queen E2 because the black queen is
not eyeing up this D4 Pawn anymore and
after Rook d8 Rook D1 so he's lost a
whole Tempo with the white Rook rookie
one two moves later Rook D1
it's not what you want it's the same
time it doesn't seem to be that right
but
this is also not going to be a boring
game that's for sure yeah and you get
the impression it's a waiting game now
Nakamura would love to move his bishop
and get castled but as soon as he moves
his Bishop white will take on C5 the
bishop will have to move again and the
Tempe has balanced out blacks yeah then
it's a very nice position for white
right playing B4 and then Bishop B2 Rook
C1 and everything is set for a great
attack from the long diagonal for the
bishop D3 Bishop very powerful yeah
and we have to remind ourselves that
yesterday Hikaru came off an Armageddon
lost one of the craziest armageddon's
losses I actually seen in all long time
pieces flying and now he's facing gukash
who of course won against farugia in the
classical game and today the Press
caught up with him and uh let's hear
what Hikaru had to say about this game
Hikaru do you think it's easier or more
difficult to play agukesh that came off
a good win yesterday
um I don't think it really matters
perhaps we'll be more confident more
aggressive after winning the first game
but I think in general most of us at
this level were pretty well prepared so
don't expect to be too surprising but
again it should be an interesting game
even though Armageddon points aren't too
big does it still leave a sour taste in
your mouth to have lost that game
yesterday
um not really I mean I think that when
you look at the amount of times you play
against these players over and over
again sometimes you win some sometimes
you lose some and uh considering that in
the church chairman store I won every
tiebreaker against Wesley and probably I
shouldn't have I mean yes he has to win
one sooner or later and also for him I
think it's more important that he wins
the one here because it matters for
qualifying for the candidates so it all
evens out and um maybe if I lose a few
more weekends then I'll feel worse about
it but right now it's not that big of a
deal I look forward to the matchup today
thank you
sorry they're being very pragmatic about
what happened yesterday in that
Armageddon it's kind of almost saying
that it was a Karma you know he's gotten
away with a few bad games
against Wesley you know it's about time
Wesley got
his own Victory
um yeah sorry but I I believe that he
thinks this way you know I think he he
he has an incredible good balance
to in his mindset also that he gives
everything in but whatever happens
happens and moves on to the next one
yeah it's a really healthy approach
right and I know that's something that I
struggled with when I was younger I know
that a lot of young players they kind of
struggle to recover from losses or at
least until this current generation and
Nakamura showing that yeah he can bounce
back and he's very much in the moment
he's focused on today no point looking
to the past it was only half a point in
the end
difference between winning and losing in
the Armageddon and Wesley's a strong
player nonetheless so
um yeah I think that's going to help him
kind of post a good tournament
performance just if he can maintain that
kind of calm exterior he was looking
really positive here it's nice to see
and uh okay a couple of moves he has
traded on D4 in the center and Bishop B7
getting ready to Castle
actually I thought maybe before the
tournament he'd be one of the favorites
Magnus of course one of the favorites
and day one's changed everything I would
say the opening Blitz really set the
tone because I I think in one of his
streams Hikaru was saying you know I'm
not probably not going to play Magnus
Carlson very early on in the tournament
because you know we'll both finish in
the top half in the opening Blitz and
then you know we'll meet each other
towards the end and then we had a
situation where Hikaru finished six
Magnus finish Sabbath
ah now they play each other tomorrow
yeah no easy games in this tournament
and Nakamura is away from the board uh
showing already kind of positive body
language until this last porn capture I
was having a bit of deja vu and I was
thinking where have I seen this before
and then I thought okay Hikaru had this
exact opening against ding in the final
game of the candidates when ding beat
Nakamura to overtake him finish second
and later qualify for the World
Championship match so um up until this
change
yeah you remember it Judith I remember
very well I was commentating it myself
too that that was quite a game I think
yeah that one the Queens came off but it
was a symmetrical Pawn structure and he
outplayed Nakamura later in the game
this what do you think about this
position I mean
it seems like great for black great
development
yeah putting pressure on D4
before coming sometimes
for the moment I just want to cast the
control over the D5 square or d8 Rook is
greatly placed Knight on C6 attacking on
D4 B7 Bishop is already there I mean
usually an isolated phone you're three
times back compared to this one I know
where one of the Tempe disappeared
disappeared with this white brick you're
right if if you get one more move uh I
think Nakamura will be loving life
but how does go cash strike in the
meantime one move before black castles
yeah it
adjusts any aggressive move other than
just developing your pieces and say like
you just do the normal stuff develop the
dark Square Bishop line The Rook on to
C1 I mean
it looks like a great iqp as we say but
is it anything more than just kind of
like maintaining the balance is black
actually better
it's too early to say I guess whether
Black's better but Black's happy yeah at
least that's the first step when you're
black in any opening the first step is
to equalize and only later uh try to
kind of claim an advantage outplay the
opponent and hit there's sufficient
imbalances if white doesn't get an
attack uh you may be using those moves
that you suggested Ivanka then long-term
big weakness we mentioned it yesterday
in the game between Abdul satorov and
Gary Gary had the upper hand for most of
their classical battle because White had
this isolated pawn and wasn't able to
generate any direct attack
um so yeah it does look like an opening
success for Hikaru Nakamura and slightly
strange because it feels like kukesh
must have prepared this position or must
have prepared this line with kind of
that strange Rook dance on E1 and D1 but
you had to make anything of it
um before we move on Judith you
mentioned the candidates you commentated
there I just want to thank you I owe you
a debt because I joined a few days
commentary there and I was so inspired
by commentating with you into the
attacking ideas that are in the Olympiad
I was feeling so Rusty but I decided
okay let's just attack everyone and yeah
helps me get that gold medal I'm very
happy if I I gave some inspirational
attacking yeah
I was going in thinking oh what to do
and I thought oh that's just
commentating with Judah I might as well
just attract every on them it worked out
well so good memories from that
tournament have you ever had any moments
of inspiration just like David's
highlighted where you you've seen a game
or you've just been inspired by a film
or whatever
um well some games yeah of course I
liked some very artistic games like Spar
of the Apollo for example when the
palace Kings was going yeah yeah
I don't remember exactly when I was
inspired and something I was really able
to get out of it as profit out of that
inspiration but generally I I always
like to be inspired by beautiful games
beautiful ideas unexpected Solutions on
the board so those are good oh cool
yeah no I you certainly are an
inspiration to us all I've also looked
at your attacks
I thought whoa you should be playing I
must say that now next year it's going
to be 10 years that I retired and
sometimes I give coaching and mentoring
Hungarian youngsters or others and
sometimes I wonder wow this was really a
good game do you ever feel the call of
the board just saying dude dude it
get back there and start playing not
really but when I was for example
playing badly in some event and and I
got lost in my resources of ideas or I
got down and there were time to time
occasions when I picked up my own game I
just to boost myself and and understand
that no you're a great player so make
some nice games of minor but I was very
proud of to give some energy and
self-confidence yeah that's a great tip
actually you know you just think back to
your positive moments I think it works
actually with most of the people if you
if you go down it's just important to
gain back the basic self-confidence
yeah and uh just we while we wait for
kokesh to come up with an answer here to
come up with a move let's zoom out and
there's only one game that we haven't
touched upon so far Let's uh just for
the sake of completeness go there and
that is the game between uh Anish giri
and Fabiano caruana uh two players who
did win their matches yesterday Carolina
in the classical and Gary in the
Armageddon and uh that one is
interesting to me for multiple reasons
I'll explain in a minute and uh let's
just check in on that position and maybe
do a quick recap of the opening still
early days there uh we're at move 13 in
their game but a very theoretical battle
in the nimso Indian defense and it is
this position let's go back to move one
and see how we got here this position
white is a pawn up but doubled C Pawns
of course and uh it started with the
nimso as mentioned and now the F3
variation and this is interesting to me
because fabi's played this multiple
times himself but also because the first
time I ever studied this opening was
using a chess 24 video course by sopico
garamish Villi Anish guri's wife and I
remember basing a lot of my opening
notes off her videos there and I thought
oh Anish must have approved them as well
and now curiously enough he gets pretty
much the exact same position that I was
studying in that course maybe what was
it five six years ago and so black
played D5 here fighting for the center
A3 one of the main lines black Parts
with the bishop pair and uh here have
you had this opening before this
variation Judith
play this with black and I was very
happy to play this with black it's a
very interesting system because White's
first whatever number of moves this pawn
moves right and actually in the next
move he even takes an extra Pawn
and
and it was I always find it very
interesting but I was kind of happy to
play it with black because the double
Pawn on the C5 C3 and C5 is like
um it's there and you cannot really take
on C3 because then you regret it because
the diagonals open up so much Queen they
do Bishop B2 and that's definitely
something that you prefer to play it
from the white side
so black does not take on C3 at all
but goes back with the Knight to E7
yeah
and later on black is just having a good
compensation with having this weird bone
structure for white with the bishop pair
I mean okay you have a bishop pair but
what is this bishop on E3 doing so much
right or Bishop on B5 it's it's not
clear how you can take a real power out
of your Bishop pair and later on black
in some way or another plans to play B6
Knight D7 B6 or something black tries to
exchange the white square bishop and
many times the one of the Black Knight
gets to C4 or something controls very
important y squares and then there is a
great compensation for black so this is
the the question whether black can
really get out with his pieces and
simplify it with B6
yeah I totally agree and hey I guess
there's two different ways of
approaching it either you kind of go
directly for this Pawn maybe with a move
like Knight D7 uh maybe Knight A5 or
another idea I remember looking at in
this type of position was to play E5
just to try to dominate this White
Knight on E2 but uh this comes with pros
and cons but you know that there is a
line somewhere that you play E5 and you
think you stop Knight D4 and then you
get an id4 in the next move
I'm not sure it's exactly here but I
know that there is a position like this
that ah E5 you stop Knight D foreign
yeah why not exactly why not it's not
hating it
and just to show look how powerful these
pawns are I think it was was it Anand
who came up with this idea I don't
remember but I remember that it's so
frustrating if you play it with black
and you think you stop your opponent
from something and then they just
suddenly White's porn structure is the
most beautiful thing you'll ever see it
was in Ruins a moment ago at the cost of
a night you've got the best pawns in the
world and yeah Steamroller The opponent
yeah about a difference of bone
structure now in the move before right
yeah so uh maybe Fabi was just uh too
afraid of this he hasn't chosen E5
instead he's played it's like you said
Knight A5 I like it very much and many
times it's actually the best move and
after that Bishop D7 trying to to get
rid of the white square Bishop really
focusing later for the C4 or D3
Square
yeah so and this type of positions
it would be a mistake for white to
actually just capture the Bishops
instead you have to maintain the tension
for as long as possible
by just continuing development yes
you're right then exactly now yesterday
we were talking about who keeps
detention yeah this is exactly another
type of tension in the in the opening or
such a position that you cannot take you
shouldn't even consider to take on D7 to
exchange the Bishops right because you
your opponent will develop by taking it
back with the Knight so here instead of
taking you have to keep the tension but
how to keep the tension are you going to
be playing A4 so can you do that and
after take spawn takes Knight C4 Queen
C1 or are you ready to go back with the
bishop to D3
I mean this should be very good for
black I think so either you come back or
or what do you do I'm sure there are
some ideas like Knight D4 maybe instead
of Bishop D3 oh yeah yeah I mean for
example black can start going so very
nice yeah
white has it blown up
kind of a reasonable nice position at
the same time within one or two moves it
can be very risky for white also
yeah and uh and each chooses to advance
his Queen uh now asking a few questions
I think I've flipped it before yeah I'm
trying to recall it's been so many years
but I think in that course by anisha's
wife by sofiko there uh this position
was mentioned and now the idea if black
plays Knight A6 for example white pretty
much has to take this Knight and
if black gets time for a move like Rook
B8 black is doing fantastic
fantastically well but you do have 10th
white Play Bishop F4 ah you have Bishop
F4 and if this is blocked five takes you
take yeah and it's important that you
deflect The Black Queen away and here
white is two pawns up uh with a big
Advantage well that two Pawn is not
really two points is it I mean who's the
worst here I'm in Bishop B6 then Rook C8
I I grab immediately one back sure maybe
I'll be greedy at some point and take
this one later but I have a nice Square
for the night I guess uh yeah it's still
hard to evaluate to be honest this type
of position but I think I would take
quite just feels like less risk even if
you win all the pawns back
and maybe we'll see this happen dude
yeah
[Music]
yeah before I think I
think I heard of our games on this
Knight C6 and now white goes Queen A4
and kind of white wants to provoke A6
and A6 is something probably not really
good for black because after that B6
will be not possible practically for
rest of the game so you have to keep
your Pawn on uh yeah maybe even taking
or maybe bishop D3 or Knight E5 is very
strong after that right yeah probably
just capturing and then and then the V6
square is really very very big weakness
for black right you can put a piece
there or maybe you can just bring
forward with uh the Knight take away
some squares yeah but it looks good for
white it looks unpleasant for black
definitely and it looks like we're on
these paths Knight C6 has been played
Let's uh allow Anish to demonstrate that
opening theory he spent a bit of time so
maybe just uh trying to recall what his
notes say here it feels like a position
that has been studied or has been played
before but
still in the balance just one slip from
either side and strategically it's uh
really dangerous actually uh one slip
and you might be suffering long term
from positional weaknesses so yeah let's
maybe leave this one for now let's Zoom
back out and so many games so much
action what to do next
I mean I think the action is just a
beginning and I think this is time for a
quick break but before we go into the
break I mean let's talk about this
amazing opportunity that is gonna be
coming your way because chess.com are
hiring if you are passionate about Chess
then this is the perfect job opportunity
for you do you love following chess.com
events and want to join their team are
you a passionate chess fan with
experience in organizing events and
tournaments you might be exactly who
we're looking for to come on board as an
events coordinator use x-clamp apply in
chat or go to go.chess.com forward slash
events underscore coordinator underscore
apply to submit your application now
and well that's an incredible
opportunity to join the chess.com family
and it's time for a quick break but
don't go too far because we will be back
with some more of the thrilling action
don't go away see you soon
foreign
I've been using it for a long time I
mean if you look up here I actually have
my streak it says
1231 days right you're gonna forget a
lot of the things that are in the book
Jessica came around when I got
unjustable it's literally I was already
doing that so this is now a game changer
because I can do it faster it's online
it's in front of me all of my books are
here if they're gonna be folders now so
I can categorize my white black and all
tactics in game but I literally have
everything in one area as you see I'm
scrolling here this is what I like this
so they're like how many adjustable
books you got I'm like all of them how I
use stressable is actually I do a lot
for the opening training I do tactics on
here I do calculation I do in-game I do
everything but the database all my
training on here all the time adjustable
is the wave this is why I like to use
stressable it actually helped me I
remember even online I was only like
tapping out at 23.50 almost 2400 and and
Blitz and bullet my chest com is 26 with
a high of 27.74 bullet and I blame all
of this if like success really it's just
working on chessable just being honest
with you
[Music]
foreign
what's the best way to follow any chess
event from the Champions chess tour to
the candidates speed chess championship
title Tuesday feed a world championship
and so much more chess.com events has
all of the top chess tournaments played
both over the board and online
analyze and review games from the
world's greatest players with live
commentary cloud analysis opening
Explorer and table bases find all the
key event information including
schedules prizes results news reports
player bios tie breaks and more
even compete by voting for your
predicted results
explorechess.com events today on web or
with our IOS and Android apps and
experience chess like never before
welcome to check with mace the only
podcast by chess pieces for chess pieces
I'm a rook and I'm a pawn let me ask you
this you ever feel like you're
undervalued absolutely everyone's like
oh pawns they can only move one square
they can't go backwards new we don't
want to go backwards you know maybe
we're focused on the future yeah I feel
that sometimes I wonder why we're even
protecting a king he wasn't elected
through a democratic process maybe I
want to be king dude I think about that
every day yeah okay real quick shout out
to our sponsor hellofresh I don't use
them because I'm a chess piece but I'm
sure they're great
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
and we are back after that short break
and all that chess excitement is
awaiting us and there we can see the
players in deep focus and the players
pacing some of them are away from the
board it's all very thrilling stuff I'm
International Master Ivanka houska and
I'm here with everyone's favorite Judith
poger and everyone's other favorite
Grandmaster and commentator David Howell
yeah it's good to be back and uh the
players they're deep in thought it's
that face of the game Judith where you
know they finally slowed down after the
opening finally coming to terms getting
to grips with the positions
well basically now is the moment when
you have to deal with the position you
got
whether you like it or not you either
want to recover from that or or you're
ready to fight it out the way it is and
you're happy and content with that
position because I think it probably
depends on Verizon the different players
who who can be happy with their position
or what was a surprise for them okay
well on that subject should we do go
through the bird's eye view and guess
who's happy and who is unhappy
and by that basically I just mean who
got the kind of position that they want
you know it's the in accordance with
their Style
yeah I think in the first game we see
that on the left we see Magnus Carlson
with white against Wesley so I think
neither player is really happy it's a
bit of a maneuvering game but at the
same time they might be happy later on
if they are the one initiating the
action I believe that Magnus must be
happy basically things went the way he
he decided to go right he was expecting
E5
he decided to go with these three Bishop
C6 I think he's happy and he can grind
away chip away at Wesley 100 moved right
exactly he's in his element
maybe I'm biased I just wouldn't be
wanting to sit there okay it's actually
probably Wesley's also happy I mean he
this is his reperto or he's playing that
so so he found two happy guys that's
true okay and what about okay in the
board next to them Ari antari in order
back at this Turf but I think if of the
center of laser Rook G8 H6 G5 he must be
happy
and what about let's put ourselves in
ariane's shoes you know you're facing a
very talented teenager and he comes at
you with this which you happen to have
an idea against
happy or if it were me personally I
would be unhappy because black is the
one attacking me or the white king might
get checkmated oh I wouldn't be happy at
all but I know Ariane a bit and uh his
style he actually thrives in Dynamic
positions uh he doesn't get them as
often as he likes because often people
try to shut him down uh kind of when
he's playing open tournaments for
example but a different challenge
against these bigger guys and he'll be
relishing that challenge oh okay
so uh okay let's move along to the
Middle where we see 17 year old cash
it's so difficult to believe he's just
17. he's such a wise HUD uh Nakamura
I'm not sure good question is so happy
yeah I'm not sure either I think we
found happy because he's just a young
kid who plays incredibly well amazing
and started a one out of one but at this
opening I'm not so sure he could not
imagine to get something better than
this
yeah I think Hikaru is happy
Hikaru he looked happy in the interview
but that was before the game true true
nothing's gone too wrong so far so let's
assume that hikara is Happy uh before
the break we talked about Anish gorilla
Fabiana karwana
equally happy in that one
equally unhappy I think Fabi Fabi is
very happy
well he's not there
[Laughter]
wherever he is he's got a smile on his
face happily walking around
yeah and uh the final game that we do
see on the right there alireza farouza
against Shakira mamajarov
crazy game who's the happier of the two
well my major always just feels very
comfortable with its home court when
it's messy
um I think firoza is also kind of uh
must be happy with the healthy position
but I'm reading
reader body language you know the fact
that alirez is not there
and uh I'm looking at Shaq's body
language
it looks tense to me but it's his move
yeah I understand that but you know
normally when you're like super happy
you're relaxed you chill you're kind of
like
it just
you you just look happy is what I'm
trying to say he looks like he's like
okay I have to survive I have to find
the best moves right now and get into
the flow
yeah and uh he has been spending a lot
of time on the clock Shack Greer
normally he plays quite quickly in the
openings he's normally got a few things
worked out especially with black wear
his repertoires may be more predictable
than it is with white and uh where
should we jump in it looks like two
games have developed kind of uh in very
exciting directions since we were last
there it's either the game between Aryan
tari and uh notibeck or this game that
we uh we're just talking about with Shaq
not necessarily on the attack but uh
sorry first okay because there is some
interesting exchanges happened over
there and we can say that probably
another black is happy because he spent
only 15 minutes up to this point so
probably there was no big surprises for
him it's just that he had this very
unique and special plan played out with
Rook G8 H6 G5 G4 so there was not much
to think about right how to react the
only big question and decision to be
made for him was but after B4 takes A3
whether to accept the the pawn sacrifice
or push it B3 as he did so this was the
only big question after this moment for
him
and interestingly enough Torres spent
already nearly 40 minutes
not a good sign for tarry especially if
he was the one who was ready for rookie
eight and he was the one who launched
the pawn sacrifice with B4 uh he
probably thought that okay that's the
top computer move I prepared an idea for
suddenly his opponent has gone deeper
is that okay blackplate G5 G4 Knight G4
Rook stands now extremely well on G8 I
would be extremely happy to have this
idea and play it out myself but uh in
reality how good is this right Knight G4
what is Black's next move it can be
Knight G5 and somehow to occupy the D4
square with the Knight so there is a
huge decision to be made by tari I think
whether how do you develop your pieces
because this is some of the most
difficult things when you get to a
position which is absolutely not
familiar you don't know exactly where
are the pieces has to be standing to to
comfort you in this position right
are you leaving your Bishop on C1 you
develop Knight C3 first is your knight
better standing on D2 supporting and
protecting the F3 Knight or the F3
Square are you ready to go Bishop B2 to
control that long diagonal most
importantly D4 Square which is extremely
sensitive or what he played right he
just played the D4 control the center
take away the E5 Square from the Knight
is there any concrete tactical idea for
black I don't know whether E5 is
possible I was I was thinking E5
and
I'm sure there'll be but before
anyway I'm sorry Ariane has played a
very natural move of taking the Santa
but um I'm sure people at home will be
wondering isn't there a pawn up for
grabs on B7 why not grab that
yeah let's uh jump in and try and figure
out why Aaron didn't get tempted to take
that pawn on the last move uh if he had
been greedy and taken on B7 first it
feels like the Queen's getting trapped
certainly does yeah you're not grabbing
but I think Rook B8 comes and after
Queen A6 Bishop G7 attacking The Rook so
some material damage yeah I just wanted
to highlight that Ah that's a good spot
uh Ivanka I was puzzled I was like okay
it looks too ugly to sideline the White
Queen but I didn't see a specific reason
and well these kind of poisoned pawns
you don't even dare to not to eat it but
to look at them they look tasty don't
make eye contact they don't tempt you
you know that it's poisoned yeah just to
show the point this Rook is attacked
only one way to save it but uh suddenly
the Knight next to it is lost so you've
uh yeah you've just weakened all your
pieces all your pawns uh yeah everything
drops essentially uh so let's go back
really good point there and Tactical
really aware D4 I'm looking in two
directions you have both mentioned E5
black fighting for the center very
logical I was also trying to figure out
how to get my queen down here to
Checkmate your king somehow you know I
had an idea for that I mean A5 and queen
H5 that's one option but the other one
is more tricky to have the queen on C7
and have some tricky ideas to play D5
and that's some tactics with Knight D4 I
had I had another one but it was based
on E5
and then Queen H4 after yeah but the
problem is the queen does swing across
the G3 yeah but then you have a
fantastic uh
yeah
the question is whether Knight F3 is
possible yeah maybe white just drops
back so stopping Checkmate on this
square the square is protected and it's
just one check looks scary as anything
but
material is material white is a piece up
right now
yeah but I think this type of ideas in
the air for sure if not uh right now I
mean for example black could just take
this note back and uh just pose the
question what to do against this threat
next move uh Queen coming out four yeah
maybe it's uh just about fine for white
here which by four cover any checkmates
down this diagonal yeah you're not quite
ready for that I mean somehow it feels
like black has to build
after all black is trying to whip on up
an attack with not that many pieces
well this game is something that you
cannot play by routine by just general
feeling that okay I put my pieces here
or there you really have to be very much
aware of what you're doing
I like this one too your first instinct
here Queen A5 just uh threatens some
tricks this Rook is only defended once
try and pretend you're taking on the
Square and uh in Blitz I would play this
without a hesitation but I'm not sure
even after Queen H5 we don't have
exactly immediately an attack so but
there are plenty of ideas I believe for
black and it has to be considered by
Abdu satirov either way Aaron I like his
last move d4 very principled and uh just
gaining some space he's not afraid of
being attacked with white that's my
worst nightmare being attacked when I
have the white pieces I want to be the
one attacking but uh yeah a very tense
position should we zoom out and see some
other developments absolutely because we
know we were talking about the happiness
factor in chess and we
did mention and it looks like not that
much has changed in the other games but
we did mention that someone who could
potentially be dissatisfied with their
position would be uh young cash who is
facing off against Hikaru Nakamura
and
if we had that because it was quite a
tense isolated Queen's Pawn position
yep it was the 10th position we thought
that hikara was the happier of the two
and openly he's quite familiar with
kakash having played some strange Rook
Maneuvers losing a bit of time and uh
he's only played one move since we were
last here he's played A4 just provoking
the pawn forward interesting it feels
like he's losing some key squares here
good cash but at least he's forced
tekaru into the tank big decision now
yeah and one thing about Hikaru is that
actually about Norway and chess in
general is that there is something
called the confessional Booth where the
players can go in and they can confess
their thoughts and someone one of these
players actually went into that Booth
wow
and told us reveal to us all what they
were thinking in fact it was the man
himself kikaru so we should have that up
shortly where we can listen to his
thoughts but in the meantime let's have
a look at this game Let's deep take a
deep dive
yep so A4 on the board and black has to
decide how to deal with this tension
either you push forward or you capture
this Pawn on A4 and uh Hikaru needs to
decide he wants that square ideally for
the Black Knight I think that's why uh
kokesh is trying to provoke the black
pawn forward in which case he'll happily
jump into the center and the tension
continues
um to be honest dude I think black has a
variety of for attempting and very
pleasant options right now
yeah and do you want to hear what Hikaru
thinks yes because we have it ready
before Martha
well I decided to come back everyone and
the reason I did is because my opponent
is still thinking so I'm feeling pretty
good about the situation because clearly
both of us I think are out of
preparation now I was also thinking
about these isolated Pond structures and
you know there were a couple other games
that come to mind because I remember
when I was much younger I used to
dislike isolated politicians
specifically where I had it I remember
there's this game I played in the US
championship and I think it was 2000 it
was the year before I won so it probably
would have been the 2003 us Championship
um against Nick deferman I had the white
piece it was a nimso Indian with um this
whole I played E3 Knight ge2 I believe
it was
um and I got this isolated Pawn on D4
and I remember after playing that game I
just didn't really like the isolated
Palm positions for white now in more
recent times I mean I've gotten used to
playing with it but I think you know it
can cut both ways that's also why I'm
pretty happy even if perhaps according
to computers my position might be a
little bit shaky I mean the fact that
goo catches thingy sort of tells me that
he's out of his preparation probably
it's not the top computer line in terms
of what I played with isolated pawn it
can get double edged and if there is a
perfect play then I I might get some
chances potentially to even when the
gamer puts some pressure on him down the
road
um so I thought that's what I was
thinking about a little bit more
um
and and so I think it's just just pretty
normal I was looking at some of the
other games actually and it's it's kind
of crazy to see notorbeck going all in
against tari actually because in that
game I mean noted about losses this
difficult match yesterday specifically
in the Armageddon game where the C5 move
which would have probably won in the
game so he's on one point he's trying to
go all of the black pieces so there's
some interesting stuff most games look
pretty standard so far all the players
are pretty much doing what you would
expect Madden is trying to grind down
Wesley in this um in this Berlin with
Bishop takes C6 now I don't really like
Magnus position and Wesley having played
so many times you know the way that
Wesley likes to play he's got the bishop
pair if Magnus doesn't get something
pretty quickly going on I think there's
some chances that Wesley might get might
might actually out of being better in
that game so that's definitely one to
watch
um what else is there there's there's
Fabiano's game against somebody who is
Fabiano playing he is um
which looks like some theoretical battle
as we know Fabiano the only way that he
wins games of Chess is when it's
preparation without prep I mean Fabian
is just never winning of course
everybody knows what I'm alluding to
when I say that uh so nothing too crazy
um but I guess so far it's it's pretty
pretty standard we're in this period I
think where most of the games are gonna
hit this lull maybe Notre packs game
against Tara will be different but most
games is like next 20 30 minutes you
should probably go out do something
useful and then come back and watch
games once things heat up so I think
next 20 30 minutes in most games can be
very stable very dry maybe Ali Reza's
game could get interesting but again
probably players will use a lot of time
before before blitzing out moves now is
a good time to take your station break
go do other things and come back when
the action really heats up
yeah
wow there you have it Hikaru giving us
thoughts on his game but also commenting
on the other players games as well he
wants our jobs we might as well just go
home let Hikaru commentate while he
plays I must admit that took me by
surprise I wasn't expecting that it's so
nice to see you though thank you Hikaru
for providing that entertainment to us
not just looking at all the other games
today but also commentating on all the
games yesterday as well
Judy you were loving it yeah I was
absolutely amazed how much Hikaru is
taking care of the audience and just
make sure that if anybody is hesitating
to stay with us or not he's suggesting
that the caves are going to be boring
for now so do other things I believe
from my point of view don't leave us
because the games are very interesting
and great fun
he did backtrack a little bit and he
says oh well maybe maybe hang around for
farisha
game is messy oh yeah yeah that was but
he said he's happy
he's happy he's happy he's very happy
because that's well yeah yeah and his
first instinct was pattern recognition
he was alluding to several games of his
own past to yeah to draw on inspiration
for this but he gave away the
information that he's okay to play
isolated Bones from Whiteside yeah true
repeating a lot of secret info there
yeah looking forward for more uh
confessional boost comments it should be
compulsory every player like every five
moves has to come in and reveal their
and they can't lie I like this you know
if they had to answer one question was
it preparation and they have to go yes
but you know I'm winging it you know I
was wondering that is it for some
players it's a relief that they go into
the confessional Booth so they give out
their energy which they have too much at
the game does it help them for example
for Hikaru did he really do it for
because okay why not if we have it or or
I really want to share it with my
audience or over the audience that I'm
happy to say that this or that my own
opinion about my game or others or it
just gives more energy that okay I go
there I talk I I go out of the game a
little bit and then I go back and focus
a reflex on the character
right because I mean there's some people
people CaRu Magnus they're entertainers
at heart you know they want to tell us
their thoughts and there are other other
people who I would count myself if I
went and did a confessional and then I'd
be thinking to myself
my goodness me
say
so I I couldn't do it that would be a
big distraction for me
yeah I mean maybe it's just part of his
routine he plays hundreds of Blitz Games
while talking every single day so it's
just maybe just getting in the right
mindset for him like you say Judith just
kind of zooming out and it's part of his
nature now uh as I said there in the
featured chat Hikaru is a content
creator through and through through and
uh why not be true to yourself and yeah
it's better to get it out the way now
rather than in a Time scramble go off
and confess something
yeah still looking very balanced on the
board
so what's going on on the board in his
game because uh he's not sitting at the
word
but he gave the entertaining to us why
is he so happy right here he played the
B4 and there was an exchange with the
Knight on e4 right so now I would be
considering uh
black snacks move to be Knight A5
actually even something that could be
considered without castling
so the question is for white is he going
to play D5
or just developing Bishop G5 for example
yeah some tactics in there uh let's jump
in with some variations uh just to try
and get to the root of what's going
through Kakashi's mind right now why is
Hikaru so happy potentially and uh you
mentioned some of those moves dude if
white just plays a nothing move uh the
reason Knight A5 is so good is because
you're trading off White's strongest
piece white best minor piece right now
this active bishop and every exchange
helps black because of this isolated
Queen's Pawn the iqp and uh yeah now as
well you're blockading you're covering
the D5 square sufficiently and if I
can't advance and the possible Knight B3
right it's hanging right there in there
which is not very pleasant for white for
sure not pleasant at all so time is of
the essence the first move I guess we
would calculate just because it's so
forcing so Direct that's how we should
structure our thoughts is D5 and it does
blow up in the center I guess black will
capture
at the same time yeah first of all I
would want to take that and after D5 we
can say definitely the black has an
advantage in development right because
look at the A1 Rook C1 Bishop
and I remember reading a middle game
book by Max irva where he talks about
these type of positions and he says you
know you have to judge them by
development and take a look at this
what's uh David's highlighted the pieces
that are the problem ones the bishop on
The Rook they're just not out there and
I feel like black is the one with the
slight Advantage there yeah you could uh
still make an argument and make a case
for Knight A5 you can make a cake for
case for Bishop F6 just stare down the
long diagonal and what about like Knight
to D4 I mean do you even have these
tactics tactics Knight to D4 yep just uh
if this Knight is captured for example
then you win the bishop in the center of
the board so a trade and black has the
bishop pair now looks like a very
healthy position so I don't think D5 too
attractive in this specific situation
watch out for it to happen next okay and
uh Bishop G5 I was about to say maybe
but might just lead to some trades in
the end of kokesh deciding on Bishop to
E3 right yeah he wants to line up The
Rook to C1 to eye up the queen and I
definitely think Knight G5 is something
you really have to be aware of later on
because in our eyes to the right that
are some Bishops pointing at the age
seven square
you know after Bishop E3 I would
consider maybe F5
I know it's double-edged because you
give away the E5 Square for the knight
at the same time probably black is
forcing divide Bishop to
aperture maybe on C6 maybe it's too
early to play F5
and risky yeah
yeah here at least you would be able to
kind of form this battery plant the
queen on D5 in some lines uh but like
you say it's very risky I guess there
would be questions such as what happens
if the bishop drops back are you going
to continue advancing
this is I was thinking to go Knight A5
and open up the diagonal for the bishop
but then probably Knight E5
well I see there was a movement yes and
it was your instinct yeah of course
Knight A5 is the the obvious move but he
played it very quickly
it's been calculating he's he's foreseen
this position
he's 20 minutes down on the clock
actually Nakamura uh it's from the
confessional I assumed that he would be
ahead on the clock uh he mentioned cash
was deep thinking but yeah right now the
Bishops are staring off against each
other and if they disappear then
Nakamura is going to be loving that end
game loving any uh exchanges that do
happen so what happens if Rook ac1 it's
a logical dampy yeah let's jump back in
Rook ac1 hitting the black queen
and uh I guess the queen will move I
don't want to get hit any longer so I'm
going to go back to a safe ish Square
not ideal but could be it
how does white continue Queen on B8 is a
little bit away from
things happening could you do moves like
okay night Bishop Bishop to G5
if I take you Ivanka oh I'm gonna take
on H7 and I hope that it works
yeah it looks scary especially if I drop
back you might just come and check maybe
yeah and you will win here but the
problem might be if I March forward I
know I know I know in G6 and and
unfortunately
oh sorry not that squat King G6 maybe H6
is better I don't know but King G6 Queen
G4 F5 yes now this queen does a job from
afar you can't step back yeah G3 yeah
and a great gift sacrifice not quite
working but definitely on the radar it's
certainly on the radar
um but okay I mean these are the kind of
ideas that both sides will have to be
calculating and yeah it makes sense to
throw in this move Judah I think you're
right it just has to happen Rook C1 and
uh it feels like you gain a move for
free forcing The Black Queen back but
the question is what next
uh I mean could you just drop this
bishop back it feels a bit awkward feels
a bit clumsy but it's come back to B1
come back to B1 at least you've lined up
stuffer later along this diagonal maybe
um well and for now you cannot play
Knight B3 because of Queen D3 right the
double attack
spawn hit this Knight game over
but uh yeah at the same time if Hikaru
in that type of position uh let's put it
on the board one last time if he just I
don't know plants a bishop on D5 I've
just realized I'm dropping this Pawn
I'll pretend I saw that one uh but let's
say I play a move like this one it's
white really checkmating the black king
if not then black is maybe a bit better
yeah
this idea coming in just going to swap
Brooks at the right moment trade off
those Rooks
well at first I would pick black
it feels easier at least
I mean I'm saying if you don't get
checkmated that's a big uh it's a big if
but
yeah stability car is quite good in
these types of positions uh
traditionally
he's a he's a great defender I mean
we've seen that time and time again he
gets himself into a very difficult
position and he manages to wriggle out
like no other I think I would say that
he's one of the world's best defenders
yep I totally agree especially in
speeches but in general uh he used to be
one of the world's best attackers when
he was a kid right you know he had the
nickname you know the age bomb or
whatever and you know he was so
aggressive and then he actually said
that he made a big leap from being like
a very strong Grandmaster to Super Grand
Master just by honing his defensive
skills
we have Rook C1 and queen B8 on the
board on the board I do like this bishop
B1 I I I do think that that is a good
decision keep all the pieces on the
board
and
that was a quite an exciting game I
think it's about time to take a breather
take a few minutes just to you know
refill our Cups of Tea or cups of coffee
or cups of solo
and uh there we see Hikaru also drinking
but uh yeah
we are going to hit the pause button and
let the excitement of Norway chess will
continue in a few minutes see you after
the break
foreign
[Music]
there either Rook C7 a7's falling uh it
is E4 he pushes the pawn this is getting
a little messy takes a knight F1
[Music]
Knight takes G3
oh my God that was and instead he played
here in general oh my God A7 wins for
white oh my gosh
[Music]
your subscription makes shows like this
possible which is why our twitch
subscribers will never see ads on
chess.com
connectyourchess.com account and Twitch
account at go.chess.com connect accounts
and bang boom voila you're done 100 AD
free Bliss forevermore whether you're
following our events on site or on
stream type the command connect in the
chat and thank you for helping bring
these shows to life
Grand Masters can lose 10 pounds and
burn 6 000 calories just by sitting yeah
so I've actually been spending a lot of
time getting in shape wow that's great
what are you doing mostly like Rook
lifts oh I've never heard of that it's a
thing don't look it up
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
ER City Center but it's certainly not
the case in the tournament playing hall
because they're the players are fighting
it out furiously look at them all sat
there pacing thinking hard Fabiana
caruana in the zone wondering what to do
but there's all action on some of the
boards yeah we saw the Ducks outside in
Stavanger but who is going to quack
first on the board that's the big
question it's very tense there some
crazy positions as we've seen so far
Judith oh absolutely we are having
incredible interesting things happening
on the chessboard are we going to tari
first to see yeah I mean one of the
games which is developing quite
interesting I know when we last left at
black cutter work on an open Line had
played very unconventional way and has
set a cheap trick that I think Ariane
more than spotted
yeah crazy opening we've mentioned it a
few times with a novelty as early as
move seven from Abdus playing the really
controversial Rook G8 but it looks like
that was justified by the opening of the
G file some attacking chances against
the white king long term now and just to
recap the last couple of moves that have
happened let's do a bit of an action
replay uh it was in this position that
we last left it after the move d4 black
played Queen A5 very natural but as we
see here there is a question mark
attached to this move so not the best
move not necessarily losing anything not
a huge blunder but not the best there's
some ideas against this Rook on E1 for
example if Whitehead missed the Trap
then Knight takes D4 would have been a
winning tactic luring away distracting
this White Knight and the white Rook
would have dropped of course Aryan
spotted this Knight C3 a nice block and
this is the current position I'm
expecting uh the tricks to continue a
move like Queen to H5 and again
threatening the deflection tactic Knight
takes D4 and if white misses it again
just to show Queen H2 would end up in a
nasty Checkmate but of course white is
going to spot this Ariane he's on high
alert right now very Vigilant and queen
H5 can be met with a variety of uh
responses as long as you protect this
Pawn or cover the H2 Square uh Judah you
mentioned uh in the break there to me
that maybe the white Bishop being on
this diagonal could be important
I guess uh yeah what I had in mind that
Bishop F4 can be something important to
cover the H2 square but now there are
several uh Alternatives maybe actually
Knight E2 can be the move in order to
protect the D4 Pawn while also thinking
about chasing away the queen from H5
yeah so it looks like white does have
everything under control for now black
playing for those cheap tricks playing
for the attack but uh let's uh see how
the players get on in this really fiery
double-edged position and definitely and
uh David you did mention that Aryan is
on high alert as he is watching out for
all those tactical tricks and
opportunities and Ariane himself also
went to the confessional Booth so let's
hear more from Aryan in his own words
very interesting position in my game I
just played D4 uh honestly I have no no
idea what's what's going on uh should be
should be unclear
um yeah I've only I only looks at Bishop
takes G4 but uh yeah it's just a very
unclear position very hard to assess uh
uh yeah I think it's hard to play for
for both sides but uh
my king is can be weak but uh at the
same time I have some chances in the
center so
uh it's gonna be gonna be an exciting
game I think
what I love about that interview oh that
not even an interview confessional Booth
it's just like he seems so chill yeah
you know unclear I have no idea what's
going on but uh come see compsa it is
what it is
think we can all relate to that right I
mean every time I sit down at the
chessboard I have no idea what's going
on especially positions like this one
and also if you I mean it was just this
one fleeting comment he said oh I've
only looked at Bishop takes G4 so only
two moves ago he was still in his
preparation and actually until just two
moves ago he hadn't spent any time at
all now he's spent uh what is it 55
minutes on the clock just in his last
couple of moves so uh interesting just
novelty on move seven but he looked
deeper and uh yeah really tense kind of
resulting position we have now
Judith who would you pick you're the
attacker among us this is a good
question who I would pick to be honest
because I think it can easily be the
case that within few moves that we have
a position where black is having a very
difficult position because white has a
very strong scent Theory the pawns on
c4d4 e44 right and they really control
most of the important squares the only
thing white should really be careful on
the Tactical side of the game
and after Queen H5 I think it's a big
question where they're really an id2
stops everything and all hopes for black
or uh or queen goes to G6 maybe I'm not
sure about this plan of Queen A5 at all
even though I suggested it myself also
as consideration but the white could
basically white was forced to develop
his pieces right or piece knight from B1
to C3 which was already very much needed
for the development of white
and the black king will stuck there
basically it's probably still the safest
place to stay on E8 and to cast so long
because after that Rook B1 can be very
powerful in Knight D5
so black has to decide how to move on to
play E5 possibly forcing matters in the
center but then the D5 square is very
vulnerable I was going to just say that
white is perhaps threatening to put the
Knight into D5 anyhow
and it just looks like it's
it's action time for black it looks to
me that if black doesn't have something
very fast he can get in trouble
yeah it feels like white has a lot of
easy moves you mentioned Knight D5
Ivanka I mean if I get a free move I
might play the bishop D2 just to ask
questions of your queen I might play
Rook B1 just looks useful long term in
general uh what does black do that could
potentially be useful not to Beck now uh
long think we see he's been thinking
almost eight minutes and uh should we
jump in I mean the move that comes to my
mind I'm not sure why but is to just put
pressure on this weak spot on D4 I want
to play Bishop to G7
yeah but after Bishop G server you block
the power of your Rook right and after
this uh yeah it's a question how to move
on root D1 is an option but also I would
maybe considered to play E5
my king now
to sacrifice a pawn and after takes
maybe to go
D5
and if I jump in I'm a bit scared here
that you're going to do nasty things uh
maybe I I blunder something after Knight
D4 because the even Rook will be under
attack but Knight D4 Queen B7 wow it
gets crazy right yeah some some
something is messy here Let's ignore the
evaluation by its hating our analysis
but it's a crazy position it's uh wild
right now and even the eval border yet
to decide what's really happening yeah
the black king under huge pressure I I
just saw a comment there from chat which
recommended
Knight takes porn
as being the move for black and I was
like
hello
what kind of what kind of move is that
and I did turn on the engine and okay
Top Choice according to this engine is
just to go Bishop G7 and then after and
then the second choice is Knight takes
porn
I don't get it well the idea I guess
Knight D4 takes and queen C5
right
but even if I is there something else
Bishop E3 yeah I can defend here but
this is the weird thing it says the idea
is actually just to develop the pieces
makes no sense to
yeah this is crazy stuff maybe the ideas
like you say develop the pieces Bishop
G7 you've got it's not only developing
the pieces the idea is that Rook D1 is
not possible because takes on D4 and
queen E5 yeah right
so there is some concrete
elements and just like that everything
is revealed this is the beauty of
computers this is the beauty of these uh
young modern talents as well they're so
concrete and Bishop G7
we're just looking for kind of
developing moves improving moves they're
just looking tactics calculation tactics
calculation if he plays Knight takes D4
that will be incredible and let's
actually try and find a way for white to
survive there because in that variation
we showed black was the one winning this
Knight is under Fire how do we defend it
well this is where it says again you
counter-attack well no you give away
pieces you just go E5 I mean it's just
crazy this
and if I take on E5 is the idea to take
this bishop yes yeah it must be this is
crazy giving up the white Rook but
you've eliminated a strong black
attacker and now white is able to slide
back with the Knight guard against the
Checkmate threat on H2 and the material
balance here is uh two pieces for a rook
and two pawns so roughly level but white
does have more pieces and if there's no
attack maybe White's minor pieces will
decide the game later
actually I can imagine easily that
another back will take on day four
But It's Tricky and back it up with
Bishop G7 well you have what I mentioned
before that if you just play moves with
black and white consolidating himself
develops the pieces Rook B1 defending
the D4 pawn it has he has such a strong
power in the center that what is black
going to do with the king I mean you
don't you don't really know what to to
play for right so black has to be alert
and to think of something concrete yeah
it's a cliche but it might be now or
never in terms of action like you say
Judith but I have a question what do you
play on Bishop G7 now
very good question
because now ah but through E1 you cannot
take on D4 because the E4 Pawn will be
an extra yeah as you take with the Rook
right take with the rook and the
difference yeah exactly as you say same
position but uh White has this one to
spare compared to the previous variation
so yeah move orders it's so tricky they
say tactics if they don't work in one
order like Bishop G7 doesn't work there
then you flip the order and sometimes
they do work that way but to spot Knight
takes D4 first takes I mean incredible
imagination it takes discipline to sit
there and calculate and uh yeah it also
takes great judgment
I I think as a sucker move I think
Knight takes porn is easy to find
because you are looking naturally at
those kind of decoy sacrifices but then
just to calmly follow that up with
Bishop G7
that's something special
and if y does not see this opportunity
which is there is a very good chance
that he doesn't you imagine you get
Knight D4 and you're just like like what
happened
I would like it if I'm playing another
game or what what's going on I would
just love it if it happened whilst that
REM was taking a drink I was like whoa
yeah I'd have to fight the urge to
resign if my opponent played a move like
1964 first instinct is pure panic but
that's the difference between classical
and Blitz just Blitz chess you panic and
you just lose on the spot after like
1964 but in classical you sit there by
process of elimination you find a way to
survive as white and the game goes on
and uh yeah I want to hear him in the
professional now Ariane has he spotted
Knight takes D4 that's the big question
but it doesn't just because there is an
idea an ID for with black objectively I
I'm not sure uh black can be happy at
all
but maybe in the position in general he
can't be happy objectively
and I guess it's then just a question of
kind of picking your poison picking
among several evils do you suffer slowly
with no kind of tricks no tactics or do
you kind of gamble that your opponent
gets kind of tricked and gets confused
in the Tactical Minefield yeah probably
if not if Hikaru is let's say passing by
mm-hmm if you see a move like this you
definitely want to go to the
confessionables and share it with
everybody there 94 opportunity and
Bishop G7 what
going on tell the world and uh yeah well
we're gonna leave everyone on a
cliffhanger here because uh an order
back in deep thoughts working out how to
continue and let's revisit the bird's
eye view because we need to show some
attention to some of the other games and
I'm you know Hikari actually passed
judgment and quite a few but he gave us
a nice little Roundup of every single
game in his confessional and he there he
also mentioned that Wesley should be
feeling happy with his position
yeah maybe we go to that game we haven't
been there since the opening of The
Clash between former world champion
Magnus Carlson and Wesley so and uh yeah
that one is still very slow in terms of
maneuvering there's a nice pretty porn
structure that I want to point out in a
moment but just very tense only that one
piece uh trade the white light Square
Bishop in the Spanish training itself
off on C6 and
after that just pure maneuvering for the
last 15 moves uh really really tense
stuff and uh who do we prefer here Judy
you mentioned you tend to be biased
towards keeping the lights going Bishop
but now Magnus has made this decision do
you think it's paid off
I don't know
eventually for sure I want to push F4
this this would be my my my real uh plan
for white and activate the pieces but it
has a it is a very interesting bone
structure what we see all the white
bones are on white squares beautifully
shaped right like a nice mountain or I
don't know how to call it but definitely
D4 or F4 will come in the next within
two three moves I'm pretty sure about
that
um I don't know if black will ever play
B5 and try to make some something out
there on the queen side
yeah his last move was B6 however so for
the moment yes that's for a later stage
I believe if black plays B5 may be only
in an end game let's say if they ever
get there yeah that's true just to
create an outside passport potentially
or at least create something for the
Bishops uh to bite on and that tends to
be the classical wisdom normally against
Bishop pairs you try to accelerate the
play Magnus is played extremely slowly
but at some point he has to go for D4 or
F4 because otherwise white is just
cramped
and it is his move it feels like he's
just picking between the two which Pawn
structure does he want I think I would
be impatient in such a position
eventually I I just I probably would
play some active move like f1d4 before
time
no somehow this is the feeling I have
in a way you're just going to kind of
close your eyes uh kind of toss a coin
and just pick one of them at 44 because
they both look equally viable they both
change the pawn structure it's just
about who that favors you can't say that
who is really better I mean or I I don't
have a feeling for it in this position
that
which way to go am I going to play King
H2 working H1 do I make space for my
knight playing Rook G1 Knight F1 it
doesn't seem right
somehow I have too many pieces on the d
e and f file having my bones on D3 and
F3 so I just simply don't have space
that's the thing it's double edged here
you want to break forward to give your
piece of space but at the same time your
opponent has Bishops if you open it too
much could backfire long term in a
difficult position you and I was looking
at the board in front of me I
accidentally peeked at the computer and
it's not a flashy line but I thought
dude that you might appreciate its
second choice G4 G4
I mean just lock it down
um yeah F4 I think is quite natural I
also like you would be tempted by that
move I would never even consider G4 I'm
not very good at these type of Pawn
pushes G4 to be honest I'm not surprised
kind of because I would be happy to give
a little air to my pieces and it's no
danger for my king because it's a close
position right at the same time
sometimes H5 can appear after G4
but after G4 I would be a little bit
scared to play F4 later on because then
already that's a completely different
right but I mean
if you do keep the position completely
locked with G4
and then the whole idea is you know step
forward with the King
H5 is it such a dangerous move
it might not be so dangerous maybe we
just bring up a board and we delve into
some of the Maneuvers here
um it has to take us taking a slower
Pace this game but uh yeah Magnus could
really liven things up G4 it could
proceed a positional type of attack G4
as you say Judith firstly you have to
weigh up H5 and potentially after the
move from Knight to G3 you have to kind
of figure out who this uh will favor
potential opening of the H file maybe it
favors white if you can kind of get the
Rook there or maybe it favors black if
black does the same King F7 Rook h8 yeah
but the thing is I'm not sure that white
is happy to have Knight on G3 because
after that Knight F4 can be unpleasant
right because you you practically don't
want to take and exchange the Bishop
from E3 for a night right
yeah some danger here tactically as well
a lot lots a lot of challenges forward
especially after Bishop so maybe this is
also a reason why B6 is a nice move
right Bishop C5 can show up yeah knowing
Wesley he spotted this type of thing
already his sense of danger uh very
alert but uh yeah I guess the question
is if white doesn't want to go for
Knight G3 Knight F5 ideas because you
give away the square then
do you really kind of slow play it do
you have time the luxury to play King H2
Rook G1
I don't know what next uh sometimes you
can get away with this type of Pawn
storm with the Kings on opposite sides
but here it feels a bit strange
that's true actually I mean concrete
says if you are meeting G4 with H5 can
you not just take that pawn
just take it just take it and uh well
we'll be done with the consequences and
then you know after Bishop takes Pawn
you just take the Knight and check
mating ideas
and then King are now King H2
or maybe yeah black king yes yeah
makes a lot of sense it's kind of nobody
wants to touch the king side really so
white might as well gain space actually
I was not sure at all whether I would
like to go H5 immediately I would maybe
go back with the Knight to f8 to our E7
and then later on keep this in mind
right
I guess white plays King H2 there's two
the same one yeah at least hints that
later yeah Bishop F7 Knight E6 keep all
those Pawn breaks open
well black can also go G5
I think only you can play G4
be my guest
and I will mention G4 has been the theme
of the tournament so far we've seen it
many surprising uh on many surprising
occasions in all sorts of openings
yesterday and in the blitz tournament we
saw Mama jarov unleash G4 in his
Armageddon against Harry yeah it's a
typical idea actually in these types of
close balance oh because that was going
to bring me on to my next question so I
I just stumbled upon it when I when I
looked at the computer here
but um how realistic is it I mean how in
keeping with magnus's style is it to
play a move like G4 when you you know
every other move that he's played on the
board seems to be lining up D4 F4
yeah it depends on his mood uh what's
likely happening in magnus's mind right
now is that he's looking at F4 D4 he's
not seeing any advantage there or he's
thinking the position opens up and it
doesn't really harm Black's chances uh
maybe doesn't improve White's chances at
all so then he'll start looking for
Alternatives he'll start thinking okay
as Judith mentioned King H1 or King H2
not clear where the king wants to go
how else to improve the position and
eventually he'll stumble across G4 and
he'll think okay there's no downside so
uh Magnus he's missed ambitious when he
gets an opportunity he does like to step
forward I've seen him play G4 in other
okay not this type not this exact
position of course but in other
anti-berlains with this structure
and it depends on his mood I think
essentially we see magnus's body
language not really positive right now
kind of head in hands but yeah if he
decides it's time to go for it not that
much risk involved then we might well
see G4 on the board
yeah I've spent way too many hours of my
life I've wasted too many hours in my
life studying these kind of closed
anti-berlin structures because I've
played this opening as black all my life
and the problem is everything according
to the computer is 0.0 so when you study
plants it's so hard to pick uh and even
if Magnus had looked at this type of
Pawn structure in the past it's still so
hard to kind of settle and decide on
what to do next and uh just it was a
quite an interesting moment there from
Magnus because there earlier on we just
saw him like it looked like he was
completely dejected and then suddenly
he's sitting up like he's had a
conversation with himself and said come
on Magnus
there's like Norwegian expression called
sharp deck it just basically means
sharpen up Shape Up shape up and I was
kind of curious I mean when you guys
have a bad position or you kind of feel
yourself unmotivated during a game what
did you tell yourself in order to kind
of get back into that flow
I don't think now it's a problem of to
get back onto flow or Magnus I think
simply the problem is he doesn't see why
he's better
but to to push yourself I think in such
a position or at least with me it was
okay so what do I want from this
position do I really want to get the
game opening up the position
and I go with it or
am I ready to make a draw or really you
have to clear yourself that what is your
goal in this position yeah and then how
do you assess the position because maybe
you consider that okay I'm in great form
which for now Magnus can say right
I mean good form whatever happens
everything will be going on my way and
then you are more Brave to make
decisions and sometimes you
I happen to to to fill that and oh my
God
whatever I do is going to turn bad so
you don't play G4 kind of stop it stop
it in that situation so I think it's
very important to you know you know
yourself what shape you are in
and uh and then accordingly and of
course what is the position itself to
make a decision I like that know
yourself know what kind of play you are
and then look at the bigger picture and
what form you are exactly and and for
you David I mean was it just chess you
were thinking or would you kind of draw
on other things
yeah
um I mean I've talked to myself a lot
these days especially when I'm uh kind
of doubting myself when I'm not
necessarily in the best form uh in the
best shape and yeah it's often just
motivational stuff just general just
come on just slap myself Come On Dave
come on just quicker just anything just
quicker but yeah I mean it's it's
difficult in this kind of uh really
tense slower positions especially if
it's tactical at least you choose
something you go for it but if it's just
slow Maneuvers it's I mean it's not just
the Dilemma this move if Magnus kind of
procrastinates delays making a decision
now with D4 F4 he's got that decision
exact same decision to make every move
for the next 10 moves 20 moves so um
yeah it's hard to offer advice I think
this is one of the hardest kind of
psychological kind of binds to find
yourself in in chess it's just what to
do which also means that this is the
reason why you have to understand the
position very well if you do play this
kind of positions because it makes a
huge difference in which position where
the queen is standing where books are
standing that you know it will work out
well if you let's say open up with D4
right and this is why also black has to
understand that to have the pawn on B6
does it have any drawback or it's only
extra
because it covers the C5 Square because
eventually when the bishop moves away
Queen A7 is not an opportunity or
whatever you know so this is why it's
very important and carpa was incredible
in this that when he was playing
different kind of openings and you
thought that tempos are not important
still he was maneuvering the way that
once he's going to open up the position
like in this position D4 F4 he made sure
that in when it happens all the pieces
are serving that idea yeah has its best
places you know and then you think ah
how lucky it is
but actually he had some great
strategical thinking but that's I
remember discussing this type of
positions with um one of my very first
trainers and okay so I was an adult kind
of improver and he told me like the
whole point of these E4 E5 positions
with the white pieces is to get a pawn
break but he used the expression but you
catch your opponent on the wrong foot
you know
and I thought well you know that's a
nice it doesn't quite make sense but I
get you and I'm gonna use it
yeah it's like in sports it's like your
opponent shifts their body weight one
way you shoot the other way and uh
that's what Magnus has to do now it's
also like a bit of a conductor he's got
so many pieces to organize in such
little space you have to make sure that
they're all kind of in harmony before
you go for any action yeah just
incredibly hard I think this one will at
some point explode or at least if Magnus
is feeling it oh no we played G4
[Laughter]
we should have had it I was gonna throw
it out there but I thought no let's say
if you'll be G4 for the score yeah he's
uh he's ambitious an ambitious man
ambitious mood it's a good sign that we
see G4 on the board yeah we'd love to
see it yeah and now Wesley focused
maybe coming as a surprise to Wesley
yeah I think Wesley might have known it
was an option he would just have kind of
written it off thinking okay Magnus
isn't in the mood to play that type of
uh loose movement no no immediately no
immediate response just adjusting his
pieces
okay I don't think I hear I think
incoming from Wesley so I think he's not
happy CG for underboard
well it's a sign right from Magnus is
clear as daylight you know we are in it
for the long run and I'm gonna put you
under pressure
yeah I would be fair fearful here as
well as black that uh at least Magnus
will start building up slowly towards a
king side attack and these positions can
be unpleasant for black there's no
pawnbricks necessarily you're just
maneuvering with pieces and especially
if you have Bishops it's hard to know
how to maneuver them Knights are so nice
at kind of hopping around and uh kind of
planting themselves on good squares in
these blocked Central structures
Magnus power move just coming back to
the board already
yep and uh there you can see Magnus
happy shall we take a look at some of
the other games because for sure Wesley
is gonna start thinking as you mentioned
let's go back
any excitement as well
yeah we've seen developments on a lot of
the boards and I'm not sure which one
has changed the most well we see
abdisator of did not play Knight D4 but
played Bishop G7
but before to go that game I would love
to see the alireza again because we
haven't been there for some time and
there are quite a few things happened
since
yeah breaking news Abdu satorov doesn't
initiate chaos but uh it will of course
be chaotic later in that game and as you
mentioned Jude at this one
has opened up White's beautiful Pawn
Center has been eroded and we still have
this strange strange structure
imbalanced all over the wood and at
first glance I have no idea how to
evaluate this one so here we see the
current position maybe we just do a
action replay since we last left it just
about four or five moves ago so we saw a
bit earlier the Queen's Gambit accepted
and we left it after A6 white just
simply developed it should be two for a
sensible move and Knight F to D7 I
wasn't expecting this one I must admit
but White's night was extremely strong
in the center and it was soon traded off
after Bishop B3 C6 white decided to
trade those Knights castles Bishop B7
just developing not necessarily a great
square but hoping the position opens up
later and F five from amateur he's not
one to sit still and just wait he wants
action and this was captured Rook takes
F5 but I also think that in these
positions you have to be careful if you
don't make any action then it can easily
be a very bad position simply because of
the very strong Center having F3 4d4 so
F5 kind of was a I like it quite a lot
because it created the D5 Square for
Black's night after capturing on F5
and also of course when you have this
structure with black having C6 bone and
B5 C4 Bishop on B7 one day when it can
play C5 it can be very powerful though
due to F3 Pawn is not that powerful
uh yeah so the question is what will
happen for white on the E file right
there are too many Bishops so black
wants to go Queen E7 rookie eight
wow I'm talking of too many Bishops to
do that really nice maneuver there from
farrugia Bishop D1 coming round yeah
nice diagonal much improved his Bishop
once it lands here on C2
instinctively do you feel that one side
is better or is that not uh under
consideration right now is it just both
sides fighting for ideas
color would I be picking right now
because it's very tempting and very nice
to see the bishop on C2 in the next move
for white and I think black cannot go
Knight F6 because of Bishop C2 and then
you cannot jump back with the Rook so
probably you have to move back with the
bishop to F7
that's where I would be going and after
Bishop C2 Knight F6
yeah and it again feels very tense white
still has to kind of get his Rooks into
the game black still needs one or two
moves to get this or queen H4 for
example after Rook F7 Bishop C2 Knight
F6 and then already the two Bishop can
be very powerful yeah I think it's
important not to let that Queen the
White Queen get to H4 that's uh one too
many attackers they're circling around
the black king yeah let's show that
variation uh after Bishop D1 on the
board we're expecting Rook F7 right now
and uh after Bishop C2 Knight F6 Queen
H4 yeah looks very strong Bishop G5
potentially coming under minus Knight
and some attacks against H7
yeah looks uh looks very logical that
sequence I'm wondering if after Queen H4
maybe B4 is strong ah sorry in that
final position here B4
and if I jump
into the center you just want to take me
I guess actually I thought first that
can I go Knight D5 with I think Knight
G5 G6
yeah hitting the square three times now
you have to play G6 I can't move my
knight because of the PIN
crazy position yeah but it looks so
scary it looks like I mean so many
pieces are hanging defend my queen yeah
exactly
yeah no it's anyone's game positionally
black is better but uh dynamically maybe
white is uh Justin just in front just in
time to attack and I'm wondering here as
well where the black maybe starts coming
out with the queen
wondering about C5 and wondering about
B4 all these different Pawn pushes
yeah so hard to evaluate this position
so hard to kind of choose uh what plan
to go for
I'm glad it's them playing not me I've
got to say
there's definitely no solidity to either
side's position
right now what happens if I go Queen C7
here
and if I continue my plan attack your
Rook I go Rook H5
for too many checkmates on H2 this is oh
you know it's a dampy I don't allow your
queen to go to H4
clever but the Rick is really misplaced
there so that I would be tempted to
actually go Queen to G3
just with the simple threat if you tap
capture the queen then the pawn will
come to G4 and
I think this is good
yeah almost trapped black has to be
really resourceful now just to extricate
this Rook from danger on the edge of the
wood
yeah I understand your point
[Laughter]
it's definitely on the radar I mean
there's like Queen C7 it was like Queen
E7 Rook F7 Knight F6 Rook F7 is on the
board okay you called it first instinct
getting out the way Rook F7
preemptively retreating and farrugia I
think we'll play Bishop C2 very quickly
surely that was his plan
why hesitate also Queen G3 is possible
but of course Bishop C2 seems to be the
most obvious but after Bishop but hold
on Bishop C2 B4
and maybe it's a blunder whoops
nice moves away in B3 yeah
opening up double attack okay that's
what I would have done and I would have
lost on the spot okay so Rook F7 is not
only good to go out from Bishop C2 but
it's a very good prophylactic it seems
yeah these players are so good at
spawning the details
23 on the board okay yeah if the bishop
hits the White Queen I guess you just
slide right it's Queen H3
makes a lot of sense some ideas of
Bishop C2
yeah still looking very much in the
balance right now
who would you pick if I had to force uh
Force you hear Ivanka dude
White
just because I feel that Black's
position is
on this shaky side and I feel it's it's
so much easier for white to play I mean
white has a very clear goal
attack the king
and
blacks pieces are all tangled up and
there's no clear breakthroughs and
you're simply just hoping to survive and
reach the end game so
yeah what about you Judith
I don't know I wondering which color I
would pick I would be
tempted to take black because it's it's
interesting with the spawn majority on
the queen side if white does not have a
huge attack very serious attack with the
Bishops and Knight and queen then I
think it can easily can go wrong for
white as well because of the the queen
side yeah so if I can develop for
example Queen f8 it can be very
interesting for example to make space
for The Rook on a cool and you know
we're kind of all being very honest
about what our weaknesses and our
strengths are and I have to interrupted
you because Hikaru went in the
confessional again and this time he's
really been very honest about his
strengths and his weaknesses and his
feelings as well
so uh well a long live the very open
Hikaru
I'm feeling pretty good pretty good
about it all and time finally is evening
out you know one thing again since since
I tend to stream more than I play these
days you know is I can be very cognizant
or very open about what I feel like the
weaknesses are in my game I think that
whether it's like I'm just getting older
what's going on I think my reactions and
critical moments with limited time have
been very questionable in this turn the
blitz particularly I mean the game
against Fabiano I was incapable of
making making a move and I lost on time
of course yesterday against Wesley very
similar where I got very low on time and
all my decisions were just like someone
who's completely lost his head and
running around like a chicken
um so I think when I've gotten really
low my decisions have been great so I'm
actually quite optimistic because now
the position I think is someone
stabilized I'm not in a situation where
there are a lot of potential moves that
I consider for example in the current
position I can look for Knight B3 I can
look for Knight six Queen be Subs move
maybe I go F5 or G6 or Rook C8 but
that's the extent and it's not a
situation where I have to look at a lot
of possible moves and so I should be
able to make my next like 20 moves
relatively quickly now of course you
don't get any extra time just an
increment but nonetheless I feel like
the time is evening out and things are
definitely going the right direction
unless of course I've missed something
obvious here and I'm completely lost
that is the other option if I'm not
completely lost here I think I'm I'm
probably completely fine so there's no
in between here either it's very very
bad for me or I'm I'm probably just
completely equal at this point maybe
even better although it's probably way
too optimistic objectively so you know
we just we just wait and see and find
out how it goes um but I'm sure
everybody at home is probably laughing
but you're laughing or they're thinking
I'm a genius because you know after the
game when I look at it
I do feel like there was something I
feel like Bishop B1 wasn't right I don't
know it was Bishop G5 I don't know if
it's D5 but it just it feels like there
was something so you know obviously well
everyone at home knows now and I'll find
out in a couple of hours and either I'll
feel like a genius or I'll be absolutely
horrified but we'll see
and Hikaru actually being very relatable
to her especially when he talks about
how age is dampening his instincts you
know how he's saying that when he's in
time travel he just feels like he's
panicking that's some things I certainly
can understand
what do you guys think about that uh
those thoughts
yeah I mean I feel it too on a couple of
years younger than Hikaru but yeah
certainly I feel a bit less sharp these
days and I know his feeling I don't play
as much over the board as I used to I
was still a lot online and sometimes it
just takes a while to kind of see things
to trust yourself to see the board and
uh I think he's being harsh he's still
playing extremely well extremely high
level but he has high standards and it's
also interesting to know kind of how he
sees the position here he was kind of
spitballing four or five different moves
and uh it's only he'll work out the
details when the time comes and
depending on his opponent's uh reactions
there so I think that might suit him
actually in the classical portion of
this tournament Judah I'm not sure at
all that it it is because of his age
that he feels this way that in critical
moments his reaction is not the way as
it was I think it's his lifestyle uh
influences it a lot that he's a streamer
and he is
around chess in many different ways I
can streaming he's playing with the
amateur players right and commentating
and sometimes he's there for so many
hours so I think those things can can
also shift your reaction time or how
you're dealing with the critical moments
and yeah I did it was very interesting
what he said about his position and it's
either very bad or he is doing extremely
fine but what was interesting to me was
that it seemed to me he was talking
almost intuitively
like he just felt and that kind of
brings me to a kind of a nice question
like which was more important Intuition
or calculation
well intuition is something very
important and intuition is based on on
knowledge and experience right
so of course we chess players we we do
most of the things by pattern
recognition how many how much we've seen
something similar so basically most of
the patterns most of most of the ideas
and and things we we've seen before the
only question is in this concrete way
what do we think about the weakness of
the B3 Square what do we think about the
B1 diagonal of the bishop you know these
things if the root goes away from f828
then you have Bishop H7 with H5 right
but actually nowadays I think this
intuition we question many times because
when the players are working with
engines many many times occasions you
tend to think that something is wrong
and actually your intuition cheats you
because
it manners you see that maybe in
principle it should be good or should be
bad but actually exactly in this
position there is nothing really going
on from right then so it looks tempting
to play it with one but if you really
don't have some Bishop H7 or Bishop H6
or Rook D3 comes to G3 Bishop G Bishop
F4 because exactly the queen on B8 is
still standing bad you know so intuition
is tricky because in this position maybe
if the queen on B7 everything is perfect
because actually that's the best place
for the queen right and that's what he
just played but maybe only one move
makes a huge difference and the but I
think I have the feeling my intuition
says that black is fine because white
White's Rook is not on G3 and it cannot
get there so fast and can I finally put
you on the spot and say
you have to pick one train on your
Intuition or train on your calculation
which one calculation calculation
calculation
over everything
yes because actually calculation will
push you to better intuition
so I take to win one
Yeah the more you calculate the the more
you see things without even knowing
you're seeing things uh in a way and it
was interesting I went I attended a
lecture by Magnus uh a few months ago at
a training camp and he was saying
basically the same as Hikaru he said the
older he's getting or kind of year by
year he's calculating less and less just
relying on intuition and uh that has
pros and cons it kind of helps him save
time on the clock it helps to make very
practical decisions but occasionally
there might be a slip occasionally there
might be a miss and a blunder and uh
yeah it's interactive I think for
younger players that you don't have to
just calculate on every single move you
can save it 90 of the time you can maybe
just trust your instincts play an
improving move but that 10 that's when
this games are decided uh when there's
actually something concrete and you have
to be 100 sure and we saw that video
from Hikaru I'm loving him coming to the
confessional I hope it happens more and
more often but he did mention Queen B7
was one of the moves on his radar he was
like oh and maybe Knight B3 maybe Queen
B7 first two moves he suggested and uh
as you said it as well that second you
said could we be seven dude it happened
on the board there's threat like it's
the two point potentially it also has a
nice defensive idea because uh if gukash
was looking to neutralize the position
with like Queen H5 and do all all sorts
of sacks on G6
that Queen on B7 has some very good
defensive
possibilities yeah you want to block
this attack with Bishop to E4 yeah my
question is can right go D5
yeah I was I was thinking Knight C6 can
be also tricky in this position uh-huh
wow Knight C6
that's incredible awareness uh Judith
just cutting everything uh apart in
Black's position you're cutting the kind
of coordination between the queen of
Bishop you're hitting everything here uh
of course I can't move my Bishop off the
diagonal because of checkmates on H7
I don't know if it's winning it seems
pretty convincing it seems good if I
take this bishop then you take on this
square or maybe A5 I'm not sure which
one you hit my queen and next move you
win I think yeah because after Knight A5
Queen D5 yeah
so wow okay Queen H5 then what is the
answer there does that I have to play F5
I thought you could go juice G6 quietly
I don't think there's any checkmates
though no because this was the queen V7
you know you could uh move the bishop
out of the way yep so for example this
would lead to a potentially a draw if
black had to recapture the white Bishop
typical thematic sacrifice and uh this
would lead to a draw by repetition
nowhere to hide for the black king but
as Ivanka says just moved the king out
uh the bishop sorry out of the way I'm
not sure where but uh the queen defense
across the board and black winds peace
up
so yeah maybe not the counter-attack uh
not the attack on H7 yet
what else could kukesh try I don't think
he wants to kind of guard against this
with a move like F3 looks too ugly after
Queen H5 G6 I will go Queen H3
and I think it's a weakness to have G6
on the board because Bishop H6 is a
threat Knight G4 possibly can be an
option
or queen G4 provoking F5
yeah lots of holes around this King
feeling a bit Airy around there
uh I guess black has a move or two again
questions Knight B3 how do you reply to
this one
yeah I'm struggling to come up with
another I mean I've guessed white would
be reluctant to put the Rook on the
Square because suddenly this poor Bishop
is locked in yeah you're not happy with
such a rook having the bishop on B1
yeah at the same time if we go back to
Queen B7
the pawn on G2 is hanging right so white
has to make a move Queen G4 in H5
between F1
Queen F1 is or F3 which is um
yeah
F3 does blunt this bishop but yeah it's
it's not the move we want to play at
least go cash he does have one target if
he can get his Bishop to D3 and hit the
A6 Pawn at some point but exactly this
is what I had in mind maybe immediately
we shift D3 what do you think wow
trying to trick me if I take this Pawn I
don't think I'm getting trapped uh not
yes at least I guess you do you take on
A6 do you play F3
you could take here I can keep my queen
in line
it does feel
I wasn't sure about Bishop takes A6
primarily because
I was inspired by one of those old games
from the past you know when they start
they did they attempt black to actually
capture material in order to initiate an
attack yeah maybe bishop G Queen G4 is
possible right and Bishop H6 wow yeah
attacking my bishop and we have Bishop
D3 on the board wow okay we predicted
right
prediction game on point this is getting
complicated here uh I guess black would
have to defend maybe I give up the
exchange maybe with a move like Bishop
F6 uh but yeah Bishop D3 is on the board
so after this move key question can
black grab on G2 if you can like
Nakamura said exactly in the video he's
doing very well or he's doing very badly
but you know after Bishop G2 also F3 has
to be considered and Bishop H3 Bishop E4
because your queen is uh
not clear where it can be standing well
lacking happy squares here yeah if you
go back then white can start getting
greedy maybe take this pawn and uh yeah
if you slide across then you have to be
really careful of another hit
if you go Queen A7
yeah D5
scary stuff NBA Knight C6
yeah maybe Queen B8 hits the Knight and
Knight C6 and we're forced to give white
this really scary Pawn past Point here
wow
it's time for no more intuition it's
pure calculations taking on G2
that's for sure
I don't know if I'd be brave enough I've
got to say unless I had an hour to
calculate this one well especially if
your opponent invites you to capture
that pawn
Pages after great thought and their 17
year old gookash one of the best players
in the world I'm not sure I would be
taking that pawn in a hurry well you can
go F5
giving up the pawn on A6
just want to push and push and yeah I
mean I don't want any Bishop H7 Queen G4
stuff but then if you do that
but if you do that then I can you not
just take one A6 you've given me some
free material I'm taking it
welcome
a certified member
fellow members if I ever play with you I
know that you're gonna grab every
opportunity any pawn or something
out there that's the trick you just
tempt them poisoned one and uh yeah here
it just looks like free material though
and uh nice move from kukesh whether it
works or not it's going to send Nakamura
into a deep deep think also another move
what about F6
[Music]
asking me to go for checkmate
yeah to which I say absolutely I'm gonna
put the queen on H5 or Bishop H7
yes
sure that was awesome is not going to be
a win by any means
right yeah I mean it could backfire very
badly on white if there's no checkmate
um the Maximum Ride we'll have is a draw
so if after F6 my idea is that after F6
you have to move your knight
and uh
so what do you do or you have to play
Queen H5 but already after Queen H5 I
might play already Bishop B4 or just
simply F5
and I'm not hanging on A6 but but you
came up with this wonderful resource of
the bishop A4 and is it not the same
idea again
it's the same but it's not the same
I don't know or there's a feeling I have
it might be not the same what did you
forget about it I didn't forget about it
because that happens to be like David
literally explained yesterday a tactic
and I was like yeah yeah yeah I could
nice one and then the move that I
suggested actually fell for it her
client and sinker and I was like oh you
can lead a horde horse to water but you
can't make a drink
better to plunder these things and
Analysis than over there
let's allow Nakamura to make this
critical decision he needs a bit of time
yeah you convinced me F6 in H5 I go F5
anyway I wanted to have the my vision my
phone on F5
okay and uh well Hikaru will certainly
be thinking after that surprising move
from gukesh and it's the ideal time to
take a pause so we'll we'll be back with
more of the heart pounding action in a
few minutes see you after the break
thank you
[Music]
foreign
my name is Edward Dawson I'm from
Chicago I'm secret Blackman my name is
Roberto beijer Junior and what I want to
share is I love tacos tacos and chips
so yeah
[Music]
well the chess program really even chess
in general like on the deck you uh you
kind of Lose Yourself you don't really
think about your case you learn to think
differently you know you strategize more
I sometimes come out uh 7 30 in the
morning I'll probably play until lock up
you know if it makes my day go by faster
it's competitive it's a lot of trash
talk it's it's crazy you know like the
chess players we got our own little
circle you know and all of us play each
other we talk trash about who be who who
garbage yeah I never played that dude
again he got the child I never played
but yeah it's real competitive
I remember that day it was Unreal I
definitely felt like I was walking on
air
yeah it was like such a beautiful
feeling because I won the the first
championship that was actually combining
women and men into the same section so
in addition to winning the title and the
money which I really needed it was like
something like 9 500 but I was like a
college student at the time and like
literally that was like all the money I
had in my bank account after cashing
that check
so that was really cool and then also
because I have Norm so it was like a
little bit of everything
[Music]
foreign
land of fjords Majestic mountains Cliffs
and waterfalls
in addition to stunning geography Norway
is home to the greatest chess player who
has ever lived Magnus Carlson
since 2013 Norway has also hosted one of
the strongest chess super tournaments in
the world and it is one for which Magnus
has claimed the top prize in the last
four years
can anyone stop him
this time he'll meet one of his toughest
Challenges ever at his home tournament
with nine Rivals all hungry to beat the
best
from Carlson's fiercest online rival
today in their first classical
over-the-board battle in nearly four
years Hikaru Nakamura
to the young star Carlson once
hand-picked as his most worthy
Championship opponent alireza farrugia
two more young stars are trying to
follow in his footsteps laude Beck
abdusotourov and kukesh domaraju
two established stars have already won a
Super tournament in 2023 Anish giri and
Fabiano caruana
two more long-time Headliners seek to
take their next turn Atop A major
tournament Wesley so and Shakira
mamagyarov
finally Carlson's Countryman and friend
Arian tari rounds out the field
two will come out on top will Carlson
run the table yet again or will someone
else usurp the throne this is Norway
chess
and welcome back after that short break
short break that didn't come out quite
right it's time to reignite the chess
fire because during the break we were
actually looking at the games and we got
excited by a lot of the positions it
seems that there is action brewing in
practically every single board
yeah it looks like huge developments
everywhere and uh not necessarily good
developments for some of those players
so much decisive action so far and it
looks like we will be treated to more of
the same today and uh where to start
this is the bird's eye view maybe a
quick Roundup of some of the action
before we jump in looks like Magnus and
Wesley have still a slow game but the
first set of Pawns have been traded some
lines opening there Harry and Harry
against nordebec will have to go to that
at some point that one's still totally
crazy but looking good for whites in
general and uh you could cash against uh
Nakamura we left that just before the
break in the balance over there we'll
come to Anish giri against Fabiana
caruana but uh also alareza against
mamacharov looking uh complicated Judith
only one place to start well my pick
would be an issue's game because we
haven't seen that for quite some time
and there is a pawn missing over there
for an age as far as I see it was there
and by the time we came back there is
something it seems that it's it got
deleted from uh yeah it was like from
the position pocket came and just slid
it from the board somebody passed by and
just hit that I sleep on right
yeah and uh that Black Knight has done a
smashing crab he's done a bit of a
thievery there a bit of theft sneaking
off that A3 Pawn from the board and we
have to try and figure out how that
happened how we got this position let's
backtrack just three or four moves to
see how uh Fabiano won a pawn and maybe
sees the advantage as black and it was
around here that we left the game uh
just actually a couple of moves before
this point and uh White here played
Bishop to default trying to kick back
trying to evict this black knight from
the center the Knight simply stepped
back white castled black gained time
against the white bishop and uh it was
this move which has been brandish with a
question mark Queen to C2 the engine
really not liking that retreating move
understandable white wants to give a
square uh for his Bishop either on D3 or
A4 to come back to but suddenly after A6
we saw the black knight jump into C4 and
maybe this is what Anisha had
underestimated there's two threats not
just this Pawn but also the threat of
jumping into D2 either with blacks Rook
or Knight Rook D2 a winning idea and uh
for example if Quincy won defending the
spawn Knight D2 a nasty Fork a niche
just falling foul of these night jumps
instead he had to give up the pawn uh
playing the move Rook to D1 and there we
go it disappeared Judith fell off the
board that pawn and we reached this
position Bishop to B3 the last move I
don't know which exactly was it the
blunder by Anish can you go back just a
little bit I have just one question when
he played Queen C2
wasn't the moment when at this point to
play Knight D4
wow I think that could have been a
really nice psychological blow as well
we see the evaluation bar approves
Knight D4 if we're discussing this idea
before right
but somehow it has a good energy and
finally the two Bishops one goes to a G3
actually it's threatening immediately
Bishop G3
so after A6 you can come back with the
bishop to E2 this is what I I want to
say or to D3 and Knight F4
I don't know but somehow it seems like
the the the energy is is good for white
and it can happen very easily That You
Don't See or you're not in the mood to
play this Knight D4 you think you can
just get along with just playing solid
and you give away the squares and I
think this is a big problem of Queen C2
right that's simply after A6 divide
squares become extremely weak for white
the bishop gets to A4 and actually of
course the concrete part that Knight D2
and Knight A3 suddenly I think there was
some Miss
by Anish yeah I think you're totally
right this is a common pattern I've been
on the wrong end of this I've suffered
from this myself throughout my career I
see a tempting move I see what I should
be playing but it comes with so much
risk I decide against it and suddenly
the whole game turns against me and okay
so let's let's see what has happened
right he gave he had to give up the A3
Pawn
so this is the current position
the problem here for a niche is that
long term this black a pawn is going to
become extremely strong also still start
to be pushed maybe now maybe now
a
a true I mean obviously white has the
worst position but uh
it looks to me pretty defensible right
or are you guys saying objectively
give me percentages here like
[Laughter]
your best yes exactly I want to own you
guys to put your money away where your
mouth is tell me tell me tell me what is
the percentage of black winning this if
I was Alpha zero and I only worked in
percentages yes
I would say
not much chance of like losing unless
something really goes wrong uh for
Fabiano it feels like he has full
control this white knight is currently
dominated you have a light Square bind
these pieces so nice together
it's upon running even if you trade off
all the Rooks the Queens black will
never lose that so I would say like five
ten percent chance of a loss okay
the rest is like equal between a black
win and a draw is that too harsh on
White's chances dude I don't know I
would bet on black about I don't know I
think it's 30 that he wins 30 he wins
and then
how much draw percentage
quite High we need to do our math the
reason I'm asking I'm asking
[Laughter]
the reason I'm asking this is that we
went okay to a normal player it feels
like it carries a lot of risk to
actually sacrifice a night and if you
get a position where you think wow you
know what I'm worse
but I can defend it
yeah but then again the other position
where white was giving up the Knight on
D4 it felt like not still not that much
risk attached we still have two pawns we
have the bishop power which is very good
competition and
not I mean here there's just no real
winning chances the other position had
full kind of uh dynamism in it the
problem is it's a very dangerous
position for white right now right if
let's say black spawn would be on A3 we
would say wow but it can happen within
few moves that really he plays A5 A4 A3
and and there are different scenarios
where black has a huge Advantage for
example from the knight from G6 it can
be transferred to C6
easily and it will be
possibly a better square right or let's
say we exchange the Rooks like is
improving the position I think and that
is a plus spawn is it can be really
deadly dangerous so it is very clear
that it's white who is trying to
stay in the game the Knight on E2 is not
standing well but it controls the F4
Square for the moment so it's kind of
important it can't really move now that
there is no Pawn on A3 you can't really
think of playing Knight D4 anymore
because I mean you would need that part
right but there are some things I mean
but Knight C6 seems to be a fantastic
idea because I was thinking as white the
most annoying piece for whites is
actually the Knight on C4 so and also
it's on white side of the board I tend
to be very possessive when pieces get in
my side of the board so I was oh no I
wasn't expecting H4 I was thinking Queen
A1 and go Queen A2 to try to dislodge it
yeah that looks like a really healthy
plan Ivanka just like then I think 92
was possibly an option though Bishop
Bishop B6 that was my plan yeah oh I uh
you're so quick it took me a minute to
see that one
yeah instead H4 unpredicted uh as you
both mentioned a bit of a surprise it
feels like he's trying to kick this
Knight away but he's kicking it back
where we wanted to put it anyway Judah
yeah
surprising stuff is this really gonna
pre uh kind of uh prepare a king side
attack it's hard to imagine G4 happening
in this game I know it's happened in a
lot of others so far I think the idea
for why to play H5 and maybe after
Knight E7 to play F4 some very concrete
somehow to get out with your knight from
E2 but it looks very dangerous I believe
for white
yeah that's really burning the bridge
you don't go back from that one
um it's because especially there's
consequences
actually what are the consequences yeah
let's jump in and try to figure out
what's going through Fabiano's mind
right now uh each was just landed on the
board I doubt he was looking in that
direction and uh if now he plays A5 for
example what could be more natural we've
been uh talking about that type of move
for a while after age five also Knight
f8 is something to consider seriously
because Knight can be even better on D7
attacking the C5 Pawn yep makes a lot of
sense
uh would you flick it
moves like A4
as well
given time if given opportunity I quite
like the fact that this bishop is
undefended right now so I'm not
necessarily in a rush uh with black I
mean let's go F4 yeah has to be F4
it would be tempting to flick in A4
right now just to get the pawn slightly
nearer to the goal as you mentioned
Ivanka but what next let's say I flick
it in force the bishop back
actually around maybe not the four can
still be in the game
yeah now suddenly that would be an
attack opened up against this for
example if F6 then I could imagine that
Knight D4 is uh as an option boom and
suddenly
all sorts of tactics maybe along this
diagonal all sorts of Pawns running
forward I must admit I'm shocked that
the evaluation bus still on black side
it looks like White's pawns are really
menacing right now and uh yeah instead
of F6 white does have a thread of F5
kicking away the bishop the defender of
this Knight so how else can black deal
with that threat well you can step away
with the Knight right
maybe just Knight A5 yeah
I accidentally
rhymed there right right Knight and A5
will arrive on B3
yeah and now we see the reason why we
flicking the A4 move
let's say
okay let's
jump jump jump jump three yes three or
between E3
you need to defend this Pawn I guess
yeah if I if you go to A3 I might take
four this one thanks
ah you wanna
yeah maybe it's uh I can't afford that
but if you go the other way there's a
chance this might just run through your
phone you're thinking dreaming about
cleaning the a pawn absolutely these
pawns must be pushed
well it's also an idea I don't know if
like after H4 if we go back to the exact
position of
the game can black go H5
I know it's a weakness
but let's say the H4 can also be a
weakness later
yeah which porn is weaker because white
cannot go Queen a queen G5 can he
Queen G5
why not
this is the question
yeah it feels like there's some tactics
in the air but I don't really see it yet
hmm I'm tempted to for example just push
though and if you take my Pawn I'll just
continue and then I might try and render
your queen uh kind of Trapped off side I
might play a move like Queen E7 so if
you ever want to come back
it will come at the cost of trading off
that Queen
yes it's cost upon but your coins are
temporarily offside on H5
this is too complex I'm not sure where
the black is I think H5 is also
something to consider for sure
it's instructive just to kill all
counter play so
black can stop White's plants with H5 or
black can continue his own plans with A5
you're predicting one of these two moves
due to h5a5 very different uh yeah yeah
I think both are good alternatives
so black black has a lot of
biggest problem of Fabi right now
because even Rook D1 Rook D1 Rook d8 is
something you would consider
trade all the Rooks and and you have to
evaluate this whether one Rook of
exchange does it improve white or black
both Rooks of Exchange
who does it favor
do I have time to play A5 and allow H5
or shouldn't I allow H5 right so there
are so many things to consider with
black and all of them are probably
pretty good and and very tempting of
course one of the most tempting thing is
to push the phone
yeah and in terms of clock times at
least Fabiano has a 20 minute Advantage
so he has uh he has the uh yeah he has
the guarantee that he will be able to
mull over all the options
but then again yeah a niche down to 30
minutes I do fear for whites bored and
clock it feels like the momentum is on
Black's side yeah I like in the future
chat though Anish has his fans we
believe in a niche
and uh yeah I believe that Anish will
entertain us in this game no matter what
the result I think I would choose black
here for sure I would like to change
our bird eye view
let's go back and wherever you like to
go because this is a lot of excitement I
mean I mean there is a culinary going on
on the menu for us we haven't been for
at Magnus it's for a long time maybe but
can I beg you to go to the orientation
is crazy yeah and know the backup
disturbed because it's like whoa and it
looks to me like black just looking at
the piece configuration is in a lot of
trouble
yeah let's uh jump to that game between
Aryan and Aaron tari and nodabek Abdul
sotorov and we'll have to do an action
replay here so much has changed uh I
mean this feels random it's like
someone's just kind of picked up all the
pieces just thrown them on the board and
uh I mean it's definitely official
random chest this one uh this definitely
didn't arrive from a classical game so
this is the current position let's
quickly do a recap of some of the moves
uh we last left it in a really tense
position we thought oh maybe not abec's
gonna get ambitious and sacrifice a
piece he didn't go for that instead uh
just playing the comp Bishop G7 E5 did
happen as you predicted Judith uh White
giving up a pawn to open up lines
towards the black king to gain a bit of
time as well and now Bishop D2 really
clever uh indirect attack against the
black queen you don't want to allow that
white knight to jump forward with this
discovery so uh interesting retreated
yeah interesting thing on the A5 Queen
yeah D5 happened so uh we looked at
something similar earlier but now white
has an e-file to look at the black king
down and uh Knight E4 Bishop E5 blocking
that e-file hinting some checks maybe
and uh the last couple of moves yeah
provocation and this uh I think has
provoked Aryan into maybe a bit of a
weakening move maybe something he'll
regret he's pushed a pawn forward but
suddenly look at this white king and
this becomes relevant in the final
position Bishop h8 this is why I think
it's Fisher random what's the bishop
doing that King f8 White's advancing but
suddenly D3 and uh this move which is
fantastic suddenly huge threat Bishop D4
hitting the white king
who's meeting who in this position
that's the big question
well Bishop D4 is something you don't
want to allow right because the threat
is Bishop D4 check and after King H1 to
push the E Pawn to E5 let's say and
queen comes to H4
so
well there's a pawn there for the taking
yeah let's uh taking that first exactly
and then Bishop B5 yeah let's jump in
with the board uh Queen takes Pawn is
the most natural move for white but
would it backfire uh as you mentioned
Bishop B5 hitting the queen Judith yeah
and the problem is that white cannot
keep an eye on both the D4 square and
the D5 bone so let's take Queen B3
and let's see how black wins because
here
check
Bishop D4 engage one and now isn't it
just a transfer a queen to the attack
but how is it Checkmate because the
White Queen couldn't come and block we
can play
uh kind of almost I wanted E6 but then
the Knight on e4 is a great defender
talking of the Knight on e4 maybe it's
something to do with F5 kicking away
this Knight
is it now or do we trade Bishops first
let's say F5 Maybe
hitting this Knight
yeah maybe white is struggling here just
because no good squares for it if you
Retreat this way then there might be
some nasty night checks as well okay
E5
E5 in yeah yeah or also you can go Queen
E8 yeah less less flashy but B5 is stake
and poisson and you get checkmated one
life beautiful stuff okay so this is
something too scary and not only scary
but it's bad
so Queen takes D3 is not possible Right
doesn't look that way Bishop C3 that's
the most uh tempting move for me and
that's what happened
protection skills on point and yeah
because you want to get rid of that
Potential Threat of Bishop D4 right and
you want to get rid of that Bishop too
yeah logical
I really want to kind of throw in D2
just throw this Pawn away just to
deflect your pieces but I'm not sure it
works I'm not sure uh it does match off
to the White Knight takes D2 what
uh what is the point for black how can
you take advantage of the fact that my
knight is not on e4 yeah they need to
build a teleportation machine and get
this queen out somehow to H4 in one move
can you try to do things to get I was
thinking of uh
yeah yeah
oh dude it reads me so well I'm like an
open book
let's check it out E5 and uh this looks
very natural trying to get the queen of
these games you know the first move
comes to mind Knight G5 yeah just to
block it
you know what I'll do here Judah I'll
take it with a rook
no it was a joke it's just like things
happen today like
you're not expect the unexpected yeah
can I go G3 or do I have to play G3 wow
so just to get this threat off your mind
do you want to play G3 but oh look at
this white king wait
well interestingly enough he hasn't gone
for E5 but nordeback has chosen E6 with
very much the same idea I I feel like E6
is a safer version okay look at the
evaluation undecided but it's it's
hating it uh it looks like a bit of a
mistake objective
just to prevent this idea
yeah makes sense what else sorry I just
don't want to get checkmated that's the
only reason I play this ugly
yeah yeah but maybe there was something
better but then you have Pawn takes D5
and
it feels like things could easily
liquidate into an in-game which black is
okay
you know what's possible to play Queen
B2 kind of move work we need to screen
H4 G3 and protect that way maybe what
about Queen B2 genius uh let's get that
analysis board up Queen B2
it's a queen H4 G3 protecting across the
board here
yeah this looks like a good defense but
there's still I don't know it just feels
so wild if I work when B2 right yeah it
does because I'm thinking well you can
I'm trying to run through the whole
order checks captures threats and so I'm
thinking Pawn takes porn is a
possibility eventually you'll even look
Knight G5 after yeah
at some point not G5
that moves on your mind now you can't
get it out but uh yeah right now it
looks like this suits Black this favors
black
well the small I mean the finite margins
for error here now what's my question I
cannot take on B7 can I
cross my mind too
getting greedy but apparently not ah no
no no yes
sorry I took your move yeah but I think
we both had the Eureka moment at the
same time I was thinking 366 and queen
B4 check
wow okay and uh we do see that E6 has
been given a question mark after the
computers come to uh a conclusion here
C6 could this be the reason and yeah if
I take
oops
oops oops I can block with the queen I
guess
if I move this to the square I'm going
to end up getting checkmated this is
going to be a deadly attack against the
black king that's not funny for black
not fun at all so I can block with the
queen
what is the killer blow well maybe just
taken Bishop B for check
um
but maybe it's not enough
it still looks good I have to run
somewhere you just take this pawn and
now without Queens at least the white
king is not going to get checkmated
could you be um oh yeah but it
transposes to the same thing as just
apples and pears I was thinking of
taking the pawn fast
keeping the pawns on Queens on the board
yeah I mean instead of Queen B4 yeah and
so the queen takes Queen but maybe
instead of Queen B4 you can just take C6
aha so this position here and if I take
back
no no I thought yeah now you well now
you can go for your
oh yeah
seven takes and Bishop h8 Bishop E4 so
yeah this type of position we're talking
about and we do a quick count Black's
still okay
it's so crazy here one slip and white is
uh winning one slip and the other way
and black is winning it's uh wow it's so
crazy draw is definitely not happening
in this game unless unless something uh
even more unexpected happens E6 current
position we think C6 is that the move
we don't see anything else
quintix B7 we didn't see why it Lost
Queen takes B7 I guess can black play
Queen H4 anyway
and then take and just block and Bishop
B8 right no more checks uh check mate
coming now
aryan's gonna find it though C6 is the
most obvious wow to try get this C6 only
way to get an advantage anything else
it's uh going to be equal of course zero
zero and zero yeah I hope yeah yeah
there's one line which is like Bishop
takes porn which we didn't look at that
was like 0.02
hahaha
and say Bishop takes Pawn is not going
to happen you see these are the
positions where intuition is lying
you just can't have it actually I have
it that white should be good but still
it's like okay there is the only move
that you have to make actually C6 is
very obvious but you have to calculate
all the way and if you don't understand
what is really going on and how it wins
maybe you choose something else
though there is not much of an option
because Queen H4 is on your neck
and what are the chances of RM finding
C6 and does it does it get a brilliant
move
I think I think simply
if you play a Blitz game you don't
hesitate if you see the move C6 you just
play but it makes a lot of sense that
black king yes the black king is
vulnerable after it exactly
yeah I think he's going to find it 20
minutes might not sound like a lot a lot
he still has to make 16 moves before he
even gets any increment Ariane but you
know he's made a move he made C6 yeah
I've played him enough in my career to
know that he'll find a dynamic move if
he's given the opportunity especially if
the margin for error is quite small but
yeah it's it's later on whether he can
handle the time pressure as mentioned
there in the future chat yeah and I have
to say I'm slightly disappointed because
it didn't get a double exclamation mark
and I only got one deserves at least one
exclamation mark there I know I remember
when I got my first brilliant move I was
like look at this it made my day
so after B takes C6 what is our
conclusion he takes C6 or queen check or
we haven't found a win yet for white or
anything that looks like it gives a big
Advantage okay so if you go
Pawn takes Pawn let's jump in Pawn takes
Pawn expected on the board and this is
what I wanted to play I want to play
Queen shark
that looks good seven I have to block
and then now Pawn takes porn I just
thought
but I think Bishop takes
no and now nothing
can I be really sneaky here if I go back
after Queen E7 I'm wondering if I can
jump in like Knight C5 for example
um hit your Bishop
I mean this is just wild and what about
Judith's variation I mean how can we
look at that because that was also super
forcing if we can revisit porn takes
point I don't want to exchange
so my question was If instead of Queen
B4 to take on C6
and if I take you back yeah and here's
something
it does feel like there's something here
do you not have that how do we just take
this bishop can you not go Bishop before
Bishop h8 Bishop E4
aha so
before it should be for you go King G7
oh
King mine pieces have to do it beautiful
beautiful
Bishop on h8 absolutely
and now the question troop C6 Queen H4
and what happens right
yeah
how does white stop this mate maybe two
check and G3
oh that's so difficult to see visually
you can cover the square in two moves
give it a try that's clear that in this
game whatever is the evaluation it does
not make a big influence on the game
what will be there Bishop D4 at the end
deflection
[Music]
you take me and I check mate you
oh my God this game is crazy
it's called chess yeah and what about
King H7 Knight G5 check maybe that's
finally got your knight G5 really I got
it
oh I don't know which way to take I can
take with the pawn take with the Rook
yeah but I'm also wondering if you give
a check with the bishop
rather than sorry Queen B2 because I
feel that one
is not working
and if I hide yeah whatever
what I wanted to ask was
do we take and run
yes you are all my wavelength oh it's so
scary but I know sorry Bishop D4 yeah
Bishop D4 and I guess I just run for the
hills
quite King is wriggling away
to safety can you imagine that you have
to calculate all this at the board
with 20 minutes and the rest of the game
yeah oh my God that's scary stuff
he's got to be using the opponent's time
here 20 minutes is not enough for white
to defend this one unless you're
cold-blooded and you can calculate let's
go back to the game position C6 and this
looks good just to show the audience as
well they might be wondering why not
Queen H4 looks like white is giving
Checkmate but I'm guessing that uh sorry
Black's giving Checkmate but white gets
there first after Queen B4 check
the king moves and
actually maybe not Knight D6 maybe we
just take this bishop it feels like
there must be a Checkmate here
surely oh yeah well also we saw that the
white king is probably quite safe if it
runs for the Seas
I like my Arrested Development whenever
they were in trouble they're like let's
run for the Seas
yeah what a game we'll have to take a
breather from this one I think let's uh
abduce a tour of try and work his magic
it looks like black might be a problem
maybe we can uh
take a look at the Magnus for short I
know that that's a boring game compared
to all this
but it's quite interesting in a
strategic way it is it is a very
interesting game because uh well Magnus
is actually making big inroads on the
king side but Wesley is pinning all his
hopes on the queen side
and I love these type of battles
and let's zoom out of this game yep it's
time to check out that uh really intense
battle
oh
this one between Magnus Carson and
Wesley so
which decide to pick it's hard to hard
to make a call here black has some well
pair of Bishops but maybe one of the
worst Bishops I've seen in a long time
that being said black has access to the
open file of the only open file in the
position and that could be an important
detail later on Jude yes it's very
interesting he did play B5 as we were
talking about at some point that it can
be a playing opportunity for both sides
it white reached out with the pawn
structure pawns G4 H4 H5 right there was
an exchange of knights
um
at first I would like to play it I would
prefer to play it with white
I'm not sure I can tell you why it's
just a intuition at this point maybe
it's pattern recognition you've seen a
bad piece like this bishop on D6 you
mean it's very bad at the same time the
rookie stands very well on B8 Rook B4 is
coming there A4 Pawn is weak A5 is not
weak right
can you do put pressure on the C5 bone
no can you take advantage of my D6 bad
Bishop not really for the moment
so the question is why really I would be
so happy with white
it's a very good question all right
that's what I'm saying it's intuition
which I'm not sure it's not lying to me
yeah it's hard to see a way to just
prevent this kind of caveman plan
really primitive uh idea of the question
is for example whether is Knight C4
favors white if let's say uh can black
capture on C4 or that really gives a
clear Advantage for white I have white
plants tonight on this beautiful Square
let's jump in Knight C4 uh let's just
for argument's sake say capture I don't
think that's the brush and now Rook B4
B4
this is a good case of uh beautiful
Bishop against a bad Bishop but more
important factors potentially
4 and A4 is just weak
well you do have sneaky ideas on the
d-line
oh C3 yes oh C3 C3 and cc3 Rook A3 Rook
A4 is a blunder to Queen D1 wow such
cool geometry here hitting the Rook Rook
takes Rook is not met by a recapture
it's met by a nasty check and the detail
is C4 was played yeah C4 I like that
move a lot I nearly said it as well uh
Knight C4 or C4 I love that trick
actually that you just pointed out your
Banker so I would have been too tempted
by that but C4 is basically saying this
bishop is dead for the rest of the game
but my question is after Rook B4 are you
going to play Knight B1 or something to
sacrifice the pawn on A4 yes
or first queen D1 that's yeah
and and put the Knight on
B1 C3
and I was just thinking about this type
of position
now c4 is a wonderful move because
actually it kills both of the Bishops
yeah I I think that I was thinking do
what David suggested of holding that A4
Pawn
yeah before maybe yeah and then and then
try to trade off all the pieces and go
into the end game which is going to be
probably good for
white yeah it looks like any end game is
going to be really nice for white uh and
you need a few moves though Knight B1
you need to kind of get it to C3 to hold
everything together you might need to
drop your Bishop back to evict this
black Rook there's a lot of ifs and uh
the final if would be whether black can
start opening the position on the king
side a bit later on but now I go Queen
E8
and Bishop D7
okay it's my bad Bishop I'm going to
take that you want to take it but now
I'm in time you're in time 93. I wanted
to be in time to use my Bishop to kick
you out but uh it wasn't in time for
that one okay Rook AB8
you want to go Knight B5 right provoke
C6 Maybe
looks like we've plugged all the holes I
mean the bar here is just confusing me
so much it can't make up its mind it
looks beautiful for white to be honest
how is white not better here
yeah so so Queen D1
just holding everything holding the pawn
okay okay B8 I don't waste my time okay
let's drop back
trying to come in
Rook B3 yeah that might be the nasty
move killing two of my plans killing the
Knight C3 maneuver and killing Bishop D2
because this Pawn would then be on press
yeah because I mean time element is very
important here whether you reach out
with your knight to c3d5 or B5 but if
not
and you don't have moves like Knight A3
A4 is hanging or it's not because of 9B
9.5 maybe maybe that was like my or
maybe
I can see
oh oops
there you go yeah maybe White's just one
move too slow and uh Magnus here after
Rook B4 which has been played by Wesley
Queen D1 maybe there's no time maybe
it's too much of a kind of uh maybe you
have to move here go back and do your
knight B1 plan immediately
or you can go Rook A2 or Rook a through
oh no it's hanging now
yeah it feels like feels like Knight B1
takes Knight C3 white has lost a pawn
but this really reminds me of a game
between nanish giri and Magnus Carlson
from the world Blitz when Magnus
basically gave up a pawn a very strong
passport but his opponent's Bishops were
totally dead against the knights and uh
this could be a case where white has
full compensation I think it's a
critical moment right now
for Magnus and it's not very often that
Magnus has less time than his opponent
right and this is the case right now
and the players have their time for the
rest of the game
yes we have to mention that the players
are not getting any increment until they
pass move 40 and then they will only get
a 10 second increment so play it is fast
and it is furious
yeah and Wesley has had the upper hand
against Magnus in uh
many kind of Blitz and rapid play
tournaments in recent times it's not
going to be easy if this goes down to
Armageddon or if it does become a Time
scramble it might be one big decision
maybe one is underborn yeah
Magnus uh I think I'm making a good
practical decision giving up a pawn but
at the uh kind of price at least he has
in compensation now of activating his
pieces
shall we wow this action everywhere the
tarry against FD satoroff game but you
know maybe here also rugby three
possible
three maybe I can slide
with Queen C2 okay he was too tempted
here Wesley took the pawn can't blame
her for that one and now White's okay
taking first the Rooks off the board and
then the White Knight jumps forward with
tempo
quick flurry of moves here from the two
players
really speeding up now as we head
towards move 40 V3
yeah Queen B3 likely and then I guess
we'll see why tonight defended
and then the Rook will come
yes what happens if black goes back
Queen C6 or queen E8 and then Bishop D7
A4
very good question
that looks promising to me Wesley is
about to move again the players they're
playing as if it splits right now
they've made their last three or four
moves instantly I think we will see the
black queen come back you're right Judah
I just pushed the pawn which can be
supported by a Black's Bishop on this
Diagon or later
oh should we take a pause from this one
I think so this one's very very tense
and uh just looking at some developments
some big developments happen in the game
between Ari and tari and Abdus Tov
because it looks like
I've just sort of blundered
and he was not punished wow okay because
we were discussing this position and we
kind of did a very deep dive and we
thought okay well
Pawn takes porn was the only move
and
take a look what happened no it didn't
happen
Wow Let's jump back into this dramatic
game maybe the game of the round so far
in terms of what's happening on the
board and this is the position we left
at C6 black took the Bishops off the
board and jumped in with Queen H4 look
at this double question mark from the
computer and uh tarry didn't find the
win here the check check G3 right yeah
Judith you spotted it I think we called
it earlier in this position white gave a
check from C5 but just to show the
winning variation he could have played
uh it was actually choosing the B4
square and uh this would have changed
everything this would have been a check
another check and when the black king
moves G3 the key detail you defend
across the board you gain time against
the black queen and next move white wins
a piece this would have been game over
a huge Miss Mutual blindness there and
uh tarry just before we left it he had
21 minutes so he's only spent a minute
or two and he breezed past the critical
moment but you know this is also one of
the the key skills for top players to
smell it when you have to think and
spend the time and when you really take
your time because you feel that this is
the moment this is a crucial point of
the game
yeah this would have won on the spot
just to show what Ariane did in this
position instead of checking from this
Square keeping the option of dropping
back to B2 alive he checked from C5 and
this changed everything as we see there
white is not losing but it's a huge Miss
suddenly more moves King G7 the black
king runs now we cannot get to the
second rank with gain of time with white
he did indeed go for the king run Bishop
takes D3 clearing space for the white
king to start escaping and now it's
anyone's game I have no idea who's
better and you know why he played Queen
C5 it is kind of very tricky process if
you think about it because of course you
see that there is a check on B4 and on
C5 and simply probably he thought that
Queen C5 is great because after King F1
I can pull it back to G1 and then he was
not looking further that is there
something else with Queen G4 other
opportunity
so it's like what you start looking at
first yeah I'm just so curious like
would Abdi photographers found this is
white did he spot it after playing Queen
H4 he blundered himself as black
allowing that opportunity and now okay
let's pick apart the remnants of this
position as you say Judith uh Queen H1
maybe 54 is also Chuck yeah Queen A1
Queen G1 and that will be game over this
is this is what he blood yes and he's
missed Queen takes porn
and now the big question for white is
do you play King G1 or do you run and I
I don't know where the king is safer to
be honest with you yeah the downside
with King G1 if we run back this way is
black does have minimum a draw
I can go with a check and uh keep
repeating moves so if you want to play
for a win you either have to block with
your knight which feels
a bit wrong somehow or we run with the
King out into the open
oh but hang on a second if you run if
you run out
to the Wilderness over E2
I mean does it simply be taxi6 I think
BTC C6 Bishop takes C6
if I take it
give me three Queen E3 yeah and you win
yeah whichever way you go if you win
this piece so yeah you've got Brook F4
yeah yeah yeah yeah
I've been doing my tactics for breakfast
no no for lunch and not for dinner
but breakfast wow anything could still
happen I think King E2 would take nerves
of Steel right now in the game position
uh sorry after critics have four check
to come out this way he's played it has
he okay he takes a force on the board
no I didn't think it's I don't think
he's made a move yet
King E2 or King G1 no he's still
thinking and just uh humor me if he does
go Knight to F2
okay dropping back with the white knight
yeah yeah I can't tell you why but he
takes his suits maybe now you're right
there Judith wow the White Queen now is
kind of tied down defending this Knight
so she cannot go and take the bishop of
C6
yeah like his two pawns up here as well
so now it's Ariane who has to tread a
very narrow path in order to survive
this game he has to find King E2
shall we leave this game on this
Cliffhanger and uh head over to other
games which are really sharpening up we
have um
alireza farouza we have to revisit um
Hikaru gukash against Hikaru
it seems It's it seems everybody woke up
in a fighting mood
they chose violence this morning
and uh okay where shall we go it looks
like action all over the place what do
you think yeah let's go to a faruga
against uh mama jarov here there's a
black knight and an intruder in the
white Camp I have no idea how it got
there but either way this one has
changed significantly since we were last
here
and yeah I'm not sure who it favors all
these developments it feels like black
is doing pretty well
um Judith body language look how focused
manager of is he smells blood in the
water clock times quite dramatic 23
minutes for black 33 minutes for white
for Rouge at least learning from the
mistakes of yesterday keeping some time
to spare up his sleeve and uh yeah quick
pull encounters it's still Level
material but this Black Knight is maybe
the key piece in the position that's a
nice piece over there yeah from the
black blacks perspective not from White
yeah it's and actually if far Asia lost
this game
he would have started with two whites
lost both of his games in the classical
portion and that's a tough pill to
swallow to say the least yeah the
problem is here if white ever takes this
Knight it's only going to be replaced by
a very strong past pawn and uh okay it
would be opposite color Bishops there
but still far far from safety right now
he's kind of threatening with that right
to take on this three and Rook D1 and
capturing the pawn so black has to be
prepared for that
and there are many questions how to
continue it with black
so let's try and solve some of those
questions the moves that appeal to me
immediately firstly jumping in with the
Black Brook to E2 yeah yeah that's very
tempting I agree another move would be
something connected with B4 but I'm not
100 sure here uh breaking the black
structure feels like a bit of a pity and
what about improving the worst place
piece Bishop C8 oh that's a classy one
Ivanka really sophisticated getting
ready to defend a passport if it does
land on the D3 Square I would also
consider to play A5 with an idea to be
for to strengthen the
I'll spawn
yeah lots of tempting candidate moves
here but only 21 minutes for the game
21 minutes to go
yeah Bishop C8 also uh
gives a great temptation
yeah that's the type of move car puff
would play Bishop C8 I'm not sure mama
jorov would play at this somehow I would
like to have my Bishop on B7 or after A5
Bishop A6 but I'm not sure it's
is the right path
yeah and uh let's zoom out wow we have
the first result of the day oh wow and
uh that does mean that we are going to
see an Armageddon to break the tie
between Magnus Carlson playing with the
white pieces against Wesley so
and the players are actually not allowed
to agree a draw before move 30. so David
can you tell us what happened
Ivanka I could tell you they got to move
31.
those sneaky players they know all the
rules they know all the loopholes
oh wow wow okay well this means in
roughly 20 minutes or so that these two
players will return to that table and
Magnus Carlson will have 10 minutes on
the clock Wesley say will have seven and
Magnus will be in a must win situation
somehow other there will be a decisive
result between the two but it does mean
that Magnus will get off the scoring
board yeah and maybe we can just show
that final position for the sake of
completeness sorry Judith no you're
seeing action elsewhere yeah action
elsewhere in with Anish game finally
what we were expecting already for so
long it has exploded and just to show
that final position between Magnus
Carlson and Wesley so we left it here
black is one upon but white has
dominance in the center and blacks
Bishops a bit uh a bit stuck white
played Rook A1 after the queen Retreats
A4 and actually on the nines you
predicted Judith Black's Bishop dropped
back protecting this pawn and after Rook
a two King F7 Wesley offered the draw
Magnus accepted that offer and I guess
it's because neither side can really
improve their position this Pawn is a
bit stuck if it ever advances it will be
captured and Black's pieces tied down
defending it White's pieces tied down
attacking it and uh yeah ultimately
Dynamic quality as they say I wouldn't
offer a draw
as black as black you'd want to play on
and win
but Wesley happy I think with that
resultant confident of his chances in
the Armageddon not wasting energy yeah
preserving energy black against the
world number one makes sense but you
also mentioned that finally explosion
happening let's go to Anish with Fabiano
I think there is something to talk about
yeah you've been uh highlighting this
peace sacrifice waiting for it it's the
Middle Ages
and it's finally appeared on the board
uh well Anish has decided that he wants
to sacrifice a piece in order to get a
very impressive porn Santa and let's get
that board up and whoa
anything can happen you know look at
that night on C4 it's stranded it's a
loose piece D5 is in the equation and
how is black going to untangle
themselves
yeah it's not easy for black right now
it looks like Anish found the opportune
moment to sacrifice the piece uh improve
his Pawn structure create all these
threats right now black is a knight for
just one Pawn up but yeah suddenly
threats in the air maybe we can do a
quick recap of how we got here it's only
been a few moves uh since that big
moment when white started pushing with
the H Pawn and it looks like Anish has
outplayed Fabiano to a certain extent
from a difficult position uh here we saw
H4 black didn't go for any of the plans
we highlighted instead a bit of a
mysterious move Queen C6 I don't really
get the point behind that one I've got
to say he dropped the Knight back now
and after a rook trade Rook D1 we saw
Rook D7
and queen A1 hoping to maybe get to the
A2 square or Bishop A4 also oh nice
Bishop A4 big threats on the board
potentially in some Lions Queen C8 and
Knight D4 landed finally before it's too
late before black gets ready and after
that night was captured
E5 has just been played yeah
okay so Fabiano hoping for onpassant
here he wants this Pawn to be captured
potentially but uh yeah what is his plan
after Knight takes can the white not
step forward in the center hitting this
Knight hitting this bishop
he has to give the piece back
looks like black has to give back the
material will this game fizzle out
towards a draw
if black gives back the piece on D5 well
maybe that's the case
yeah
this is the feeling I have
position like this white is a pawn down
but with the bishop pair feels like it
should be full compensation
um maybe the white Bishop will at some
point it can land on D4 right now and
also I don't know if Queen E5 is
possible first and then give the threat
of Bishop D4
yeah suddenly a bit scary uh everything
is still possible so this is one line if
a niche wants something relatively safe
where he's just a pawn down and uh looks
like he's got great compensation what
else could white consider pushing D5 now
feels slightly less uh intuitive because
black can give back the piece under more
favorable circumstances here you're
still a pawn down but black has these
two connected pass pawns it feels like
more risk for white and not necessarily
more reward
yeah I don't see uh too much here for
white uh in terms of counter-attacking
while the black pawns could potentially
win the game so what do we think is not
gonna happen I believe that probably C
takes B6 uh
is the right way at the same time it's
not the most obvious you don't want to
give up those
Collective passports especially that
after B5 is a really past spawn on C5
right before it was not a passport but
after B5 it could be but the C4 Knight
is just uh such a strong Outpost
that I don't think there is any time
that D5 could be strong
ER than now and that means that black
can sacrifice back the piece
and have a very strong position
yeah you can't play around this piece
sometimes a strong Knight you could kind
of just play around it and yeah he has
gone for that most logical of moves
we're expecting Knight takes B6 now and
then D5 white will win the piece back
and uh still everything to play for in
that position after black gives back the
piece on D5 yeah I was just gonna say I
love uh Boris girl fans line about
sacrificial players this goes um
secret goal of every gambiter is to win
back the material they sacrifice
apart from Kingston
they just want to check mate
but they might get checkmated in 13
moves
and okay this is all happening at
lightning fast speed uh body language
it's hard to tell who's most confident
here it looks like Anish is relieved
maybe I yeah I think Anisha was very
happy that he could give up with Knight
E4 and I think they both know that they
go to the Armageddon exactly yeah I
think so too and uh maybe now is the
perfect time to actually go back to the
bird's eye view and have a look at some
of the games that we haven't checked in
on a while so I'm thinking gukash
against Hikaru because that game does
look incredibly tense
yeah tense position actually on the face
of it it looks like not too much has
changed there but there have been small
and uh kind of big decisions uh at least
small decisions with big consequences
having been made over the last few moves
five on the board each other you've been
predicting it for a long time yeah yeah
I was waiting it for a long time to see
F5 on the board because it's blocking
the D3 very powerful Bishop and the the
E5 square of course it's a huge weakness
of Black's position the only weakness
but the D5 Bishop is also so extremely
powerful of Black's position right the
black Rook was forced to go back to AAA
to protect the A6 spawn but look at the
bishop play by Hikaru moving it from
maneuvering from E7 through d8 to B6
attacking on D4
it looks like very promising at the same
time this Knight on B3
seemed to be that it gives lot of
unpleasantness for white
and it's attacking the D4 but I'm not
sure it can give deadly big dangers for
white after white is going let's say
Bishop E5 here
yeah and uh just to put this on the
board Bishop E5 and some of our viewers
might be wondering why isn't black going
to take on F3 why does black not just
shatter the white Pawn structure now
yeah maybe he will I guess we'll see a
queen trade and the question is can
black grab this Pawn on D4
this is what Hikaru is aiming for well
now the F5 shows its weaknesses right
once you lose your uh you give up the
Bishop from D5 that's another story
having F5 it's already not funny having
Bishop C4 or after Knight D4 capturing
and the E6 is uh taken and then actually
white can get a better position yeah
suddenly real weaknesses in the black
Camp maybe this F5 Pawn the A6 Pawn
whites Rooks more active than that no
big deal A5 yeah bishop and D4 is just
so powerful Hikaru will hold this if it
comes down to it yeah but the Hikaru is
behind in time he has only 18 minutes
a while go cash has 26.
and it's not an easy position yeah
do you think uh given the opportunity
he'll head into that end game where
he'll most likely make a draw because
he's down on time or will he keep the
tension for example if white does just
play a move like Bishop E5 will he uh
just say okay I'm just going to maybe
play a move like A5 first or I don't
know play a useful improvement with
rookie eight and just sit on the
position I think it depends very much
how he feels if he feels extremely
comfortable that he cannot get
endangered and he's absolutely going to
be waiting uh
for for some opportunity
it does feel like black can actually
wait and make an improving move like A5
like you suggested and then okay not
Bishop E5 Queen E5 oh
feels Brave it yeah because it does
allow Bishop takes but I just don't
understand this move
what does he want the queen is not
necessarily a great piece here it's
relied on tactics Bishop F3 he wants to
take on E6 and check on B3 yeah tricky
tricky guy young players they hold
things together with tactics
yes and uh well we are leaving you all
on a cliffhanger because we are going to
take a short pause and uh when the
action resumes well we will be treated
to an Armageddon game between Magnus and
Wesley
looking for a new way to learn chess
meet Dr Wolf the ideal chess coach and
companion
play against Dr Wolf as he explains
everything step by step points out
strategic ideas and alerts you to your
mistakes
train with him and go over your past
mistakes until you master them
choose from over 35 lessons created for
all skill levels no matter your level
everyone could use a coach download
Learn chess with Dr Wolf for Android or
iOS devices today
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
our first Armageddon game of the day
between Magnus Carlsen and this man
Wesley so he's been three-time U.S
Champion two three-time Philippine
Champion 2022 chess.com Global champion
and they left the player to pass the
2800 barrier and he's also been the
Champions chess tour Nemesis for world
champion Magnus Carlsen oh he is quite
the contender
what is his chances
yeah he played a great game against
Magnus in the classical I think his
chances are pretty decent shooter
absolutely I cannot agree with David on
that and he's a very stable player right
he's like rock solid and uh but of
course it's not so easy I think for the
players to switch in their mind that now
draw is clearly a victory for Wesley
right so Magnus should go out double or
nothing and I'm also expecting something
sharper somehow to get out of the
comfort zone right Magnus of course with
10 minutes on the clock to Wesley seven
Wesley seven minutes and Magnus being in
a must win situation he needs to
unsettle Wesley and the two have
actually played many times before and I
can remember that in their last
Armageddon encounter last year Wesley
playing with the white pieces actually
beat Magnus
okay and those types of uh stats those
types of head-to-heads will be on the
player's mind as they play the game a
bit later Magnus it feels like you need
something a bit special a bit different
against Wesley this time but we await
the beginning of that game definitely
and whilst we are waiting for that game
perhaps we should check out the
Armageddon format because this is what
makes Norway chess super exciting and
unique I do think every tournament
should have an Armageddon in the case of
a draw and uh here we can see that the
players will be playing with the same
colors that they played the classical
game white 10 minute black seven minutes
there's a small twist just to make life
easier for the players because one
second will be added per move after move
40. it ain't much but it's something and
it's of course is a one and a half
points for win and 1.4 a loss and black
will win with a draw
yeah we've seen three Armageddon games
so far three games yesterday and uh yeah
those all came down to the last few
seconds nail biting stuff and sure to
happen again but while we wait for the
game between Magnus and Wesley to begin
uh yeah shall we delve back into the
action that's a game incidentally will
be starting in approximately three
minutes so we will switch over there as
soon as it starts so
let's have a quick look at the other
games
and uh here we do have our bird's eye
view of the games we will check in on
that Armageddon soon there have been
huge developments in the clash between
ariantari and nordebec Abdul sotorov it
looks like that one has totally turned
rather than a win for white Ariana
missing a win pretty much on the spot
earlier suddenly white is two pawns down
and another Beck's gonna take the
victory surely Judith absolutely this is
what we've seen that it was a very
interesting game I must say maybe the
most interesting game of the whole
tournament so far with the crazy ideas
in the opening in the middle game
practically Tori outplayed nodier back
but there was a turning point when uh
tari played extremely fast and it meant
that things went on the downhill and now
I don't think tari has any chance to
save the game no he looks very unlikely
at this point that white can launch a
comeback and maybe we can just show an
action replay of developments because
even after missing the win he was still
in the game Aryan and suddenly things
fell apart if we backtrack just a few
moves to this position after Queen takes
F4 check we left it here the white king
did indeed poke his head out to E2 after
e takes D5 Rook F1 was the next mistake
we see the question mark attached to
this move they must have been stronger
but by this point extremely complicated
of course black played Queen E5 really
nice move there and we saw trades the
White Knight was pinned it fell off the
board and a nice tactic at this point
actually after Rook F4 it looks like
things are falling apart for black but
not a back so sharp had spotted that he
could simply take the White Queen not
worrying about the vision Zig Rook takes
G4 check because the black king can
simply March forward and after the black
queen is captured the white Rook will
drop at the end to Black having too much
material so instead of this white had to
accept this sad position and after
rotate C3
as long as Black's careful consolidates
the material two versus one on the queen
side two versus one on the king side as
well
well it happens in in different games
that once you lose the thread then
Things Fall Apart right especially if
you don't have enough time to recover
and you don't have enough time to to
analyze and say stop to yourself that
okay I screwed up it's not good but
don't go all the way it's you can still
save the game
yeah still some saving chances for uh
Ariane if he's lucky the bishop better
than Knights normally when their pawns
on both sides of the board reduce the
material of course but we're expecting a
black win in that game I mean while we
see
Wesley first to arrive at the board
he's ready seven minutes it's not a lot
on the clock he's got to be fast he's
got to be quick he certainly has to be
very light fingered with his pieces and
he has to be prepared to hold because
I'm sure that Magnus will come at him do
you think he will employ the mama jar of
approach which is just sacrifice the
pawn go straight for the king my bomb in
the bag
I think he has to come up with with
something special because if it would be
a very slow game as it was the classical
I don't think then he has so many
chances I think it's very important to
unbalance your opponent when you play
with the white pieces definitely you
have to win and we just see what's going
on on the board
and so far it's a repeat the Berlin
defense exactly what we saw earlier the
players are going copycat style wow what
is Magnus got up his sleeve is he just
gonna play a 100 move Game beat Wesley
on the clock so far okay first deviate
deviation from that point the white
Bishop comes out to G5
painting black snake this is rare
normally uh the white Bishop doesn't
really want to necessarily give itself
up for a black knight but Magnus forcing
Wesley to think it's only move seven and
the players have only used a few seconds
up to this point where you can see
Wesley is surprised I was gonna say I
was just looking at the database and I'm
like says there are no no there has to
be some games there are some games not
many just one
so a rare line for Magnus absolutely
well it's a provocation Bishop G5 Bishop
H4 or that's how I'm taking it but let's
go play G5 and then we'll see but of
course Wesley is more solid than that
yeah and I must admit I'm surprised to
see Magnus try and strike in the center
uh he's pushed the white d-pawn for a
second time in this game losing a bit of
time there and now big moment which way
does Wesley Castle he casts was Queen
side I think that's a great move and it
shows Wesley Is Not Afraid at all black
has everything covered and uh yeah black
is actually ahead of development
potentially white is the one with a lot
of ground to cover in the middle of the
board and you mentioned the provocations
unit the advance has begun Wesley
stepping forward pushing pawns kicking
the black uh the white Bishop away from
the PIN
I don't understand what Magnus is doing
here what his plan is well he's
attacking one in the center on E5 what
can Wesley do Knight D7
just here hold the foot step back brace
for impact
then Knight C4 so
but I mean can't you go yeah Knight I
was going to say H5 as well is this a
bone sacrifice Knight H5 good move
yeah maybe a pawn sacrifice but a lot of
activity around the white king
looks like one-way traffic in terms of
who's playing for the initiative right
now
yeah I would be shaking my head too I've
got to admit I just don't think that
this is the type of position that can be
easy to play in an Armageddon let alone
creating winning chances for white it
looks like Black's having all the fun
and it's far quicker uh far easier
speedier to attack than it is to defend
and is black actually threatening to
capture that pawn in the middle of the
board so I'm going to take Bishop to
xifa
might as well suffer for something right
Judith yeah and I hope for the best
yeah but you guys did perfectly but
you're gonna suffer quite a bit because
after all the exchanges there is night
in F3
yeah so Magnus wasn't attracted by that
and instead reinforces the center well
he has a queen A4 in the pipeline
but his position doesn't look
all that
if I'm being honest
yeah an easy moves for for Wesley so he
just trades in the center opening things
up for his his Bishops isn't this a pawn
by the way if she takes D4 Bishop takes
G3 and Rook D4
yeah
it looks like it's falling apart for
white
it's what has Magnus got up his sleeve
he was the one who chose this opening
variation he did not surprise Wesley in
the end clock time still looking healthy
for Wesley over five minutes Magnus just
under the eight minute mark
time to actually come up with the queen
to A4
counter-attack Ivanka you want to go
after this loose A7 Pawn go for the
black king at least maybe gain a Tempo
in the process looks logical but some
calculation needs to be done there
Magnus burning the clock
yeah I do like uh this comment which
says no keep the faith get brace
yourself for a brilliant move from
Magnus
he needs one he does need one I mean his
position looks like he's losing control
yeah and long think now over one minute
and then in an Armageddon game this is
potentially crucial what does he do now
he does simply capture and your question
now Judah is going to be answered can
black simply grab a pawn
take this bishop take this Pawn on D4
there's a pin this Knight is pinned so
the default Pawn is not truly protected
maybe he's just gonna gamble there just
move his queen and I hope for the best
I don't see it I think he can be greedy
here Wesley
well let's see if he's going to be
greedy
yeah other options maybe include
bringing the bishop to B4 creating a
double pin
this Diagon of this diagonal if you want
to be fancy but
he does go for that idea there we go
I mean you still have Knight takes
Bishop on your pocket and then the plan
of actually opening up the H line
yeah did you see Wesley looked up at the
screen where he can see what move number
it is he's already thinking about
getting to move 40 getting that one
second increment but it's only move 15.
miles away from that
he has he has a lot of moves to make
okay the query sacrifice Bishop F3
exchange is gone wow but if you're in a
in a situation where a draw is equal to
a win are you going to gamble with those
type of moves
Queen A4 that Magnus has just played
yeah yeah he is gambling well yeah
exactly but grabbing the material well
where's Lea you know he's a cool
customer he says yes absolutely so he's
going to take that rook and is Magnus
going to meet a capture of his Rook by
taking this black A7 Pawn
yeah but it is a rook it's a true gamble
yeah I don't know if you have any check
meeting attacks there
just have to hope for the best but it
feels like if you don't play that you're
just material down for free
he has to take this
yeah and the idea is to bring the white
knight forward to take away the black
King's Escape square but wow nice move
from Wesley there were some tactics
there the black queen was threatening to
go back to A5
but
or takes first he trades but now there's
no background checkmate at least for
white the white King has some breathing
space so the White Knight can jump 95 on
G4 maybe
it's an opportunity
big threat Knight E5 takes away the
black King's Escape Square Queen A8 will
be a Checkmate Wesley needs something
now well can you not play F3 oh sorry F6
yeah classy control that white knight
exactly then I go E5
E6 another Checkmate
oh nothing gets past you uh whoa I think
Knight G3 I'm not sure it was good this
was a great gamble Suddenly at least
there's attacking chances and he's
forced Wesley to think three and a half
minutes for Wesley so he's not coming
back only one second increment after
move 40.
whites got a decision to make now no
Queen trade surely maybe you can give a
check to the black kid I can't come back
to A4 right
there we go he's gonna play that
Queen back somewhere
and the black king is out in the open
Magnus is back in business
at least it's double edged now it's
extremely complicated he's got a knight
and a pawn for The Rook
and three minute time advantage and uh
could Wesley try to play it safe and to
actually step back with the King to C8
and say you know what I'm gonna house my
king on B8 and if you want the draw
you're welcome to it I think that was
the best move actually
yeah that's decision
because
F5 D5 look at that wow he took a leaf
out of your book Ivanka just controlling
that White Knight with F6 Wesley so but
suddenly Magnus has the time to open
things up that black king
it might be in huge trouble he goes back
and how does Magnus continue now and
Wesley again looking up he's trying to
check what move number it is he's
struggling now under three minutes but
it's also the tension I think that he's
just enough
really dense
now how to continue five of course of
course A5
better the flow now Magnus push forward
at any cost
but uh can the king not hide itself on
B8
Safety First when you have this type of
limited time but then already you can go
eat takes F6 takes on D5 F7 Knight D5
you protect I mean
[Laughter]
he does hide the black king on B8 we're
expecting Magnus now to either push or
take this Pawn I think take it I think
take it on F6 yeah open up your Rook get
that pass Pawn
he's got to make a decision Magnus
Carlsen he's maybe mulling over even
capturing on C6 first though after he
takes F6 maybe Rook f8
just to hunt down this Pawn Yeah makes a
lot of sense will we see that variation
Wesley head in hands
he goes for it oh fumbling the pieces
there Magnus a bit of nerves potentially
no his Pawn has landed on F7 where is
rookie 895
big big Initiative for white great
compensation for the material look at
this look at this past Pawn on F7 maybe
it's time to actually
um try and trade us Queens
yeah white will not agree to that trade
though surely yeah the queen slide okay
the queen oh 95 95 threats now night
Forks all over the place
and
can he play it now yeah but what is this
can you give a check Wesley's banking on
the fact that he can give back some
material the White Knight can jump into
D7 with a family Fork there but it will
be captured immediately
should be winning you feel like for
Magnus he's got the safer King if he
wins back the material but still some
calculation to be done
and uh well Magnus plenty of time on the
clock he is just under four and a half
minutes
this is a very critical position
Wesley has two minutes to make 13 moves
what do you think about Queen Queen D7
beautiful you're smiling on communities
Queen to D7 hoping the only thing I
don't see the threat
yeah I don't see the threat either but
beautiful move though and it was forced
Wesley to think
can you
use the idea and play Queen to E8
yeah there would have been some tactics
there I'm not sure it was quite working
out but Magnus is going for direct
Checkmate he's lifted his Rook up
shifting it across the board
Queen E8 was a mate threat so black has
had to play C6 opening up space for his
King
he's got a run just like ariantario in
his game the King has got to go on a
walk
but Magnus is hunting it down
surely this is winning for white Judy
you're the attacker here is this
decisive
continue B3
Rigby three looks good
Wesley at this point looks up more in
Hope than expectation he's only got one
minute and 52 seconds and looks like the
black king is not going to survive that
long
and you do feel that there are some
ideas of Knight takes porn as well
Knight takes C6 threatened Knight takes
Rook on F7 threatened
or maybe now your idea yes
and I can capture on C6 there might be
better that might be even stronger maybe
just Queen B6 check
yeah take the material back and then go
for checkmate after
well if King CA then yeah but also look
F3
F3 could be a killer in the next couple
of moves he plays it immediately dude a
nice spot there
full board awareness and that one is
entering the seventh rank ah
no it's it's one The Rook is it's game
over it's game over
you can still oh no still not
one check and it's over
check check
the game what a game what a gamble by
Magnus Carson and there he takes it he
played a very risky game but he gets
away with it and he merges with a win in
Armageddon and he will walk away with
one and a half points and Wesley just
won
Magnus must be thanking his lucky stars
there because
that was
an incredible
attack at the end yeah and it came out
of nowhere the opening cannot be
classified as a success for Magnus
Carlsen but he turned it around he
turned on the style when he needed to
Judith yeah it's absolutely though I'm
just uh
rethinking how how was it were these
moves and which was really the Turning
Point here right that he made an awful
opening and when things went really
wrong then he shaked himself and said
okay come on I mean it's time to play
well
right
somehow this is the feeling I had and
then he shifted to gear five and then
probably from one point on from D5 E5
I wouldn't be surprised if he would just
making the best moves
yeah I mean when he was given the
initiative and the chance to hunt the
king he was just simply Relentless and
you felt like Wesley was powerless but
oh in the meantime we do have a result
in the classical portion and the we can
see by the body language of the players
Nordic Abdus
beat Ari antari and let's three points
some very important points you know some
very important points and it could have
been a totally different story here
Harry and Harry had a win in basically
one move but uh he missed the
opportunity and Abdul satorov discussing
the game now I wonder whether they see
it I wonder whether they both realized
that white had a winning move I have the
feeling that Nadia Burke realized it
because it happens very often that you
make a move and then you realize it oops
oops it's something really bad and these
are not good moments for Atari I mean
when you lose a winning position
especially if your opponent was or going
to tell you where you really missed your
opportunity
and it's nice to see them discussing the
game but heartbreaking stuff Ariana
played so well just not rewarded and
actually that game was about to end in a
mating attack it was about to end in
Checkmate uh so yeah really brutal
turnaround really brutal finish
certainly and I do think that an order
Beck was showing Ariane how he could
have won because they were their
gesturing kind of
correlated with the moves that we had
highlighted of the queen jacking and
then G3 ah okay you saw them looking
yeah they were looking at that square
and then Arya was talking about
G3
um I was surprised actually not to see
Aryan shake his head a bit more than if
he'd realized if either player had
realized I would be crying I would be
running out of there if I had missed
lettering opportunity and my opponent
had told me immediately afterwards the
RN is not that kind of person I mean I I
when I've pointed out stuff to him he's
always kind of like oh yeah smart on his
face okay
no worries
well this was a great opportunity for
him but he missed it but he was very
close
yeah definitely a lot to learn from
those games but uh we still have three
classical games continuing shall we take
a quick peek at how they're getting on
some very interesting things happening
between alireza and shock
we are so some strange things spawns are
missing where you're supposed to see one
on the board
yeah it just looks so Random the
position now and uh it looks like mama
jorov has definitely lost control it
looks promising for black but we see the
evaluation bar up on white side so maybe
a miscalculation from Mama jarov this
one is going to be a scramble seven and
a half minutes against eight minute 43
and uh this is the current position it
looks on the face of things Judith like
the white king is in so much trouble on
this diagonal but there's no knockout
blow at the same time look at the bishop
on D4 before it was standing on F2 with
very passive uh location for the bishop
and after somehow grabbing the pawn on
the on C5 from D4 then it has a
fantastic outpost on D4 and okay we
shouldn't forget that the B1 Bishop is
also extremely powerful G3 Queen stands
very well the only problem for white is
that the G2 Pawn is missing and there is
a back rank problem possibly
it's one or two things one or two small
things small details
wow and maybe my major have got to this
position instinctively he thought okay
there's going to be something on the on
the diagonal bit here but uh if there's
no breakthrough you could just be lost
I don't see a move here for black simply
this Rook is attacked and
you don't really want to start trading
everything off here I mean you can't
take this Pawn because of Checkmate
whoops
on G7 well it's a question Knight D1
would be something uh to look for right
so what happens after Knight D1 if yeah
let's jump in Knight D1
really tricky move there great practical
very tricky because you cannot capture
on F6 right because of rookie one
checking G2 Knight E3 and then Bishop C8
for example nice and black is winning
so that's why white has to be extremely
careful yeah but there are some
Desperado checks in the air for white
so for instance you could go Bishop H7
that was one move
that caught my out the way yeah and take
the Knight that was one off to Dad
I wasn't sure I think black is having a
fantastic position so it's like really
it can shift from one move to another
yeah Knight D1 what is the solution
there is it just a rook slide do I just
threaten Checkmate maybe yeah maybe just
Rook G2 and everything is protected by
white I cover the E1 Square now so no
tracks and it's easy to blunder that all
these things just work out for white
yeah I mean it could be turning out that
uh this Black Knight is lost
this one I see in the featured chat that
farrugia will grind this out to a win
maybe he'll win spectacularly uh looks
like this one is going in either
direction wow it's on the board Knight
D1 Rook G2 and G5
with white he plays G4 with black he
plays G5 we talked about it if you don't
play G4 or G5 nowadays you're out of
fashion
that's why I'm such an unfashionable guy
yeah it's a force of habit by now G5 and
I mean how do we unpick this chaos I
mean it's just wild isn't it
um okay so in these type of positions
it's very much move by move so we have
to go for the checks the captures and
the threats
and if they fail then simply develop and
that would be the light squared Bishop
so
is there anything wrong with actually
capturing the night sorry The Rook The
Rook is what I wanted
yeah I guess so you know after Bishop F6
Queen F3 is killer
whoa I think
let's jump in six minute 50 for furusia
we have to analyze this bishop takes I
mean there are crazy lines right Bishop
F6 Queen F3 you cannot take Queen F3
because Rook D1 and Bishop F3 mate
you've done your puzzle rush dude
it was just an instincts at this point
attacking and check mating okay so after
Queen F3
it's game over right
Rook check is the threat well actually
eight seven will not help you I guess
because the pawn on G5 so King H7
Community seven King G6 look at this now
you sneak out onto H4
King march check and no more checks or
no more good checks
you can take this but it's not going to
end in Checkmate because I can drop back
and block at the very end what a long
variation that is like 10 moves and it
turns out black is fine with the king or
nature yeah because it goes on the X on
H5 takes on D1 but black is not taking
on G2 but rookie two yeah
pin and win at the very end after Rook
G1
I mean literally yeah okay
engage four king H3 that's more
instructive wait H3 King H3 you have
move it's no stalemate yeah
almost stalemate oh so close I got
excited there oh dear so this is all
forced super fast losing it foreign
position he cannot play the most obvious
move on the position he would lose on
the spot Bishop takes for it but there
are other moves that he can play which
are just at attacking which follow the
rules of calculation which is Bishop E4
and this last one is Bishop H7 and if
those don't work then
okay
we simply improve but Bishop E4 this one
looks good Rook takes Bishop takes
Bishop it might be very important that
here the black okay I was gonna say the
black Rook uh can to give a check but
the white Bishop can slide back here I
guess
maybe black can just take the spawn as
white is all tied up look at this King
in the corner smothered by its own
pieces and uh Bishop takes Rook takes E4
what therefore is the winning move for
white
um so you you could now go Bishop takes
work
or you could also go Rook text Knight so
suddenly everything is hanging for black
The Rook the Knight the house is falling
yeah and you have ideas of Bishop takes
G5 as well I think that's the the key
point that after Rook moves back to E6
or somewhere then Bishop G5
yeah and uh oh tactics but either way it
looks complicated but in White's favor
uh so right now or not at least until
Bishop takes G5 I think maybe we can
just take the knight in that case but
Bishop E4 looks like a killer move
or at least it looks like a good move
and this position yeah I think just here
we mentioned just for a taste night and
there'll be some nasty checks for white
to give as well in something it should
be four is on the board yeah I found it
great move yeah and uh talking about the
clock situation it's move 34 and of
course the players will get us 10 second
increment per move once they pass move
40. so farida not in any serious time
travel
serious he's in time travel but not
serious time travel he's had worse
yesterday was far worse from farrugia uh
the clock handling there
and look at the two Bishops what a
beautiful place in the on the board E4
and E4 yeah I was thinking of getting my
first ever tattoo and it would be two
Bishops
I'm just yeah I'm not sure I'm brave
enough but the bishop here when they're
working together in tandem like this
it's beautiful
E4 yeah looks like a killer move and
later we want to talk about the two
Bishops uh in the Nakamura game he has
the bishop pair there and potentially an
advantage as well
yeah Bishop's dominating Knights look at
that Black Knight
gone off the board in the next couple of
moves yeah
and I'm just looking at uh I was going
to check the engine just to find out
yeah only one move to stay in the game
somewhat and that's you have to capture
that Bishop as we predicted and now
it takes work yeah and that's the only
move it's immediately played by farooza
yeah he's worked it all out he paused
for a minute or two but a good
investment on the clock still five moves
to make before but I have a question
what happens if Queen F6
wow okay let's jump back in Queen takes
F6 there's two tempting moves there for
black uh either we give a check on B8
yes and then I go King G7 okay after
taking the bishop I want to go Rook E7
aha
do I take the bishop maybe I've messed
it up already rookie seven you're
blocked you're fine yeah you've blocked
and you've got some check counter-attack
ideas you've got Rook G1 yeah yeah so in
this position after Queen takes F6 do I
just recapture the Knight instead maybe
but what was wrong with that position
for white oh uh sorry uh let's go back
there sorry for this final position oh
this one is also good
what did you want to make here just
dropped the bit drop the queen back to
D5 then Knight E3 ah or you go Queen A8
yes yes yes yes yes yes and it's all
gone wrong Queen A8 it feels like a loss
of control either way even yeah I mean
C3 is also hanging kind of right even if
black takes here and starts motoring
these pawns wild unclear so let's go
back to the position uh Queen takes F6 I
think it's a good practical try dude you
mentioned it but maybe just Rook takes
Knight
yeah and then I wanted to go Rook F4
nice block my I mean somehow trying to
survive right but but now I can check
and win your Bishop
oh because it's been no but there's a
Queen City one at the end of it I'm
blind this would be a check and black is
the one winning yeah wait
takes F6 Queen takes F6 this is still so
crazy I think Shakura should just take
this piece and hope for the best
well probably he does not have too many
other options right yeah just take this
bishop right now
oh but wait one second if you take the
bishop
how is the double
um the end game with two Rooks versus a
queen
oh Queen to be a chuck
king move take and you want to give up
your queen here yes
yeah this one if this white Point
survived one more move I think maybe but
here Queen takes porn and yeah yeah the
white Rock's not coordinated but look at
that we are going to have some fire
because uh mama jarov is going down to
two minutes what firoza also not full of
time but he has only three and a half ah
you can see visibly nervous now mama
jarov
the body language tells it all
lots of hide your emotions when you've
only got two minutes and when you have
this position and you have to calculate
Non-Stop
and you may lose in one move
you're supposed to move something he
looks like he's reaching for his Rook
Rook to E3 something we didn't consider
but immediately a question mark pops up
on the screen
this looks natural to me but what has he
missed
looks like there might be a king walk
incoming from the black king
but what is the threat I mean can you
not capture Bishop G5 right yes there's
that this one this one there's two moves
two main moves to consider Rook takes
Knight or Bishop takes Pawn no Bishop
takes Pawn he wants to go to F3 that's
what he wants to Rook takes F3 and
counter attack and if Queen B8 check
just rook f8 and everything is pinned
and everything is hanging
stuff uh it is crazy stuff and well
whilst we are going to stay on this
super exciting game The Press did catch
up with Magnus after his Armageddon win
over Wesley so let's see what he had to
say
end up with a win today how important is
that for the confidence in this
tournament
I'm not sure about the confidence like
the game that I won was pretty poor but
I mean at least
uh getting to to attack him was was fun
did you feel he had any chances in the
classical game today
[Music]
um
that's a difficult question like I felt
that I was probably a little bit better
uh or not really better
um but that my position was slightly
easier to play but real chance is
probably not
you're saying it's uh hard to assess
your real chances there was quite a bit
of a tipsy-turvy Armageddon game there
we went up and down how would you
summarize it well it mostly went down
and then it went up
good luck tomorrow reminders thank you
thank you
Magnus still showing us he has a sense
of humor as he loves that at the end and
here are today's scores Magnus hot
Carlson winning the Armageddon game does
walk away with one and a half points and
for noribbeck Abdus he won in the
classical game against orientari and
therefore gets three points with the
other games everything is still yet to
play for and we are going to rejoin that
super exciting action here in the game
between alireza farouza with the white
pieces against shakuria mamajarov and
the clock is ticking down and the
position is completely mad anything can
happen all three results possible
although it does look like according to
the evaluation bar that white is winning
well the reason is because Rook F1 would
seem to be a very tempting move to play
Queen G2 Checkmate in the next but
unfortunately Rook F1 would be with the
check and the other problem for black
Rook F2 is another very important idea
but then white is going to be
sacrificing the queen on B7 and after
that taking with the bishop The Rook so
I don't see
exactly how black and uh survive because
we still can make some random moves like
F4
yeah yeah Rook F4 a rook G1
and then yeah but you know once pieces
are very much tied down and so you can
still kind of go H5
slowly no I I I want to play something
and also don't forget we have B4 as well
in the air
and don't forget we know this bishop is
super important that uh there is a
bishop on D4 willing to come back to G1
yeah not right now but uh in some
variations if there's a back rank check
the bishop can block so right now we're
expecting uh Refugee one just defending
the Checkmate threat on G2
but it's interesting what do you think
after Rook G1 to go Rook G4
but then maybe work
one second or we see a king walk in it
it's gonna get crazy of course the king
woke
yeah maybe he has to go for this he has
to gamble managerov if we reach move 40
oh we're about to reach me 40 next and
uh he's still a rook down then he
is unlikely to save the game 20 seconds
15 seconds for Mom and jar of he's gonna
make details two moves in ten seconds
no increment yet
Queen swoops into F3 still no threat
this bishop on D4 is an amazing Defender
enough for Rouge 30 seconds to make his
final move before getting 10 second
increment
wow this is the hardest moment to pick I
would just throw in a check and then I
would just go Bishop G1 but that's the
thing David you can throw in the check
but you only get a 10 second respite the
action is still gonna keep pounding whoa
H3 given a question mark there we saw
briefly and
turns away Queen takes H3 has he lost on
time
no he's was he just resigned
I think he might have resigned no
I think he looks I think
judging by his body language it does
appear
lost on time well he lost to find out I
think he loves the game that's very
clear of the body language and the
position also
proves that yeah his position was losing
but it must have been the clock he had
five seconds to make his final move
maybe he just wasn't in time zero zero
zero yeah we see on the screen
confirmation we see the clock has ticked
down he didn't execute the move in the
allotted time there and it was difficult
he was going to be a piece down anyway
with the Lost position that's yeah
disaster for mamajara ferrugia bouncing
back after yesterday's loss yes and uh
whilst there are still two games in
operation can we pop in to the good cash
Hikaru Nakamura because there it looks
like Hikaru is firmly in the driving
seat
yeah very much indeed
see it on the camera we talked about the
bishop pair my favorite pieces in Chess
Black's two Bishops are just controlling
everything the White Knight looks nice
but hitting thin air right now
black is also pulled up with full
control yeah
do you foresee any any comeback here
true that any chances of A Swindle well
I think there is only a blunder option
for black
not to win the game but it seems like
it's very close
the moment where some extra more
material will be
gone don't forget the players are
playing on seconds they will be
receiving a 10 second increment per move
that's it and uh
the queen comes to E3 and there we see
the belief that hikaru's fans have
another they will win this yep and
Bishop coming to D4 well good cash oh
[Music]
okay the white Bishop drops back hitting
the black queen the black Bishop in the
center is pinned The Black Queen needs
to move but yeah Kara still has things
under control it Queen trade will favor
Black maybe Whitehead another bishop
move Bishop B1 or something
right some tactics were in the air but
no time yeah
and uh Hikaru 37 yeah Knight C6 you can
do that but Bishop takes porn yes
that's the difference I think Judith the
bishop if it had occupied any other
Square for white I would have uh kept
the connection between White's Rook on
D2 and the pawn on F2 though
yeah keep things under control
looks nice and healthy
now no more checks killing move yeah
oh I could cash fought so hard he carved
out a chance from nothing just as we
jumped in but Hikaru now with 30 seconds
should be enough
root trade is not going to help White's
pawns are all dropping all too weak Pawn
down as well
maybe he will try not at E5 Bishop F6
Knight C4 trying to escape the different
color bishop and game
yeah but there's a pawn hanging on A4 as
well this
of two point disadvantage unlikely to
save him he's fighting to the better end
though
he's still fighting so good oh Bishop F6
Bishop C4 exactly at least you're eyeing
up the E6 Pawn
wow and I did just check kukesh would
have had the advantage if he had put his
Bishop on a different square a big
Advantage for white instead of Bishop
yeah wow so there was a mutual blunder
that shows how decided decisive the
clock times can be but in the end
too difficult and uh unfortunately his
instincts led him down there go cash
okay will Hikaru cling on here 20
seconds against 20. hmm
should be a win this absolutely should
be a win also
that is Bishop F6 attacking the knight
in the air
yeah it's looking good Bishop power just
too strong
cash fighting for his life okay it's
down to one Pawn the deficit now still
some chances
but only seconds
Arrow has seven seconds okay looks
nervous visibly you see him counting
there with his fingers Bishop F6 he's
allowing a simplification down to an
opposite color picture bending but he
will be that he will be ahead sorry to
Pawns
and okay a check the black king has to
move B3 yep he's fighting for his life
kukash definitely he does if I sing
admirably
and the black Bishop will move out the
way black will create a pawn uh passport
on the queen side is that enough
car is shaking his head
yeah realizing that they should have
should have won the game already
you should have won the game but he's
still winning if he can hold his nerve
this
feels like Armageddon even though it's
the classical portion of the event still
and okay Hikaru repeating gaining a bit
of time or at least asking the white
king to go back where it came from
he's hitting pawns on both sides of the
board that's why the Bishops are so
strong
and we will update you all on the other
results the classical game between Anish
giri and Fabiana caruana is about to be
drawn
so we will see more chest today more
action in Armageddon absolutely and uh
that's our favorite part of the event
it's so unique and there we see cash
attack hikaru's Pawn
actually he's giving a good fight
I can't really nearly touched the piece
and then he took his hand back he was
like sorry I'm gonna play something else
he was about to push his e-pawn forward
it's getting more and more difficult for
him to convert his Advantage I mean
he has an extra Pawn but now you have to
put effort probably King F7 F6 G5
yeah things are disappearing from the
board so drawing chances may be
increasing but black should have enough
enough pawns remaining
I'm impressed the players are still
writing down their moves with only a 10
second increment well probably it's they
have to right I think they have to but
uh gukesh now down under 10 seconds and
it has to make a move oh two seconds
left when he made that move the black
king is coming though Judy the remaining
piece the remaining uh forces in Black's
Army are being activated
oh the White Knight having to retreat
some really bad squares but still
fighting
forward with his King increase his time
30 seconds
he tells but somehow you feel that both
players are super stressed this is not
calm Chess By Any Means
oh and we do have confirmation that the
other remaining classical game between
Anish giri and Fabiano caruana was a
draw in an opposite color bishop and
game so we will see the Armageddon clash
between those two in around 20 minutes
time
meanwhile all eyes on gakesh against
Nakamura now Bishop G4 is inside
oh five seconds for the youngster he
defends his Pawns
black still needs to create that past
Pawn well Bishop E6 is something to
consider for Nakamura right yeah is he
going to be simplifying is it the best
way to win
and uh you see he comes from jumping
indecisive that he was reaching for the
King when he changed his mind and said
we know let's put my Bishop on a stable
Square
I love what gokash has been doing though
he's made it really difficult for the
black king to enter to break into the
white half black still maneuvering
around with the Bishops feels like
Hikaru doesn't want to commit yet to a
specific place
I thought maybe A4 and Bishop A2 could
be an option but Knight D2
he's gonna go for the other plan you
mentioned Judah he's going to make sure
the circumstances are all perfect and
then he'll trade off maybe light Squad
Bishops and run with the black king in
one of the two directions maybe against
the king side pawns on the side uh for
white there that have been abandoned
maybe he wants to go Bishop C6 and A4
after all yeah at the right moment makes
a lot of sense
but no need to rush I think really good
practical play here from Hikaru he's
just gaining 10 seconds of soft every
move asking a few little questions here
and there
is no need to rush at all
yeah and also black is preparing having
his Bishop on C3 that let's say he's
going to King F6 exchanging the bishop
The White Square Bishop let's say the
white king wants to go to the center to
D3 for F5 then A4 breakthrough right can
be an option exactly I mean that's what
I was thinking you know improve the king
as much as possible and you have an
extra Pawn on the queen side use it
they'll now probably Bishop E6 Bishop G4
Bishop F5 and the bones will fall off ah
it falls off already
yeah and uh it was said there in the
featured chat just a few minutes ago a
few moments ago but zuk Swang I think
that previous position White had to let
something go and now you know suddenly
he's forced to push pawns forced to
weaken his own pawns and one target
became two Targets the G4 Pawn now is
simply dropping
I think with it White's position falls
apart nothing left to cling to really
nice technique and kukesh does resign he
offers his hand Hikaru takes the win
oh
what a game what a victory by Hikaru
yeah I mean
it really was a very well fought game by
Hikaru first of all the opening choice
was tense it uh forced gukesh to think
and perhaps feels slightly uncomfortable
but I thought you cash actually Rose to
the channel challenge quite well and it
was a very very balanced game and then
at the end
it was just pure stress as both players
just fighting with their instincts just
to make those good moves and Hikaru
showing his class and walking away with
three points
yeah that's a very important victory for
Hikaru but we could see when he arrived
that he had all the self-confidence he
didn't pay too much attention what has
happened yesterday in the Armageddon
game
and uh and he must have felt very
comfortable and and good in in his
comfort zone going into the confessional
boost twice even I think he's doing
three times three times yeah
yeah and now mulling over the game with
his young opponents
yeah I'm looking forward to watching
that content when Hikaru does a recap
video of this really dramatic game let's
not forget though that good cash put up
a great fight and actually had one
moment where he could have struck back
uh when it looked almost hopeless
and uh I'm hoping we can do a recap of
this at some point it was really
dramatic in the end but great end game
technique yeah shows the power of the
two Bishops Hikaru Nakamura absolutely I
I would actually love to see that moment
because it was one golden opportunity
yeah and uh let's try and jump back into
that game just one key moment decided
this one or at least uh didn't give
gokash the opportunity to fight back it
was uh yeah it was a very difficult
tactic he only had 10 seconds on the
clock Hikaru was in control so uh the
momentum was on black side but it was
here that white uh missed after Bishop
D4 a big mistake actually as we see from
the question mark suddenly white could
have struck not by recruiting to E2
we'll see why this was a mistake in a
moment but if he had retreated to F1
there's a key difference and it's
something Judah pointed out suddenly if
Hikaru had fought in the game as uh if
he had continued in the same way with
Queen to E4 there's simply a capture a
night check and when the black king
moves there's Knight to C6 with a fork
double attack and white would achieve a
winning position the key detail is black
cannot take on F2 anymore because Rook
takes F2 and there's uh this is of
course a check but the Rook is connected
with this pawn it wouldn't have been so
if the white Bishop had been on E2 as in
the game so a key difference this
position is winning for black but with
the bishop on F1 would have been winning
for white
such small details decide everything
Judo and after Bishop F1 white is
running simply white is not winning but
uh I think black would have to struggle
to fight on Wow A2 or something I just
checked apparently Bishop takes A4 is
the best move but either way white has a
massive Advantage well we have to point
out that Bishop F1 is possible so there
is this checkmate
pattern right of course Bishop E2 is the
same idea what was played by uh gokash
but it was also he thought it's
important maybe that the queen is also
under attack but actually the main idea
is that there is a pattern of Checkmate
this is easy to miss right Checkmate the
king moves trapped uh all because of
that pawn on E6 and likewise if you've
gone the other way but actually I I have
the feeling that he saw the mate he just
thought that after the bishop moves it's
a pin threatens to take on B3 but he of
course did not have the time to
calculate it Bishop on E2 it blocked the
road for the Rook to defend the F2 right
and just a little nuance and this is
something that maybe he had already the
intuition that there should be something
suddenly but this is full calculation
after all that you you go all the way
the calculation and then you realize
that ah I can't have my bishop and E2 I
have to have it anywhere else right but
you also need time as well to figure out
these things out and we must remember
good cash here was playing with seconds
on his clock so it was a great find by
kakash it was just unfortunate that he
put his Bishop on the one bad square and
we shouldn't forget that basically
Nakamura out played him he played it he
did but you know opportunity is lurking
at every corner
and uh oh that's been an exciting
conclusion to a lot of the games but
there's still one game remaining there
will be an Armageddon game to decide who
wins between Anish Gary and
and Fabiana caruana and meanwhile the
players are actually
deep in thoughts deep in analysis
between yukash and Hikaru Nakamura but
for us we will be taking a quick
breather as we catch our breaths and we
will see you in time to catch the game
between Fabiana caruana and Anisha Geary
see you on the other side
foreign
some of you may remember when puzzle
Rush launched it blew the Chess World up
and it happened literally right in time
for the World Chess Championship in 2018
and all those pieces just came together
of like and it was just awesome to see
of course it was excited it was a new
feature which we hadn't done in years
and it was a really good one and we're
like Ugh we like grew chess we're done
like how cool is that I remember the
word saying like guys like after I came
down
early early 2019 like we all need to
reset let's think about how we're going
to add more features what could maybe be
something
close to puzzle Rush again because we
are never going to see growth like that
for chess again in 2018 puzzles because
the other thing that Serendipity with
was the world championship our first
feature in three years God I get anxiety
it was our first feature like those were
the dark years that Eric and I joke
about there were tears during that time
it was hard it was tough but then like
here goes puzzle Rush here comes the
world championship and here comes a
fateful dinner where I had queenies
shout out to you Hikaru take me to that
small restaurant the Isle of Man the
British Isles because hecaro picks it
because the car was a bit of a foodie
for those who don't know and that was
the dinner where I told a car that I
thought he could be the ninja of Chess
and that maybe if he gave streaming a
chance he might be surprised I spent two
and a half hours explaining what was the
online content ecosystem to Hikaru and
Sunil and Hikaru Embraces streamy partly
because puzzle Rush was such a fun
feature to stream sort of not the I
don't want to say the chipping point
because there were so many incredible
streamers who were committing to what
would become the future of what we now
know is like this incredible ecosystem
online the chess bras were like the ogs
of of committing to it you know um at
least as far as having a fully a fully
focused switch brand right and there
were there were so many others but but
we all knew and Eric Hanson I had talked
a lot at the time like we knew like the
category needed a Hikaru and we knew
that it was going to be something that
was going to take us to the next level
but I think partly the reason Hikaru
committed is because it was so easy and
fun because of puzzle rush like that was
it and then the world championship
viewers we were raiding the chess bras
and Hikaru every single day with Peak
viewership for the chess category and it
was like the Chess World peaked yeah
appeared the end of 2018. that was that
was what you asked about right we're
talking if that's all we're talking that
was in that was that was the high point
of Chess that was it but I do remember
the first time Magnus played on our site
I remember that feeling and I remember
the Goosebumps going on my arms of like
oh my goodness
that's like yeah okay I mean there's no
better chess player in the world who's
gonna ever play well maybe in the future
one day but
that was like the thing I remember the
moment where I was like oh my gosh we
have a Grand Master on our site he's
like kicking everyone's ass he's just
winning all his games what super strong
Grand Master is this
foreign
Ty cheating and we're like oh my gosh
how are we going to deal with this it's
hard to explain the whole process but
immediately right then we're like this
is going to be make or break for our
future we have to invest here and
immediately started hiring like
statistician built an amazing team
around this and we've invested so much
time money and resources just to protect
this game that we love we immediately
knew how dangerous this could be and
remember that very first cheater was
such a painful experience to see so it's
been at the core of what we've done and
it's challenging because it's not
preventable
Majestic mountains Cliffs and waterfalls
in addition to stunning geography Norway
is home to the greatest chess player who
has ever lived Magnus Carlson
since 2013 Norway has also hosted one of
the strongest chess super tournaments in
the world and it is one for which Magnus
has claimed the top prize in the last
four years can anyone stop him
this time he'll meet one of his toughest
Challenges ever at his home tournament
with nine Rivals all hungry to beat the
best
from Carlson's fiercest online rival
today in their first classical
over-the-board battle in nearly four
years Hikaru Nakamura
to the young star Carlson once
hand-picked as his most worthy
Championship opponent alireza farrugia
two more young stars are trying to
follow in his footsteps laude Beck Abdul
sotorov and kukesh domaraju
two established stars have already won a
Super tournament in 2023. Anish giri and
Fabiano caruana
two more longtime Headliners seek to
take their next turn Atop A major
tournament Wesley so and shakuria Mami
yarov
finally Carlson's Countryman and friend
ariantari rounds out the field who will
come out on top will Carlson run the
table yet again or will someone else
usurp the throne this is Norway chess
welcome welcome back and I hope you're
refreshed and ready for the final
Armageddon game of the day it's between
Anish giri and Fabiana Karana and it's
happening in a roughly six minutes and
for those people who just joined us I'm
International Master Ivanka houska and
it is a great pleasure to be calling all
the action alongside grandma said Judith
Polgar and Grandmaster David how it's
been a pleasure so far
it has been a lot of fun just non-stop
action we've been really Sports here in
the studio Judith oh absolutely I also
feel that we are really spoiled and I'm
not sure they are going to be spoiling
us more tomorrow but today it was just
amazing thing starting from the opening
until the very end and it's not the end
yeah it's certainly not the end because
we have one Armageddon game left and of
course we should remind ourselves of the
Armageddon format it's something that's
very special and very unique to Norway
chess now the players will be keeping
the same colors
white will have 10 minutes black will
have seven minutes there will be a one
second increment added after move 40
it's not much but it's a little and it's
been one and a half points for the win
and one point for a loss and the most
important thing is that black will win
if the result is a draw oh this one is
going to be exciting it's gonna be tense
it's gonna be everything and we've had a
lot of action so far in this get day I
have to say and one of the games that
really stands out as being very wild was
the match between alireza farouza and
shakare mamajarov and let's go to Ali
Raza farouza who told svera exactly what
he felt during that game
it was a crazy day I didn't expect to
win
um I was probably lost most of the times
but okay he was very nervous and like
use that factor
it's like on every board there was crazy
games going on today is that typical for
like a second day of a tournament when
people are trying to push a little more
like this no it's not typical it was
crazy day I think so it's not typical
thank you so much adidasa we look
forward to tomorrow thank you
with that victory in the classical game
it does mean that alireza gets off the
scoreboard with three points and uh one
final game remaining Anish Gary against
Fabiana caruana the in their classical
encounter it looked like Fabiana Corona
had the upper hand what are we expecting
for today's Armageddon game
well definitely we had a very exciting
game in the classical game between them
it was a seemed like a very slow opening
right it was more or less balanced
everything and then things somehow
heated up there was a Pawn gun from
anisha's position and then finally there
was a very nice kind of a very typical
idea played with the night Sacrifice by
Anish and that somehow Fabiano could not
create anything really difficult moments
I think for an age it became extra poem
with a different color Bishop but it
became a droso I think they are they are
both kind of happy to move on and let's
go for the Armageddon
yeah I've been extremely impressed I
must say by both of these two so far uh
Fabi just uh yesterday beautiful game
earlier pressing but uh never in too
much danger and Anish yesterday had a
great day too so it's so hard to predict
for a niche maybe the pressure's on him
beating Fabiano on demand even with the
time Advantage is no mean feat so uh
yeah I'm excited to get going now I'm
looking forward to this time scrambled
ahead I'm certainly looking forward to
it too and we have to remind ourselves
of today's score it was a victory for
Magnus Carlson in the Armageddon game
against Wesley so so he takes one and a
half points and for nordie Beck Abdul
sotorov it was a very Scrappy win
against Ari antari but a classical win
nonetheless and he walks away with three
points and also hikara Nakamura played
an excellent game to take three points
and a victory over gukesh and he thinks
yet to be decided between any
a much needed Victory with the white
pieces against chakra mamajarov and
there in the background I can see our
two Gladiators getting ready to fight
now
if you two were either of the player
seconds what would you be saying to your
Protege right now well
be calm lay as if there would be no
stake just focus of course you have
different strategy with white and black
because with black you want you have to
go for stability and make fast moves
don't make too risky options at the same
time with white you want to go go and
risk and do you approve of this Catalan
that Anish has employed I always approve
of the Catalan Ivanka one of the best
openings out there for white and Anish
he's a specialist he knows his stuff of
course so does Fabi and it's uh one of
the main lines of the Catalan uh there
have been a set of porn trades a set of
Bishop trades as well white has gone for
the doubled f-pawn structure which has
opened up the G file and look at White's
last move the King has shifted the white
Rook is getting ready to plant itself on
the G file and yeah we could well see an
attack from anishigiri uh White Center
is Rock Solid for now so he does have
the ability to switch sides and it's up
to Fabi to maybe kind of dampen anisha's
enthusiasm by trading pieces off a bit
later by finding some activity of his
own black is solid no weaknesses yet uh
what do you think of this well to be
honest I've played this with the black
side but I did not take on F4 really I
did not allow this that the right Pawn
is capturing on F4 I think it's
perfectly great opportunity for Anish
because it's a complicated game there
are some tactics
and but still he has to complicate
matters right because Knight E5 seems to
be a very tempting move at the same time
it means that you're exchanging a pair
of Bishops so somehow it would be
important for him to still keep the
tension as much as possible I believe
yeah and talking about keeping the
tension we see Anish take his first
pause of the game was he considers how
is he going to make some progress
Black's position looks Rock Solid and
Fabi has managed one big thing and that
is he's managed to get the light squared
Bishop outside of the pawn chain and is
active
well now actually I believe that Anish
is in in a decision making mode because
whether he keeps his Knight or the
bishop because otherwise Bishop F3 was
kind of a threat already with black and
then black would have played C6 Knight
D5 so he decided that he wants his
Knight on the board
and do you like that decision Judith is
still relatively blocked I like the
knights
especially if you want to win attack
right and if you want to cause surprises
in a short time
yeah and uh he keeps his Knights on the
board and Anish okay I'm surprised he
rushed this decision but maybe he was
just scared of some black counter play
Black was getting ready to strike out in
the center with C5 uh he's dropped back
with his Knight a set of night trades
you would think help black but still no
sign of any Queens coming off the board
white will have attacking chances no
matter what happens White's other rook
in the corner on A1 is going to slide
across they're going to double up on the
G file and you start to feel nervous as
black in these types of situations and
it's not just a king side attack that
you have to be worried about white has a
massive space Advantage as well and can
torture Fabi for quite a while you know
can stick a rook on G5 there he goes
just as I say it
well called that Rook on G5 stares
across the whole board and black has one
nice piece this Black Knight but
actually in reality it's not really
doing too much it's looking nice and
pretty but it's not got any real
substance and okay a set of one uh
nitrate there
what is Black's plan well there we can
see it Fabi makes a very committal move
breaking open the position with C5
F5 Maybe
wow five hitting the white knight
kicking it back and he makes sure that
he can capture on the C5 square with a
piece rather than a pawn which would
have wrecked his own structure now this
white Rook looks like it's a bit offside
caught on the wrong side of that last
break
now with that very impressive maneuver
it feels like Fabi is the one who is in
full control and it is the white king
that is in complete Danger
yeah one move and suddenly our whole
opinion of the position switches right
maybe it was a bit of a slip from
anishigiri to allow this little
transition maybe it was important to
bring that white rook in the corner that
doorman Turk into the game
suddenly E5 faby's not letting the pace
slip he spins so quick up to this point
to Fabi spent less than two minutes to
get here yeah but also Anish is playing
extremely fast so it seems like if they
would be playing about five versus seven
minute game
too fast do you think Judith well well
maybe at some point it would be possible
to spend a little bit more time with
white but of course it's very difficult
to adjust yourself after such a
classical game
I would switch to to a moderate fast
play right it's either you just want to
slash flash out all the moves or you
think and then maybe you're going to be
thinking too long and a big question
actually here I mean is this Rook
sacrifice that David is indicating is
that a threat can black simply get away
with capturing the pawn on F4
it's interest
ing first of all it is definitely a case
for Fabiano that he has to stop for a
moment and double check whether original
G6 is something the real threatened it's
danger and he decided that it is
yeah really nice move there I agree with
the feature chat very impressive from
Fabi just getting out of the way of that
sacrifice if you're taking this Pawn he
was either winning or losing pretty much
and I think it was wise to just avoid
any complications any sacrifices any
attacks so now what can a niche conjure
up he has to capture back with a pawn
and he has because otherwise the Queens
will get traded off and uh Anish
desperately pinning his hopes on a
potential King side attack remember
Anish is in a must-win situation
he's not hiding I think his plan very
clear-cut that H4 H5 is something that
he can hang on to
and there is not too much other options
for uh White I believe
yeah it's a bit tricky here for both
sides I think equally offside these two
nights right now they would both love to
have Knights on the king side but uh at
least fabi's creating some weight in for
his uh night there on the D3 Square
white has some weak pawns he's got to go
for it H4 on the board and now the big
question is can you do tricky moves like
H6 or no he actually plays his Rook to
attack the queen
now he's going to keep on attacking yeah
we see the first hint that Fabiano can
bully uh anishagiri here with the threat
of a repetition the threat of a draw
he's happy to repeat the White Queen
needs to find a safe Square where she
cannot get harassed by that black Rook
so I'm expecting her to drop back maybe
to the G2 Square there we go oh rookie
one was kind of something to consider
but probably that's too optimistic at
Queen G5
yes and uh here we see a question mark
attached to White's move uh it looks
very natural I think in a must-win
situation this was the only way to play
for Anish but the problem is the White
Queen therefore Pawn is vulnerable yeah
she doesn't protect her pawns the Black
Knight has come in with a gain of time
gain of tempo
yeah and uh Fabi plenty of time on the
clock under four minutes
1991 and all these three
Judy you've spotted Knight D1 today
you've spotted Knight E1 for black
wasn't there a night C1 at some stage
yesterday yesterday these are the
hardest moves in Chester See Knights to
the back rank retreating Night Moves
maybe after 91 Queen H1 is the most
wow really passive but maybe good enough
about maybe the only move yeah it's
difficult to kind of evaluate these
types of risky night moves if you don't
have too much time on the clock if I'd
be down to three minutes
smooth 31 they'll gain increment in nine
moves time
well there are a lot of Temptation for
BlackRock C4 Queen D6 really put extra
pressure on the F4 pawn and he does go
for work C4
and for Anish perhaps his only chance is
to try to press that button that says
chaos and go with it H5
it's very difficult to
recommend something other than going
Knight E2
yeah retreating and defending with
Knight E2 does not look positive right
now Fabiano looking up at the big screen
checking the number of moves until he
gets that one second increment he knows
he has plenty of time
three minutes should be enough to make
eight moves nine moves over the next few
turns and yeah retreating with the white
knight would just be so sad I think
anisha's just put his Knight on a poor
circuit unfortunately it was that F5
move earlier that really clamped down
forces forced white to kind of go all in
on this attack now but it's too slow
it is slow and uh if the Knight were to
jump into D5 then
black at the very least say I was gonna
say queen E4 oh
it's really looking
terrible for Anish yeah even if black
has to give up a pawn to get the Queens
off the board I think that would uh kind
of get to full safety so any Queen trade
white has to avoid at any cost
better to resign than on our trade of
Queens right now
okay what's what's Anish gonna do four
minutes 30 it's time Advantage
disappearing
that's the least of the problem
I believe I mean practically B2 is
hanging F4 is hanging but once F4 drops
F2 drops as well and it's not like
Black's pieces are awkwardly placed
there I mean they're primed to start
attacking the white king
you know we saw one of the featured
chats a few moments ago believing that
Anish might make a comeback and there's
still possibilities if Abby gets nervous
one slip and White's Rooks White's
pieces will flood towards the black king
but
no way through how is he gonna gamble
he's got to gamble somehow now Anish if
he kind of keeps defending it's not
going to work out well for him I think
his only chances in the queenless end
game trade-off queens and
or maybe pray
[Laughter]
you said it Judith
he's got to move that's for sure
it's
well
almost level on the clock now totally
decision time for Anish and it's a sad
decision to have to make two and a half
minutes on this one move and Counting
it shows how desperate the situation is
but you just gotta move just move the
White Queen do something
push the H Pawn do something and the
problem is the more he's looking at it
the worse it looks yeah
because he knows it's bad he just has to
I mean but deal with it that positions
happen Okay so he has moved the queen to
G3
is there a threat that's the first
question that Fabi will be asking
himself
and for me the answer is no
sorry drops
and okay F3 so at least he's saved the
second Pawn for now the white king
there's no checks there's no hits on it
yet
white
well six
ruthless from Fabi
is forcing the queen trade here or maybe
it's more than a queen trade maybe it's
just a winning tactic the white Rook is
trapped unless it takes the pawn on G6
in which case black captures on H4 yeah
okay four and drop day two and the queen
is primed to
come in and check the king
that might be the Clincher this last
move
opening up Black's King but so well
calculated from Fabi he worked this out
while Anish was thinking
and now the time Advantage is no more a
niche down on the clock as well as
losing on the board
and there we see it Anish resigns and
Fabiano wins the Armageddon game over
the black pieces very well played from
Fabiano there he he seized his
opportunity to turn the momentum in his
favor and again making a niche look
helpless very good game
he looks in Prime form Fabiana carwana
just recent times just so quick so
confident in his openings Rock Solid
which is no weaknesses to his game and
he's just racking up the results
getting those points on the board
impressive stuff
yeah I think it's very nice
you know for whatever happens right in
Armageddon the players know that it's
it's it's luck it's knowledge it's it's
the moment it's intuition but it's very
frustrating to lose like this and this
is I think the only thing what Anish can
regret that the way he lost yeah right
and that we can see today's scores
Magnus Carlsen winning in the Armageddon
portion against Wesley Soto walk away
with one and a half points for noribbeck
Abdul sotorov it was a win with the
black pieces in the classical game so he
picks up a rather valuable three points
it was also a victory for Hikaru
Nakamura who was playing his second
black in a row against 17 year old cash
and again walks away with three points
and black it was a good day for black
today because Fabiana Carona one with
the black pieces against anishagiri in
the Armageddon so that's one and a half
points and Ali Reza faruga winning with
the white pieces in in a crazy game
against Shakura mamajarov to pick up a
very valuable three points and here we
can see the standings after two rounds
and in the early lead it's Fabiana
carrona with four and a half points out
of six Hikaru Nakamura is half a point
behind on Four Points as is Nordic Abdul
satoroff and there we see Ali Reza
farouza and gukash on 50 with three
points out of six
oh such an exciting day I mean I liked
what David said is it like the players
woke up and they smell blood
I don't know what they feed them here in
Norway but it gets the juices flowing he
gets the blood pumping that's for sure
and I think it's the format as well we
really uh really enjoying this format
that they have here in Norway chess
where there's always a Victor at the end
of every day and what were your
impressions of the round oh this was a
really day where the players spoiled us
I think I can pick maybe two most
biggest highlight for me the way Magnus
turned over the almost lost position or
very bad position against
uh Wesley right and the other one is the
Atari game versus not your back because
that was really a roller coaster
on the way there in the back I mean
there were so many unexpected moments in
that game that it was it was really
interesting yeah it was quite a
fascinating day you know lots of missed
opportunities and lots of uh tactical
brilliances and of course it's Norway
chess and that means every single round
is gonna be a treat for us and let's
look at tomorrow's matchups and you can
see Magnus Carson is not having easy
ride because he will play Hikaru
Nakamura with the black pieces and it's
gonna be a battle between the teenagers
as nordebec Abdul sotorov plays with the
white pieces against alireza farooza for
Fabiana Corona he will be meeting Ari
antari and shakare mamajara faces
gookash and for Wesley so he will not
have an easy ride either as he plays old
friend Anish Gary which uh matchups are
you excited about tomorrow
oh there's one that stands out isn't
there against Magnus whether that's
decided in the classical or the
Armageddon is going to be dramatic we
know how much they want to beat each
other those two big rivals any
predictions how many armageddons do you
think we'll see
at least one that one I I think that
will go to Armageddon what about you
dude
well uh how many our marketers yes three
three
or the Maria
I I agree but I mean what a spectacular
day of Chess you've had so far it's been
absolutely amazing uh what were your
impressions of today's roller coaster
ride of events yeah I mean uh we could
barely take a moment to catch our
breaths right like that was just action
tactics tricks on uh all the boards and
I don't think we saw even one boring
game uh yeah just I'm gonna go back and
look at those in detail because some
really instructive moments as well as uh
some moments that are great for
practicing calculation
um yeah the youngsters as well just full
price of them just going all at it
learning experience for them but they're
not backing down no fear at all
and what were your impressions of the
day Judith
I think I can say that maybe it was one
of the most interesting exciting game of
my commentary career
really really a lot of exciting moments
yeah for me if I'm gonna sum it up in
one word it was wild it was a bit
everything was happening and uh of
course that brings us to the end of
today's action but still tomorrow we are
going to be in for a treat as a round
three kicks off so we will see you
tomorrow same time same place and thank
you all for watching
thank you
foreign